GOOD MORNING I WOULD LIKE
TO WELCOME ALL OF YOU THIS
MORNING TO THE SELECT COMMITTEE
ON REGIONAL TRANSPORTATION
SOLUTIONS HI MY NAME IS CHRIS
HOLDEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER REPRESENT
THE FORTY FIRST ASSEMBLY
DISTRICTS TRICK AND IT'S MY
PLEASURE TO BE ABLE TO CHAIR
OF THE SELECT COMMITTEE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
LEGISLATURE OF THE ASSEMBLY
IN PARTICULAR -- I'D LIKE
TO ALSO RECOGNIZE -- BEFORE
OR I THINK THEY ARE HOST TODAY
I WANT TO RECOGNIZE TWO OF
MY COLLEAGUES WHO REPRESENTS
A GOOD PORTION OF THE INLAND
EMPIRE -- AND BRING TREMENDOUS
LEADERSHIP -- TO THIS REGION
BUT NOT JUST THIS REASON TO
THE ENTIRE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
I'M VERY PROUD TO BE ABLE
TO SERVE WITH ELOISE RADIUS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WHO REPRESENTS
THE THE FORTY SEVENTH ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT OR AND THIS IS PART
OF HER COMMUNITY AND SO I'M ONE
IT'S IT'S PLEASURE TO HAVE HER
ON THE SELECT COMMITTEE AND --
I WILL GIVE HER AN OPPORTUNITY
-- AFTER OR INITIAL OPENING
COMMENTS TO MAKE COMMENTS BUT I
WANTED TO THINKER AND ARE GREAT
SENATOR CONNIE LEYVA WHO ALSO
REPRESENTS A SIGNIFICANT PORTION
OF THE SAN BERNARDINO INLAND
EMPIRE COMMUNITY AND WITH SO
MUCH OPPORTUNITY FOR THIS REGION
OF YOU COULD NOT HAVE BETTER
LEGISLATORS AND SACRAMENTO IN
SENATOR LEYVA AND AS SOON AS
AN ASSEMBLY MEMBER REYES AND
SO I THANK YOU BOTH FOR BEING
HERE TODAY AND BEING A PART OF
THIS CONVERSATION -- I'D ALSO
LIKE TO THANK OUR HOST CITY OF
RANCHO CUCAMONGA -- THIS IS
QUITE FRANKLY ONE OF THE MORE
ATTRACTIVE CITY HALL SO I THINK
I'VE BEEN IN A VERY LONG TIME IF
NOT EVER EVER AND THE TECHNOLOGY
AND CERTAINLY ACCESSIBILITY TO
THE TECHNOLOGY IS CERTAINLY A
PART OF THIS IS DISABILITY AND
SO WE ARE ALWAYS APPRECIATIVE
OF THE GREAT LEADERSHIP IN
THIS COMMUNITY AND WE WANT TO
RECOGNIZE TO BRING SOME OPENING
-- GREETINGS FROM FROM THE
CITY OF RANCHO CUCAMONGA
COUNCILMEMBER WHEN CANDIDATES
GOOD MORNING EVERYONE
ON BEHALF OF THE MAYOR DENNIS
MICHAEL AND OUR ENTIRE CITY
COUNCIL WELCOME TO RANCHO
CUCAMONGA WE ARE VERY VERY
HONORED AND PROUD TO HAVE YOU
HERE TODAY AND TO HOST THIS
CONVENING AND YES WE HAVE AN
OUTSTANDING STAFF WITH EXCELLENT
TECHNOLOGY AND WE'RE HAPPY
TO BE OF ASSISTANCE TO YOU
YOU KNOW IF WE'RE NOT CAREFUL
WE CAN ACTUALLY THINK OF
TRANSPORTATION AS THE BANE OF
OUR EXISTENCE ESPECIALLY
WHEN WE'RE IN OUR CARS
AND WE'RE DRIVING AND
WE'RE STUCK IN TRAFFIC OR
WERE EVEN TRYING TO GET ACROSS
TOWN TO AN APPOINTMENT BECAUSE
WE'RE LATE BUT OF COURSE IT'S
THE ON EVERYBODY ELSE'S FAULT
BECAUSE THEY'RE ON THE ROAD AND
THEY'RE KEEPING US FROM BEING ON
TIME AND SO WE HAVE TO BE AT
A FIFTY THOUSAND FOOT LEVEL
AND I BELIEVE THAT'S WHY WE'RE
ALL HERE TO DAY WE NEED TO
THINK OF IT BEYOND OUR CARS
NOT JUST US AS INDIVIDUALS
BUT THE US AS A REGION
AND HOW IMPORTANT TRANSPORTATION
ENDS IN TERMS OF CONNECTIVITY
AND MOBILITY AND WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY NOT JUST CHALLENGE
BUT AN OPPORTUNITY TO IMPACT
THIS ENTIRE REGION THROUGH
TRANSPORTATION SO I'D LIKE TO
THANK OUR ASSEMBLY MEN HOLDEN
FOR CONVENING THIS GROUP OF
POLICY MAKERS AND POWER BROKERS
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE
DECISIONS THAT TRULY ARE GOING
TO BENEFIT THIS REGION SO
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE STAY
AS LONG AS YOU LIKE HAVE DINNER
HERE AS A MATTER OF FACT WE
HAVE SOME EXCELLENT RESTAURANTS
A BEAUTIFUL VICTORIA GARDENS
AND WE'RE HAPPY TO HOST YOU AT
THIS EVENT SO ENJOY YOUR DAY
TODAY THANK YOU COUNCILMEMBER
COMMITTEE AND THIS IS A GREAT
COMMUNITY AND WE WILL TRY TO
ENCOURAGE EVERYONE TO SPEND A
FEW DOLLARS -- BEFORE THEY LEAVE
LET ME ALSO REPRESENT OUR
RECOGNIZE ROBIN HARDER --
SHE IS THE CITY COUNCIL AND
FOR THE CITY OF LA VERNE
THANK YOU COUNCILMEMBER
FOR BEING HERE BEFORE
I KIND OF GO INTO SOME OPENING
COMMENTS I JUST WANTED TO LET
ALL OF YOU MAY ALREADY KNOW
THAT THERE ARE NO PARKING
RESTRICTIONS FOR THIS HEARING
SO THAT'S ANOTHER THANK
YOUR SHOT OUT TO THE CITY OF
RANCHO CUCAMONGA THANK YOU FOR
THAT AS MANY OF YOU KNOW THE
SELECT COMMITTEE HAS A HISTORY
OF ADDRESSING TOUGH ISSUES
CONCERNING OUR DETERIORATING
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE --
WE LOOK IN TRANSIT CONNECTIVITY
AND TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN AND
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN WE ADDRESS
GOODS AND PEOPLE MOVEMENT AND
TACKLE THE CHALLENGE OF SECURING
FUNDING FOR INFRASTRUCTURE
IMPROVEMENT AND TWO THOUSAND AND
SIXTEEN LASSER HAVING SECURED
VOTER APPROVAL FOR MEASURE AND
AM IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY AND AND
SP ONE ONE STATEWIDE WE BEGAN
A DISCUSSION OF HOW TO SUSTAIN
AN AMBITIOUS AND LONG OVERDUE
PROGRAM OF NEW CONSTRUCTION
AND INFRASTRUCTURE REPAIR
WE HAVE PLENTY OF SUCCESSES
A HIGHLIGHT LIFE AND WE WILL
TALK ABOUT SOME OF THOSE TODAY
ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION FIRST
LAST MILE ADVANCES REGIONAL
NEW REVENUES TO IMPROVE LOCAL
STREETS AND SIDEWALKS FIX IT
POTHOLES LIGHT RAIL EXPANSION
JOINING TO COUNTY HOUSE POPULAR
COMMUTER RAIL LINKING THE ENTIRE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA REGION AND
MORE BUT BUT THIS IS A VERY
BIG BUT WE FACE A SIGNIFICANT
CHALLENGE TO CONTINUE FUNDING
OF IMPORTANT LOCAL AND REGIONAL
IMPROVEMENTS TODAY WE'RE
GOING TO REVIEW THE CRUCIAL
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE
IMPROVEMENTS IN OUR REGION AND
LOOK AT HOW THE LOSS OF SB ONE
FUNDS WOULD DEPRIVE OUR REGION
OF CRITICAL IMPROVEMENTS TO
ROADS AND BRIDGES AND LOCAL
ACCESS TO IMPROVE PEDESTRIAN
SAFETY AND ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION
CALIFORNIA HAS MORE THAN FIFTY
THOUSAND LANE MILES OF STATE
OWNED HIGHWAY INFRASTRUCTURE
AND ROAD MAINTENANCE UNMET
NEEDS ARE STAGGERING IN THE
NEIGHBORHOOD OF SIXTY BILLION
DOLLARS THE LEGISLATURE PASSED
S. B. ONE LAST YEAR THIS
WAS A BIPARTISAN EFFORT THIS
IN THE GOVERNOR OF THE VEHICLE
TO INVEST AND BRINGING ROADS
BRIDGES COVERTS TUNNELS AND
OVER PASSES STATEWIDE INTO GOOD
REPAIR SP ONE INVEST FIVE POINT
FOUR BILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY
OVER THE NEXT SIX DECADE TO
FIX CALIFORNIA'S TRANSPORTATION
SYSTEMS IT IS ALREADY ADDRESSING
BACKLOG OF REPAIRS AND UPGRADES
WHILE ENSURING A CLEANER AND
MORE SUSTAINABLE SYSTEM FOR THE
FUTURE THE FUNNY TRANSPORTATION
PACKAGE THE REST EVERYONE IS
HAVING A POWERFUL POSITIVE
IMPACT ON THE FORTY FIRST
DISTRICT WHICH I REPRESENT WITH
OVER NINETY ONE PROJECTS FUNDED
AND THROUGHOUT MY DISTRICT
STREET IT IS ALREADY IMPROVING
ROAD SAFETY FILLING POTHOLES
AND REPAIRING LOCAL STREETS
IN AROUND THE SAN GABRIEL
VALLEY SP ONE INCLUDES TWO
HUNDRED MILLION IN MATCHING
FUNDS FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
TO ENSURE THAT COMMUNITIES
GET TO DECIDE WHAT PROJECTS
OR MOST IMPORTANT TO THEM
THESE FUNDS ARE PROTECTED BY A
VOTER APPROVED CONSTITUTIONAL
AMENDMENT PROPOSITION SIXTY
NINE PASSED ON THIS YEAR'S YOUR
PRIMARY BALLOT BUT PROPOSITION
SIX ON THE NOVEMBER BALLOT
WOULD REPEAL REVISIONS OF SP
ONE ONE TODAY OUR PANELISTS WILL
ADDRESS THEIR CONCERNS WITH THE
POTENTIAL LOSS OF SB ONE FUN
ONCE THERE WILL BE A DISCUSSION
OF REGIONAL PLANNING AND THE
ROLE SECURE FUNDING PLAYS
AN ADVANCE AND THOSE EFFORTS WE
WILL CONTINUE DISCUSSION I CAN
ACTIVITY BETWEEN OUR VARIOUS
TRANSIT MODES AND HOW TO MOST
EFFECTIVELY MOVE PASSENGERS
TO DEFINE DESTINATIONS AND OR
TO A FISHING CONNECTORS TO THE
DESIRED DESTINATIONS I'M LOOKING
FORWARD TO A PREVIEW OF AN INTER
COUNTY OWNING STUDY LOOKING
AT THESE VARIOUS QUESTIONS
LOCAL LEADERS AND ESPECIALLY
THE EFFORTS OF THE ONTARIO MAYOR
PRO TEM ALLEN WALKING -- WERE
SUCCESSFUL IN REGAINING LOGAN
FROM CONTROL OF THE ONTARIO
INTERNATIONAL AIRPORT LAST YEAR
I COMMENTED THAT I COMMITTED
IT WE MIGHT BEGIN DISCUSSIONS
OF CONNECTING PASSENGERS TO
THE AIRPORT WORK AND THAT IS
OCCURRING NOW AND I THINK ALLEN
ALLEN WILL UPDATE US ON THOSE
DISCUSSIONS WHEN WE INCREASE
BECAUSE CONNECTIVITY BETWEEN OUR
COMMUNITIES WE CONNECT PEOPLE TO
JOBS AND OPPORTUNITIES AND OUR
REGION ENGINES IN OUR REGIONAL
ECONOMY BENEFITS THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER IN ASSEMBLY MEMBER REYES
FORTY SEVENTH DISTRICT JOBS ARE
BEING CREATED BY THE INVESTMENTS
OF SB ONE FUNDS THESE LOCAL
IMPROVEMENTS INCLUDE MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS DEDICATED TO LOCAL ROAD
IMPROVEMENTS IN THE FORTY SEVEN
INCLUDING ROAD REPAIR TUTORS
ROADS IN NORTH WILMINGTON ROAD
MAINTENANCE AND REHABILITATION
OF VARIOUS STREETS IN RIALTO
AND MORE IMPORTANT IMPROVEMENTS
AND FONTANA AND RANCHO CUCAMONGA
WILL BENEFIT FROM THE DOLLARS
AWARDED THE CITY TO CONSTRUCT
THAT A WANDA AVENUE GRADE
SEPARATIONS THIS PROJECT WILL
AVERT LONG DELAY AT THE CURRENT
ON GRADE REAL ROAD CROSSINGS
AND IMPROVE THE FLOW OF FREE
NOT ONLY WILL THIS PROJECT'S
WHO'S THE LOCAL ECONOMY BUT ALSO
THOSE PUBLIC SAFETY BY REMOVING
CHRONIC OBSTACLES FOR FIRST
RESPONDERS -- MANY BENEFITS TO
LOCAL COMMUNITIES IN THE SAN
GABRIEL VALLEY AND THE INLAND
EMPIRE AND I'M EXCITED TO MOVE
FOR WITH OUR DISCUSSIONS THIS
MORNING MEMBERS WE WILL HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO YOU IN A DAY ON
EACH PANEL -- ONCE WE'VE HEARD
FROM ALL THE LOCAL CHANNELS I
WILL INVITE THE PUBLIC TO COME
FORWARD FOR COMMON ELEMENTS
OF THE BEFORE I INTRODUCE
OUR FIRST PANEL I'D LIKE TO
TURN TO OUR MEMBERS TO SEE
IF THEY HAVE ANY OPENING
COMMENTS AND I WILL AGAIN --
SO CABLE -- WITH --
ASSEMBLY MEMBER IS
THANK YOU SO MUCH IT'S
AN HONOR TO BE PART OF THOSE
SELECT COMMITTEE WITH OUR CHAIR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHRIS HOLDEN
I REALLY ENJOYED MY FIRST
TERM OF THE STATE ASSEMBLY
WORKING ON SO MANY PROJECTS THAT
BENEFIT THE INLAND EMPIRE I I
LOVE REFERRING TO SENATOR CONNIE
LEYVA IS MY FAVORITE SENATOR SHE
AND I REPRESENT THE SAME AREAS
HERE I DON'T REPRESENT RANCHO
CUCAMONGA BYE BYE DISTRICT
AGAIN IN FONTANA AND GOES
EAST TO RIALTO TO THE WEST
SIDE DECEMBER DINO -- COLTON
AND GRANTORS AND SOME OF THE
UNINCORPORATED AREAS INCLUDING
BLOOMINGTON AND MOST GORY
I DO I ALSO WANT TO LOOK TO
THE LIST OF THOSE WHO WILL BE
PRESENTING AND I AM LOOKING
FORWARD TO HEARING FROM ALL OF
YOU I AM ALSO LOOKING FORWARD
TO HEARING YOUR TESTIMONY ON
THE IMPORTANCE OF MOBILITY
CONNECTIVITY AND REGIONAL
PLANNING AND THAT THE HOW THESE
INTERSECT WITH INCLUSIVITY
COMMITTEE AND EQUITY THE
DISTRICT I REPRESENT FOR THE
MOST PART IS IN THE HEART OF
SAN BERNARDINO COUNTY AND WE
HAVE MANY CHALLENGES WITH
POVERTY LOW PARTICIPATION
CIVIC ENGAGEMENT RIGHT ACCESS
TO A GOOD PAYING JOBS POOR AIR
QUALITY AND LACK OF GOOD PUBLIC
TRANSIT ALTHOUGH WE'VE HAD GREAT
IMPROVEMENTS AND WHEN I PLUG
THOSE ON MY CELL OF RECORDS
OTHER WE'VE HAD THESE PROBLEMS
AS WELL AS OTHERS WE'RE MAKING
PROGRESS IN SOLVING MANY OF THEM
THEM IT IS IMPORTANT THAT
WE CONTINUE THE CONVERSATION
ON HOW WE EXPAND PUBLIC TRANSIT
TO THE END AND THOSE WERE
DOING THIS IT'S IMPORTANT THAT
WE CONSIDER TWO THINGS THAT I
CONSIDERED EXTREMELY IMPORTANT
MAKING SURE THAT THE PROJECTS
BEING PROPOSED OR IN DEVELOPMENT
BENEFIT TO EVERYONE ONE IN SAN
BERNARDINO COUNTY NOT JUST A
FEW AREAS AND MAKING SURE
THAT WE LOOK TO SEE HOW THESE
PROJECTS THAT LIVE LIVED THE
LOCAL ECONOMIES IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT TO ME THAT WE HAVE A
RENEWED FOCUS ON HOW WE SPEND
THESE FUNDS THAT ARE BEING
USED TO BUILD BILL PROJECT US
LOCAL PROJECTS SIX SHOULD USE
LOCAL BUSINESSES AND LOCAL
LABOR TO PLANNING BUILDINGS
TRANSPORTATION PROJECTS THE
EFFORTS THAT THAT THAT WILL
THAT WILL KEEP OUR LOCAL TAX
DOLLARS LOCAL AND HELP US WITH
LIVED IN OUR LOCAL ECONOMIES
AS NOTED EARLIER BY PROVIDING
THESE GOOD PAYING JOBS FOR OUR
RESIDENTS IN ADDITION IT WILL
HELP CREATE A TWELVE WELL IN
OUR COMMUNITIES I'M LOOKING
FORWARD TO THE DISCUSSIONS
AND I ALSO WANT TO ECHO THE
COMMENTS FROM ASSEMBLYMEMBER
CHAIR HOLDEN REGARDING ALL
YES YES ONE ONE BENEFIT TO OUR
COMMUNITY JUST LAST WEEK WE HAD
A PRESS CONFERENCE IN COLTON
AND PRESENTED THEM WITH THE
CHECKS WHICH REPRESENTS WHAT
THE CITY OF COLTON ALONE WILL
BE RECEIVING WHICH WAS ALMOST
ONE POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
IN THE IN THIS YEAR I'M REALLY
EXCITED ABOUT THE PROJECT THAT
COLTON HAS UNDERGONE AS WELL
AS RIALTO FONTANA AND ALL
OF THE CITIES THAT I REPRESENT
DONE THESE ARE IMPORTANT TIME
AND I SEE PROGRESS AND I SEE
THE HOPE IN THE THE FACES
OF SO MANY IN THE COMMUNITY
ESPECIALLY WHEN THEY SEE THE
THINGS ARE REALLY HAPPENING
AND AND AGAIN I LOOK FORWARD
TO TODAY'S TESTIMONY ABOUT
EVERYTHING ELSE SO WE GET
TO DO TO HELP CONNECT OUR
COMMUNITIES THANK YOU THANK YOU
THANK YOU THIS COMMITTEE
IS -- ALSO REPRESENTED TODAY
BY SENATOR LEYVA WHICH MAKES
THIS A BICAMERAL SELECT
COMMITTEE AND SO WELCOME STUDENT
WHO LEYVA THANK YOU CHAIR
HOLDEN A GOOD MORNING EVERYONE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HOLDEN THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR INVITING ME IT'S
GREAT TO BE HERE TRANSPORTATION
IS ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL UP AND
DOWN THE STATE BUT ESPECIALLY IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA I ALSO WANT
TO THANK ALL OF THE STAKEHOLDERS
INCLUDING THE TRANSPORTATION
AGENCIES FOR THE TREMENDOUS
WORK BEING DONE TO REVITALIZE
AND GROW THE TRANSPORTATION
NETWORK ACROSS THE INLAND EMPIRE
TOGETHER EITHER WE HAVE DONE AN
INCREDIBLE JOB OF IDENTIFYING
OUR NEEDS SENDING A CLEAR VISION
FOR A MODERN TRANSPORTATION
SYSTEM AND PUTTING THE DOLLARS
A PLACE TO ACCOMPLISH OUR GOALS
AS YOUR SENATOR I REPRESENT
SEVERAL DIVERSE AREAS IN THE
INLAND EMPIRE WITH WE UNIQUE
TRANSPORTATION NEEDS AND
POSSIBILITIES MY HOPE IS THAT
WE BUILD OUT A NETWORK THAT
WORKS FOR EVERYONE FROM WEST TO
EAST AND EAST TO WEST SO THAT
EVERYONE IN THE INLAND EMPIRE
CAN ACCESS AND AFFORD AFFORDABLE
TRANSPORTATION AND GET TO
WHERE THEY NEED AND WANT TO
GO A SUCCESSFUL TRANSPORTATION
NETWORK WILL REQUIRE US TO
THINK BEYOND OUR GOVERNMENT
BOUNDARIES AND FOSTER FAIR AND
REPRESENTATIVE PARTNERSHIPS I
WOULD LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT SOME
OF OUR SUCCESSES FOR BRINGING
FUNDING TO THE REGION SB ONE
IN SB ONE COMPETITIVE DOLLARS
ALONE NOT INCLUDING THE FORMULA
DOLLARS GOING TO CITIES AND
COUNTIES WE'RE INVESTING OVER
THREE BILLION DOLLARS IN OUR
ROADS AND HIGHWAYS WITH AN
ADDITIONAL STATE INVESTMENT
OF THREE HUNDRED MILLION TO
THE GOLD LINE TO EXTEND RAIL
SERVICE WILL CONTINUE TO CONNECT
OUR RESIDENTS AND BUSINESSES
TO THE BROADER HONOR SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA REGION THE GOLD
LINE PROJECT ALSO SERVES AS ONE
OF OUR TEST MODELS FOR SHARED
GOVERNANCE AND HOW WE USE THE
RESULTS REGION CAN SUCCESSFULLY
AND EQUITABLY SERVE ALL OF
OUR RESIDENTS THROUGH S. S.
CTA'S VISION ALONG WITH LOCAL
TAXPAYER SUPPORT WE ARE BRINGING
DOWN SEVENTY FIVE MILLION FOR
THE REDLANDS PASSENGER RAIL
PROJECT THAT WILL CONNECT
DOWNTOWN SAN BERNARDINO AND
THE CITY OF REDLANDS TOGETHER
WE HAVE SECURED FUNDING
TO IMPROVE THE SEVENTY ONE
EXPRESS RIGHT THANK GOD AND
I TEN AND I FIFTEEN INTERCHANGE
ADDITIONALLY FUNDS ARE BEING
DEDICATED TO A TWENTY TWENTY
EIGHT VISION FOR OUR METROLINK
SYSTEM WE ARE WORKING WASTE WEST
AND WEST TO EAST TO CONNECT OUR
REGION AND LOCAL ECONOMIES ALL
OF THESE FUNDS AND PROJECT'S
HIGHLIGHT HELP FOCUS WE HAD WE
BEEN ON ALIGNING DOLLARS WITH
OUR PROGRESSIVE TRANSPORTATION
VISION FOR THE REJECTION I
UNDERSTAND A VERY SIGNIFICANT
ISSUES THAT WE MUST ADDRESS
INCLUDING SHARED GOVERNANCE
IN ORDER FOR SYSTEMS TO BE
SUCCESSFUL I LOOK FORWARD TO
HEARING FROM ALL OF YOU TODAY
AND FIGURE OUT HOW WE CAN
CONTINUE TO WORK TOGETHER TO
MAKE NOT ONLY THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA BETTER BUT THE INLAND
EMPIRE AND I WOULD IS WITH
WE HAVE DIFFERENT REPRESENTATION
IN -- SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA THAN
WE'VE HAD BEFORE I THINK YOU
HAVE TO REPRESENTATIVES HERE
IN MYSELF AND ASSEMBLYMEMBER
RADIOS THAT REALLY CARE ABOUT
TRANSPORTATION AND FIGURING
OUT PARTNERSHIPS SO WE'RE
VERY HAPPY TO BE HERE TODAY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER HOLDEN THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR HAVING US MY
PLEASURE AND AS MUCH AS THIS
WILL BE INFORMATIVE FOR THOSE OF
YOU WHO ARE HERE TO LEARN --
IT WILL ALSO BE INFORMATIVE FOR
US AS WELL SO WE LOOK FORWARD
TO THE THE CONVERSATION --
RIGHT AND LET ME JUST -- ALSO
-- DO APPROPRIATE SHOUT OUT TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MARC STEINORTH
WAS DISTRICT WE ARE YEAH YEAH
AND -- HE HAS -- HE'S NOT GOING
TO BE ABLE TO JOIN US TODAY
BUT IT'S VERY -- APPRECIATIVE
OF OUR BEING HERE AND BEING
IN A POSITION TO SHARE SOME
IMPORTANT INFORMATION WITH WITH
-- CONSTITUENTS THROUGHOUT THIS
REGION BUT CERTAINLY HERE IN
THE CITY OF RANCHO CUCAMONGA
A SO IF I COULD INTRODUCE OUR
FIRST PANEL -- THESE ARE ALL
OF FOLKS WHO ARE VERY WELL
KNOWN IN THE INDUSTRY AND BRING
A TREMENDOUS -- DEGREE OF YOU
-- AND SIGHED AND UNDERSTANDING
AND VISIONS AND -- WHICH I
THINK WILL ALL BENEFIT FROM
TODAY THIS FIRST FIRST A PANEL
TOPIC WILL BE ON REGIONAL
PLANNING AND IT'S MY PLEASURE
-- AND I WILL CALL YOU UP
YOUR BIO AND THEN IF YOU WOULD
JUST WHERE ARE THEY WORKING
WRITER RIGHT THERE OKAY OKAY
SO OUR FIRST -- PANELISTS IS
HIS SON CROWDER ON --
MISTER GOD HAS SERVED AS THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA SESSION
OF ASSOCIATION OF GOVERNMENT
SINCE EARLY TWO THOUSAND EIGHT
HE HAS WORKED FOR LA METRO AND
THE SOUTH COAST AIR QUALITY
MANAGEMENT DISTRICT'S A SON
ATTENDED SCHOOL ADD SOME
PROJECT -- -- UNIVERSITY
CITY OR WHERE HE RECEIVED
BOTH A BACHELOR'S AND MASTER'S
DEGREE IN CIVIL IN INDUSTRIAL
ENGINEERING HE ALSO HOLDS
A MASTER'S DEGREE IN CIVIL
ENGINEERING FROM UCLA AND A PHD
CANDIDACY AND URBAN PLANNING
AND TRANSPORTATION FROM USC
SO USC AND UCLA -- SO NOT SURE
HOW YOU RECONCILE THAT BILL WILL
WE WELCOME YOU AND WE ALSO
WANT TO SAY CONGRATULATIONS
ON YOUR NEW ASSIGNMENT DOWN
IN SAN DIEGO REGION THAT'S AND
WE'RE REALLY LOOKING FORWARD TO
GREAT THINGS DOWN THERE -- WE'RE
NOT QUITE SURE HOW YOU CAN LEAVE
THIS LOVELY COMMUNITY -- THE
REGION TO GO TO SAN DIEGO BUT I
GUESS BEING NEAR OR NICE
YOU FOR BEING HERE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH -- CHAIRMAN --
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SENATE THERE
IT'S GOOD TO SEE YOU AND HASAN
IF YOU COULD COULD GET GIVE
ME JUST A SECOND I'M GONNA
INTRODUCE THE OTHER PANELISTS
AND SO WHEN YOU'RE DONE AND
ALLOW EACH ONE OF YOU TO JUST
MAKE YOUR WAY TO THE PODIUM
-- -- OUR A SECOND
-- -- PRESENTER WILL BE
HAPPY BILLION WOULD BE IS THE
CHIEF EXECUTIVE OFFICER OF
THE FOOTHILL GOLD LINE IS A
GRADUATE OF THE UNIVERSITY OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA A B. DOES
WORK FOR THE FOR THE -- GOLD
LINE EXTENSION CONSTRUCTION
AUTHORITY FOR SIXTEEN YEARS
A B. PREVIOUSLY SERVED AS
CHIEF OF STAFF OUT OF LA METRO
-- DURING HIS TENURE AT THE
FORT HILL GOLDLINE OVERSAW THE
CONSTRUCTION OF LOS ANGELES
TO PASADENA SEGMENT MET AND
SUCCESSFULLY COMPLETED THE
PASSING A TO ZEUS A SEGMENT
HE LOOKS FORWARD TO COMPLETING
THE CLAREMONT SEGMENT ON
TIME AND UNDER BUDGET AND I
SHOULD SAY ALSO TO MONTCLAIR
OUR THIRD CENTER DR LOUISE
THAT SETS BEDS VOTERS FOR
THAT'S WHAT FOR A DOCTOR GOD'S
WORDS WERE IS THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE STRATEGIC
GROWTH COUNSEL'S A STATE AGENCY
THAT BRINGS TOGETHER MULTIPLE
AGENCIES AND DEPARTMENTS AND
SUPPORT SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITIES
EMPHASIZING STRONG ECONOMIES
SOCIAL EQUITY AND THE
ENVIRONMENTAL STEWARDSHIP PRIOR
TO JOINING STC LOUISE WAS
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF THE OFFICE
OF PLANNING AND RESEARCHING
GOVERNOR JERRY BROWN'S OFFICE
WHERE SHE WORKED ON THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THE INTEGRATED
CLIMATE ADAPTATION RESILIENCY
PROGRAM LOUISE IS A GRADUATE
OF MIT AND RECEIVED A PHD
AND ENERGY AND RESOURCES FROM
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
BERKELEY GO BEARS A SAUCE ON
THANK YOU -- CHAIR HOLDEN --
GOOD MORNING TO ALL OF YOU
I WOULD SAY -- I'M GONNA TELL
YOU A SECRET THAT I HOPE YOU
DON'T TELL ANYBODY THAT THIS
IS MY FAVORITE COMMITTEES OF ALL
COMMITTEES ARE SACRAMENTO --
IT IS A MY
PLEASURE TO BE HERE MIGHT LISTEN
WAS THE SHORTEST COMMUTE TO
WORK I EVER HAD THEY LIVED ON
MY SHOW COME ON GUYS SO SO WAS
NICE TO KNOW THAT -- MY COMMUTE
IS JUST JOKING LOCAL CITIES
BUT I'M GRATEFUL FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP SO I'M GRATEFUL
FOR SEEING YOU HERE IN THIS
CATEGORY JIM AS YOU DON'T
GO TO THE NEXT SLIDE PLEASE --
WE ARE A SIX COUNTY
REGION UNDER THE NINETY ONE
CITIES NINETEEN MILLION PEOPLE
-- ALMOST HALF OF THE
STATE STATE AND OFTEN TIMES
THE STATE FORGETS THAT --
SIXTEENTH LARGEST ECONOMY
IN THE WORLD WILL AND
WITH THIS IS GOOD NEXT WITH
THIS IN ON THAT IS ALL KINDS
OF CHALLENGES AND OPPORTUNITIES
SO IF I WANT TO ASK YOU
TO PICK A CHALLENGES FROM THE C.
-- -- -- I PERSONALLY
WOULDN'T THINK HOUSE HOUSING
TO BE ONE OF OUR BIGGEST
CHALLENGES I THINK IF ONE
HOW HOW DO WE KEEP OUR
KIDS WHO WE SPEND A LOT
OF MONEY IF YOU'RE KIDDING
HERE AND SPECIALLY
-- IN AREAS LIKE PLAN
RIGHT NOW -- RESIDENTS
A NINETY EIGHT COUNTY HAVE TO
SPEND MORE THAN HALF OF THEIR
INCOME COME FOR HOUSE HOUSE
AND PEOPLE SAY WELL IT SEES
IT IS JUST THOSE MORE HOUSE
HOUSE I SAW THAT THE CITY'S
-- THERE WERE WELL OVER A
HUNDRED BILLS IN HOUSING IN
SACRAMENTO LAST LEGISLATIVE
SESSION AND I ANY
AVIS BACK BY THE AUTHORS OF THE
BILL AT WORK WITH THE WITH FROM
THE BILLS I THINK THERE HAVE
GREAT INTENTIONS BUT BUT
I DON'T NECESSARILY THINK THESE
BILLS IS GONNA SOLVE ALL HOUSING
RICE RICE AND I QUOTE PRICING
BECAUSE IT IS A HOUSING CRISIS
AND I'M NOT TALKING ABOUT
HOMELESSNESS SOME TALKING
ABOUT JUST SIMPLY MIDDLE CLASS
FAMILIES BEING ABLE TO AFFORD
HOUSE -- I I BELIEVE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER NAY AS HE MENTIONS COLOR
SEVENTEEN PERCENT OF ALL KIDS
IN THIS CATEGORY IF YOU LIVE
IN THE PUBLIC BUT A SHAMEFUL
STATISTICS FOR THE GREATEST
NATION ON AND A FOREST IS THAT
HAS THE SIXTH LARGEST ECONOMY
IN THE WORLD -- TRANSPORTATION
-- YOU KNOW CONGESTION IT IS A
GIVEN YOU CAN WE MANAGEMENT AND
AND THAT'S THAT'S WHAT THE THE
TOPIC THAT IS GONNA BE CAN WE
MANAGE CONGESTION IF NEXT
LIST SO WE DEVELOP WHAT'S
K. WHAT'S CALLED THE REGIONAL
TRANSPORTATION PLAN SUSTAINABLE
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT THE NIGHT
IT'S A TRANSPORTATION IS NOW
FOR THE SIX COUNTIES THE HUNDRED
AND NINETY ONE CITIES AND IT'S A
VERY EXPENSIVE IT'S OVER
A HALF A BILLION DOLLARS OVER
THE NEXT TWENTY FIVE YEARS
AND FOR THE FIRST TIME IN A
LONG TIME I AM HAPPY TO SAY THAT
THAT THIS PLANET SP ONE ONE
WILL BE FULLY FUNDED ON
AND I'M GONNA TALK ABOUT THE TO
THE NEXT LINE NEXT WEEK'S ONE
IN ICE WE WHEN YOU
MENTION IT IS TO BE ABLE
PEOPLE TAKE THIS VERY
LIGHTLY FIRST OF ALL A
I SHOULD HAVE SAID IT IS IN
THE BEGINNING OF MY PRESIDENCY
THE PRESIDENT OF CCAC I
BROUGHT THEM OF ON TERRIO YOU'LL
ISLAND WHAT NOT IS HERE WHAT
I'M SPEAKING TO YOU ABOUT THE
ONE I'M SPEAKING BECAUSE ALMOST
SURPRISED BY THIS GUIDE TO SAY
THAT WE SUPPORTED THIS BEFORE
WE ARE DEFINITELY AGAINST
THE REPEAL OF HISTORY ONE
I KNOW SOME OF YOU MIGHT FEEL
DIFFERENTLY BUT BUT I
BELIEVE IF WE DO CALL IS IS ONE
THIS WOULD BE ONE OF THE BIGGEST
MISTAKES CALIFORNIANS MAKE
IT'S NOT JUST A FIVE POINT FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS THAT'S JUST
GONNA BRING IT WILL FIX THE
HOW IS IT IS THE IMPORTANCE OF
THE HIGHWAY SYSTEM THEM TO OUR
ECONOMY IT IS IS ESPECIALLY
FOR AREAS LIKE MAN AND
WE NEED MORE OR LESS MOST MOST
LESS WE HAVE
TWENTY THREE HUNDRED BRIDGES AND
STALKING CALIFORNIA THAT'S HOW
TO CLASSIFY EFFICIENT SERVICES
FUNCTIONING DEFICIENT ARE
OBSOLETE AND IF WE DON'T
FIX THOSE THOSE GOD FOR BID
BID IT BECOMES A PROBLEM
SO WHEN WE TALK ABOUT THIS BE
ONE WE HAVE BEEN GETTING BACK
OUT OF THE FACT THAT THIS IS
ABOUT AND INFRASTRUCTURE THAT'S
SO IMPORTANT TO THE ECONOMY IT'S
ABOUT JOBS JOBS -- I AM
VERY HOPEFUL THAT CALIFORNIANS
WILL BE CHECKED IF YOU CALL OUR
WE HAD CAG I DON'T LOB LOBBY
WE CANNOT LOBBY LOBBY BUT
WE'D YOU CAN AND WE NEED
YOU GETTING A LOT LIVE AROUND
THE STATE FALLING APART
SP ONE AND ITS CONTINUATION
AND WE JUST TALK ABOUT THE PLAN
THE PLAN CANNOT BE FULLY FUNDED
IF WE DON'T HAVE ISSUES IF
YOU TAKE FIVE POINT POINT FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS OVER TWENTY FIVE
YEARS THAT'S OVER A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY BILLION DOLLARS AND YOU
CANNOT HAVE A PLAN THAT'S NOT
FULLY FUNDED ATTORNEY NOW NOW
WE ARE EXPERIENCING A
POPULATION SHIFTS AND SOFT
NOW THE LARGEST GENERATION
IN THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA
TODAY IS THE MULLIN ENGINE IF
AND I'M AND EXHIBITS AND
MILLIONS I HAVE TO A TOM SO I
CAN TELL YOU ANYTHING YOU WANT
TO KNOW BUT THEY ARE HITTING THE
DIFFERENCES WISH WE DON'T KNOW
LEARNING A LOT ABOUT THAT
BEHAVIOR AND IT'S IN FACT THAT
CONSTITUTION AND HOUSING CHOICES
BUT THAT HEAVIER IS IT IS
NOT CLEAR BUT IT'S DIFFERENT
ON THE BEDROOMS THAT DELAYING
THE MISSING THAT DELAYING THE
-- GETTING LICENSES THEY'RE
DELAYING THEIR -- GETTING
MANAGEMENT OF THE NOT HAVING
AS MANY KIDS ALL OF THAT WILL
IMPACT THE FUTURE AND THE AND
THE REASON I'M MENTIONING THAT
IS BECAUSE WE ARE PLANNING FOR
THE FUTURE GO TO THE NEXT SLIDE
AND THEN WHAT THE SAM'S I WILL
HAVE A GROWING NUMBER OF SENIOR
CITIZEN THIS OUR SIXTY
FIVE PLUS IN THE NEXT TWENTY
YEARS OF THE SEASON WILL MAKE
UP ABOUT TWENTY PERCENT OF THE
POPULATION EIGHTEEN PERCENT OF
THE POPULATION TO BE EXACT TEN
THOUSAND UNLESS WE COME SIXTY
FIVE AND ALL THAT EVERY DAY
AND THAT ALSO HAS AN APPLICATION
ON TRANSPORTATION AND HOUSING
GO TO THE NEXT LIFE SO
WHY THE MILLIONS THAT IMPORTANT
I MEAN VIETNAMESE RACING IS
THE THE SMALL A BLUEPRINT
FOOTPRINT IN THE SHARE ECONOMY
THE INTERNET OF EVERYTHING
BIG DATA DATA LIVE ANYTHING
WHAT DOES NOT ONLY FOR ALL
OF US WHEN WE PLAN FOR THE
FUTURE -- IT'LL -- WILL
ALLOW FINISHED LET'S WATCH
-- I VIDEO BY THE MOMENT IN
AS A MILLENNIAL I'M PART OF
THE MOST ADVANCED COP OF HUMANS
AT OUR SPECIES HAS EVER SEEN
ASSOCIATE WITH THEM IN PERSON
ANYMORE AND I CAN SAY WITH
CONFIDENCE I HAVE LITERALLY
NEVER HELD EYE CONTACT WITH
ANYONE HOW OLD MY I'M
FIFTY FIVE INTO MY BIRTHDAY
AND THIRTY THREE BUT AS A
MILLENNIAL I DON'T I TEN
OF FIVE WITHOUT A HITCH IT
IS DISCRIMINATION TO THINK
THAT I'M AS OLD AS MY AGE
NOW I'M SIXTY FIVE WHICH
MEANS I SHOULD QUALIFIED TO GET
SOCIAL SECURITY CHECKS EVERY
MONTH NOT WHEN I ORDER SOMETHING
OFF AMAZON IT ME OFF THAT IT
TAKES UNTIL THE NEXT DAY FOR
A TERRORIZED ME WHAT KIND OF
THE S. IS THAT THAT I HAVE TO
WAIT ALMOST TWENTY FOUR HOURS
TO GET MY NEW COLD BREW COFFEE
MAKER ONE TIME I STARTED
A PETITION AGAINST AMAZON
BUT I GOT TIRED OF ALL THE
WORK IT ENTAIL BEFORE I SENT
IT OUT TO ANYONE BUT STILL
WHEN I WAS A KID I ALWAYS
WON THE GOLD MEDAL IN THE
SCHOOL'S TRACK TEAM I WAS ONLY
THE EIGHTEEN FASTEST KID BY
ALWAYS WON THE GOLD MEDAL SO
DID EVERYONE ELSE ON THE TEAM
AND THE OPPOSING TEAM BECAUSE
WE WERE ALL THE BASS WHAT THAT
TAUGHT ME IS THAT HARD WORK AND
DETERMINATION ARE SEVERE FORMS
OF ABUSE I ONLY THAT I DON'T
NEED TO PUT EFFORT INTO BEING
GREAT AT SOMETHING BECAUSE I
CAN JUST HAVE PEOPLE TELL ME
THAT I'M GREAT AT THAT SOMETHING
THAT I'M GREAT IN EVERYTHING
I DO IT ALSO TAUGHT ME THAT
ME AND MY FAMILY CAN FILE A
LAWSUIT AGAINST ANYONE WHO
DOESN'T GIVE ME A GOLD MEDAL
I HAVE EIGHTY SEVEN VOICE
MAILS I HAVEN'T CHECKED IN
AND WON'T BECAUSE I'M APPALLED
WHEN PEOPLE CALL ME WITHOUT
TEXTING ME FIRST TO SEE IF I CAN
CALL ME IT'S SO INCONSIDERATE
OKAY SO THEY WANT THINGS
YESTERDAY NOT TOMORROW
THE THE THE SPEED OF --
AND AN OFTEN TIME I TALK ABOUT
OKAY SO WHAT TRANSPORTATION
CHOICES ARE THEY GONNA HAVE
THAT'S DIFFERENT WELL THERE MOST
LIKELY TO -- USE OF THEM WAS
THAT THAT BABY BOOMERS MILLION
JEWS AND THAT'S WHAT IS A FAIR
SOME LOST MILES BECOMES REALLY
COMMITTEE THEN THE THE -- BUT
A LIST GENERATION THAT MADE ME
THAT THAT'S A TRANSPORTATION
DEMAND SERVICES SO IMPORTANT
YOU KNOW WHEN WHEN -- BUT I
LEFT IT THERE WOULDN'T WOULDN'T
HEAR BEFORE NINETEEN NINETY FIVE
AND WHEN THEY HAVE BEEN IN
NINETEEN NINETY FIVE MANY OF THE
A POLICY MAKERS AND
GOVERNMENT ENTITIES WHERE WHAT
CONFUSION WHAT TO DO ABOUT
BUT BUT THIS IS THIS IS A FAST
PROFESSIONAL SOLUTION OF THE
TWENTIETH CENTURY WHERE --
IT'S NO LONGER ACTION CAPITOL
WATER LEFT I KNOW BUT I LEFT
HAVE A HUGE IMPLICATIONS FOR
THE FUTURE OF TRANSPORTATION
SYSTEM MANY TIMES AGENCIES
AROUND THE COUNTRY RIGHT
NOW I'M LOOKING AT THIS AS A
VIABLE OPTION AS PART OF THE
PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION SYSTEMS
I WILL TELL YOU THAT THAT --
WHEN PEOPLE ASK ME SO WHAT
DO WE DO TO MAKE SURE PEOPLE
LIVE THAT CAR AND TAKE OTHER
ALTERNATIVES WELL WELL MY
NO YOU'RE GONNA HEAR FROM
EXPERTS IN THE AREA AND OUR
LADIES HE HAD ON HIM WHEN
I COOK A LOT YOU KNOW IF WE
WANT PEOPLE TO KEEP THEIR CARS
WHEN THEY NEED TO MAKE PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION CONVENIENT
WE NEED TO GET THE PEOPLE TO
THEIR STATIONS FROM THEIR HOUSES
AND FROM THAT LAST STATION TO
THEIR DESTINATION FOR THE JOB
AND HOW DO I MAKE IT CONVENIENT
BY INVESTORS TING IN THE FIRST
AND LAST MILE ITEM NUMBER WE
STARTED WITH METRO -- WENT
WHEN I WAS THERE DOING WAS CAT
AGAIN MITCHELL DOING TOGETHER
OFFENDED SOME LAST MINUTE STUDY
AND WE NEED TO RESPOND TO THIS
IN ADDITION TO THIS WEB BECAUSE
UNLESS YOU MAKE IT CONVENIENT
DOESN'T YOU CAN NOT EXPECT
SOMEBODY LIVING ABROAD FROM
AMONG A TO TAKE A AT TIMES
AND OPTION THAT'S GONNA TAKE
TAKE THREE HOURS WITH THE NON
OR FIVE HOURS WITH ORANGE COUNTY
BUT THERE WAS AN OPTION THAT
THAT'S EQUIVALENT TO THE COT
EVEN WITH CONGESTION I
BELIEVE VERY STRONGLY THAT OUR
OUR TRANSPORTATION SOLUTION IN
THE FUTURE HAVE TO INCLUDE THAT
IN THE SHORT FILM SOME LAST MILE
ISSUES BUT ALSO HAS TO BE --
INCLUDING SOME PRICE ICING I
KNOW MANY PEOPLE THE LIKELIHOOD
THAT I KNOW NAY LET HIM PAT
I WENT TO THE FRONT ON THE CITY
COUNCIL AND THEY WENT AFTER I
MEAN THIS IS WELL THIS IS GOING
TO PENALIZE IF WE DO HAVE A PLAN
ON ON ON ONE TO TEN TEN
ONE MEMBER SAYS WELL YOU'RE
GONNA PENALIZE LIKE FOR
AND I'LL TELL YOU THE
OPPOSITE IS TRUE WHEN
WE OPENED LANES IN
IN LA COUNTY IF ANYBODY
EVEN IF THOSE WHO USE THE HUTS
TENTS AND THOSE WHO DID NOT
AND YOU HAVE BEEN USING YOUR
THE INVESTORS IN A CREDIT OF
SENATE MUST NOT HONEY BYE
BYE IF USING THINGS THAT
THAT THE PERCEPTION IS IT'S
GONNA HAVE BUT THAT CAN BE
THE REALITY IS WE NEED RISE
THE SYSTEM RIGHT FOR US
TO HAVE TO HAVE A SOLUTION
WHAT WE'RE DOING ON TIME OKAY
YOU GO GO NEXT LIFELINE
MIX LEGISLATIVE CAN GO
CAN GO AND SO
NOW WE HAVE A COUNTY WIDE NIGHT
IMITATION PROGRAM IN EVERY COUNT
COUNT BUT -- HERE I MENTION
WAS ELECTED TOWN COUNCILMEN
MEDINA COUNTY IMPLEMENTATION
WE HAVE A MENTAL LINK SYSTEM
THAT BY CLOSE TO THAT THAT I
GET FOR SOMETHING CALIFORNIA
AND IF THE STATION SHOULD HAVE
A TRANSIT ORIENTED DEVELOPMENT
WHAT NOT ONLY YOU HAVE
HOUSING AND SHOPPING IN
PEOPLE WALKING IN ENTERTAINING
BUT THIS IS TRANSPORTATION IN
THE FUTURE IS MANY DIFFERENT
YOU DON'T HAVE TO HAVE IN
DOWNTOWN LOS ANGELES TO HAVE AN
ADDED ON STYLES TRANSPORTATION
SYSTEMS WE COULD DO THAT AMONG
THE CATEGORY THE EAST WAS
CALENDAR FROM SOMEONE IN THE
FOR LOS ANGELES NEXT SLIDE
PLEASE KEEP GOING
YOU KNOW WE START TO GAG ON
A VERY STRONG ACTOR ACTRESS
POSITION PROGRAM WHERE
WE -- WITH FEDERAL FUNDS
A MATCH THE CALIFORNIA
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION
FUNDS AND THE FUNDS OUR
PARTNERS AND SO FAR OVER
ONE OR NOT ONE ALMOST ONE
BILLION OVER A HALF HAVE BEEN
LOCATED IN ON SOMETHING IN A
OKAY TO DOES WE SPEAK TO YOU
SP ONE ADDED ABOUT A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS PER YEAR
TO THE STATE'S LIGHT ROGAN
FOR ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION
NOT NOW PEOPLE SAY WELL
-- I HAD A LOT OF IT WAS IT
WILL YOU KNOW THESE BY SIX OR
SEVEN A CREATING CONGESTION
AND THEY SHOULD GET OUT OF MY
WAY AND THEY COULDN'T BE
MORE WRONG THIS CITY I ELEVEN
EVENTUAL COMING AS A GREAT
STATE YOU WANTED COMES TO
PROVIDING SIZE LOGS AND PLACES
FOR PEOPLE TO BUY IT IS A
QUALITY OF LIFE MUCH I DON'T
THINK I'M GONNA TAKE OUR BIKES
TO COSTCO TO SHOP SHOP BUT IF
WE CHOOSE TO USE A LOT OF LIKE
WE SHOULD HAVE THE FACILITIES
AND INFRASTRUCTURE TO USING
AND WE SHOULD USE IT SAFELY
AND SO I'M I'M PROUD TO SAY THAT
IS OKAY -- WITH THE CALIFORNIA
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION HAS
PUT A LOT OF MONEY AND INVESTING
IN ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION
OF THE SAFETY MIXED PLEASE
AND WE DO HAVE LOCAL PROGRAM
SUSTAINABILITY PROGRAMS TO
ANDREAS IS AND I TRANSPORTATION
THAT'S WHAT SEVENTEEN YEAR
YEAR AND LOST CITIES TO BID
FOR FORTY FOUR DIFFERENT
PROJECTS NEXT WEEK'S
I DIDN'T KNOW HOW MANY OF
YOU HAD TO THIS BUT WE HAVE
A FULL HUMAN CAMPAIGN AND
WE CALL IT THAT BECAUSE IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR THE COMMUNITY TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT IT MEANS FOR
MAYBE ONCE IN AWHILE YOU'LL
BE ABLE TO IT'LL GO BRING
YOUR KIDS AND HAVE THE BIKE
WITHOUT BEING AFRAID THEY'RE
GOING TO BE HIT BY A CAR WE HAD
SEVERAL A FUNCTION INCLUDING IN
THIS CITY HOW WHEN WE CLOSE
SEVERAL STATE OUR PRESIDENT
JUST OPEN THIS IF YOU WANT
TENURE SECURE TO COVER SAFETY
-- UNFORTUNATELY WE DON'T HAVE
ENOUGH MONEY TO DO IN THE CITY
THAT MOST OF THOSE BUT ONCE
YOU DO IT WOULD YOU REALLY
APPRECIATE VERY MUCH
THAT ABILITY OF THE CITIZENS
OF THE CITY TO BE ABLE TO DO
THAT KIDS AND THE FEEDBACK
HAS BEEN AMAZING THE REQUEST
FOR THIS WILL HUMAN CAMPAIGNS
HAS BEEN AMAZING USING AND WE
HOPE TO GET MORE FUNDING TO
CONTINUE DOING THAT PLEASE GO
TO THE NEXT ONE KEEP GOING ON
OKAY AFTER THAT WOULD BE BACK
SO SO LET ME JUST CONCLUDE
WITH BEFORE WE HAVE THE LAST
NIGHT YOU YOU YES WE HAVE THE
MILLION GENERATION YES YEAH
THE LARGEST IN THE NATION
THE UNITED STATES DOWN THE
MOST EDUCATED IN ADDITION
JUSTICE BUT THEY GET OUT
OF COLLEGE WITH ABOUT FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN DEBT TO
I KNOW THAT FOR SURE
AND AND WIN WIN WIN WIN WIN THIS
TEST LIKE THIS IS AND YOU HAVE
THIS HOUSING ISSUE AND YOU HAVE
THESE TRANSPORTATION CHALLENGES
WE HAVE A LOT OF WORK TO YOU AS
I WOULD LAY THERE IS A COMMON
PROBLEM UPLOAD AND AND IF
WE WANT TO TACKLE THE HOUSING
TRANSPORTATION ISSUE WE REALLY
NEED TO PACK A LOT OF THINGS
THAT THAT IS NOT COMFORTABLE FOR
US AND ONE OF THEM WE ABSOLUTELY
NEED TO TACKLE SEE CLUB USERS
YOU KNOW WE TRIED SEVERAL
TIMES AS GAG GAG AND WE WERE
SUCCESSFUL IN AND HAVING
A LET ME JUST ADD SOME
LUCCHESI FORTY FOUR I AM I
HAVE SEEN FROM BY THE WAY I
AM PROBABLY CONSIDER MYSELF
ONE OF THE BIGGEST SUPPORTERS
BUT THAT USES SIX WHAT
STOP BOB MAJOR INFRASTRUCTURE
PROJECTS FROM MOVING FORWARD I
THINK WE HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY
TO DO THAT WE ALSO HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY TO WORK AND
WE'RE GONNA WORK HARD WITH YOU
ALL THIS YEAR WITH EVIDENCE
SKAGIT OR SANDBAGS TO BRING
REDEVELOPMENT SOME FORMALLY
DEVELOPMENT WE PRETTY MUCH JUST
TOOK THE ONLY INCENTIVE CITIES
HAVE PROVIDE HOUSING AND WE
TALK ABOUT HOUSING CRISIS ALL
OF THIS HAS TO BE SOLD FROM THE
STANDPOINT THAT WE HAVE A NEW
GENERATION THAT'S AND LANDING
DIFFERENT TRANSPORTATION SYSTEMS
DIFFERENT HOUSING CHOICES AND
I'M GONNA HUNDRED BY TONIGHT
AND PRESENTATION BY THIS
VIDEO OKAY AFTER THAT WOULD BE
HELLO DAD YOU ARE ADDICTED
TO THE SAME TIME TO UNPLUG
WHILE BEAUTIFUL THANK
YOU I INHERITED FROM
MY MOTHER SO YOU STILL
HAVE YOUR PARENTS HOUSE
CONOR YOUR FRIENDS HERE BUT
NOT CONNECTING WITH THE TARGET A
DEMO THE OLD PERSON
THE MUSICIANS WERE ARRESTED
AND USE DRUGS DECAYING IN
THE FABRIC OF OUR SOCIETY
SUCH A RAT RACE NO JOY
JUST WORK WHAT DO YOU THINK
THE WORLD OWES YOU SOMETHING
IS THIS NEW TECH COMPANY KNOWS
CAN TAKE USERS MORE IN THIS
WHAT WE DO REALLY LOVE THIS
PER ROOM -- WOULD BE SO
BAD IF WE TOOK OUT A SMALL
NUMBER ARE YOU SURE YOU
WANT TO START THIS PHASE
OF YOUR LIFE YEAH MAYBE
TRY SOMETHING MORE AFFORDABLE
LIKE A DAY AT THE BEACH
THIS THING ABOUT NINE TO
FIVE FIVE THIRTY I JUST
DON'T GET YOUR WORK SCHEDULE
SO WE NEED TO UNDERSTAND THE
THE MULLIN YEAH BUT THEY ALSO
THINK ABOUT THAT SIMILARLY OF
DIFFERENT THINGS SO I'M GONNA
SAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
CHAIR HOLDEN A SENATOR AND
ASSEMBLYMEMBER ASN ASSEMBLY
AT IT'S A GOOD TO SEE YOU HERE
IN THIS REGION AND I'M LOOK
FORWARD TO WORK WITH YOU EVEN
FROM SUNDAY THANK YOU THANK
YOU THANK YOU AND -- WE WILL
HAVE QUESTIONS FOR YOUR AT
THE END OF THIS PANEL -- AND
AND THANK YOU FOR REMINDING
ME THAT AS A PARENT OF THE
MILLENNIALS I'M NOT ALONE
THIS IS A
A BABY
GOOD MORNING WAS A GERMAN
GERMAN THANK YOU FOR HOSTING
THIS TODAY MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE -- I APPRECIATE YOU
BRINGING US TOGETHER TO TALK
ABOUT A VERY IMPORTANT PROJECT
OF OURS -- ONE THAT HOPEFULLY
IS A SOLUTION TO SOME OF THE
CHALLENGES BEARING DOWN ON LA
COUNTY -- FIRST AND FOREMOST
IS THE POPULATION GROWTH THAT'S
IT EXPECTED WITHIN NOT JUST LA
COUNTY BUT WHAT'S TURNING OUT TO
BE A LION'S SHARE OF IT COMING
IN TO THE SAYING GABRIEL VALLEY
-- AS YOU KNOW THE POPULATION
GROWTH WILL INCREASE BY ALMOST
SIX PERCENT BY TWENTY TWENTY
FOUR -- AND THAT IS GOING TO
AFFECT THE SAN GABRIEL VALLEY
WITH A LARGE A PORTION -- COMING
INTO THE SAME ZERO VALLEY -- FOR
JOBS AS WELL AS FOR EMPLOYMENT
AND THE MAJORITY OF THOSE PEOPLE
COMING INTO THE FORT HILL COURT
OR ITSELF -- WE ARE RESPONSIBLE
FOR SOLVING SOME OF THE PROBLEMS
WITH IN THE SAN GABRIEL VALLEY
-- NOTABLY THOSE PROBLEMS IN
THE EAST PART OF ARE YOU SAYING
GENERAL VALLEY A RUNNING ALONG
THE FOOT HILLS -- THAT IS OUR
RESPONSIBILITY OF OUR CHALLENGES
TO BUILD THIS PROJECT IN THREE
PHASES OF FIRST PHASE WAS
OPENED IN TWO THOUSAND THREE
-- FROM LOS ANGELES TO PASADENA
THE SECOND PHASE OPENED -- AND
-- UNDER BUDGET COMPLETED IN
TWENTY FIFTEEN -- ELEVEN AND
A HALF MILES FIVE CITIES FIVE
STATIONS AT THE NEXT PHASE OF
THE PROJECT FROM GLENDORA TO
MONTCLAIR WE BROKE GROUND LAST
DECEMBER AND IT'S TWELVE POINT
THREE MILES SIX STATIONS THROUGH
SIX CITIES OR RIDERSHIP
SHE IS AT HISTORIC LEVELS ARE
WE'RE VERY PLEASE WITH METROS
OPERATION OF THE SYSTEM AND THE
SATISFACTION OF THE CUSTOMERS
NOT JUST ON WEEKDAYS BUT ALSO
ON THE WEEKENDS -- THE SEGMENT
FROM GOING DOOR TO MONTCLAIR
-- WHICH IS -- IT WITHIN
THE SHARED CORRIDOR -- RUNS
OR WILL BE AND SS AND WITH
METROLINK SO WE WILL BE BUILDING
THIS PROJECT WITHIN THAT CHER
TOWARD OR DIFFERENT TRACKS
BUT WITHIN THE SAME HUNDRED
FOOT REAL ROAD RIGHT AWAY
OUR PROJECT IS GOING PLAN IN
OVER THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS
-- WITH EACH OF THE STATIONS
IN EACH OF THE CITIES -- WITH
PLANNING NOT ONLY WHERE THE
STATION IS GOING TO GO AND
WHERE THE PARKING WILL BE BUT
ALSO ACCESS AS WELL AS THE US
THAT EQUIPMENT TO MEET STATION
INCLUDING STATION COLORS AND
ALL THE ENHANCEMENTS INCLUDING
ARTWORK C. C. R. GLENDORA
THERE'S LIVER AND MONA -- THE
LAST TWO STATIONS -- OF THE
SYSTEM CLERMONT AND MONTCLAIR
AGAIN FULLY FULLY PLANNED
WITH COMMUNITY INVOLVEMENT
OVER THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS
WE WILL HAVE WORKING IN EACH
OF THE FACILITIES -- METRO
HAS RECENTLY UNDERGONE A
CHANGE IN THEIR POLICY THEIR
PARKING POLICY WHICH IS IT'S
BEEN ADOPTED -- JUST JANUARY
OF THIS YEAR WHICH REQUIRES
OF A CHARGE FOR PARKING IN
EACH OF THE STATION PARKING
LOT SO THEY ARE LOOKING AT US
TO LOOK AT THE TOTAL NUMBER
OF PARKING SPACES THAT WERE
PLANNED AND SEE IF THERE'S ANY
CHANGE NOW THAT THAT ASSUMPTION
FREE PARKING IS NO LONGER
THAT THERE WILL BE CHARGED
PARKING SO WE ARE LOOKING AT
EACH OF OUR STATIONS SITE AND
-- REVIEWING THAT ENVIRONMENTAL
PROCESS ONCE YOU OVER THE
NEXT YEAR ON A NEW NUMBER FOR
EACH OF THE PARKING STRUCTURES
A BIG PART OF OUR PROJECT IS
FIRST MY LAST MILE PLANNING
OVER THE LAST THREE YEARS WE
WORK WITH THE CITIES AND NOW
IT'S BEEN TURNED OVER TO METRO
-- USING MEASURE AND DOLLARS
THAT IN THE MAIL MADE AVAILABLE
THROUGH THE THE COG -- TO DO
FIRST MY LAST NAME I'LL JUST
NOT JUST PLANNING BUT ALSO
IMPLEMENTATION SO THAT WORK IS
UNDER WAY -- WE WOULD EXPECT
THAT WITHIN THE NEXT YEAR METRO
ON EACH OF THE CITIES WILL HAVE
A PLAN TO UTILIZE OR SMILE LAST
MILE DOLLARS AND BETTER CONNECT
WITH EACH OF THE STATIONS ALONG
THE FOOTHILL GOAL LINE LINE
AHEAD OF ME HAVING PROJECT
CHALLENGES THAT ARE ARE FAIRLY
SIGNIFICANT -- MENTION WE'RE
IN A SHARED CORRIDOR -- WE WILL
BE WORKING WITH METROLINK NB
AND SS KEEP THEIR OPERATIONS
OPEN DURING OUR CONSTRUCTION
-- THE REQUIREMENT IS THAT
THEY STAY OPERATIONAL -- WE
WORK AT NIGHT AND WE WORK IN
A NON PEAK HOURS WILL BE IN
THE SOUTH AND METROLINK TO
MAKE SURE THE WORK GETS DONE
SAFELY BUT ALSO KEEPING THEIR
SYSTEM -- IN OPERATION AT ALL
TIMES -- WE WILL BE RELOCATING
IN THE CLERMONT METROLINK
STATION ABOUT FIVE HUNDRED FEET
-- AND THAT'S A SIGNIFICANT
CHALLENGE TO THE PROJECT AS OUR
TWENTY SIX AT GRADE CROSSINGS
AND TWENTY FIVE ON A RENT
RENOVATED BRIDGES -- WE HAVE
WE HAVE COORDINATE WITH A LARGE
NUMBER OF THIRD PARTY CITIES
-- DIFFERENT ADMINISTRATIVE
OFFICES AS WELL AS TO COUNTY
AND THE CONSTRUCTION -- DOLLARS
THAT WE ARE ANTICIPATING OUR
BIDS ARE JUST RECENTLY COME IN
-- AND WE ARE NOW LOOKING AT
THOSE BIDS UNDERSTANDING THAT
WE ARE IN A VERY DIFFERENT
ECONOMY THAN WE WERE WE BUILT
THE PREVIOUS PHASE OF THE
PROJECT -- WITH -- XCELERATED
ECONOMY -- OVERHEATED ECONOMY
SOME PEOPLE SAY -- IN BEADS
COMING IN VERY HIGH AND A LOT
OF PROJECTS THAT WE SEE AROUND
THE STATE SO WE'RE ANXIOUS TO
COMPLETE EVALUATION OF OUR BIDS
AND UNDERSTAND IF THAT'S GONNA
HAVE ANY IMPACT TO OUR PROJECT
-- THE WORK PLAN FOR A PROJECT
WAS WE HAD AS I MENTIONED
WE WE BROKE GROUND -- JUST
LAST DECEMBER -- TO --
-- THE NEW WORK THAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN NEXT LIFELINE -- WHICH
WAS THE UTILITY RELOCATION
CONTRACT OF THIS CONTRACT WAS
AWARDED TO AND ALLOWING US TO
GET THAT WORK OUT OF THE WAY A
LOT OF UNDERGROUND FACILITIES
OUT OF THE WAY FOR THE NEW
ALIGNMENT CONTRACTOR -- WE'VE
BEGUN THAT PROCUREMENT AND WE
EXPECT TO AWARD THE ALIGNMENT
CONTRACT WHICH IS VIA ALMOST
BILLION DOLLAR CONTRACT LATER
PART OF THIS YEAR WHEN THAT
CONTRACT -- IS ON BOARD THEY
WILL COMPLETE THE DESIGN OF THE
FINAL DESIGN AND ENGINEERING FOR
THE PROJECT THE ENTIRE SEGMENT
THAT INCLUDES THE RELOCATION
OF THE BNSF THE METRO ON TRACK
-- THEN THE CONTRACT WILL COME
IN AND RELOCATE THOSE TRACKS AS
THE FIRST PART OF THE PROJECT
AND THEN THE SECOND PART AND
FINAL PART WILL BE THE LIGHT
REAL CONSTRUCTION ITSELF SO
THAT'S A SUBSTANTIAL -- JOB
THIS -- THE RELOCATION OF ALL
THOSE FACILITIES AND THAT'S
WHY THIS PROJECT WAS ABOUT YOUR
CONSTRUCTION PROJECT OVERALL
THE DB ONE CONTRACTOR AS I
MENTIONED WAS RUSTIC AND THEY'VE
COME IN AND THEY'VE RELOCATED
-- MUCH OF THE UNDERGROUND
UTILITIES -- THAT HAD TO
BE MOVED AS PART OF THE --
PREPARATION FOR THIS PROJECT
SLIDE SLIDE WITH REGARD
DRUG PROCUREMENT MRS ARE A
DESIGN BUILD PACKAGE NUMBER TWO
GB TO -- WE ISSUES THE SHORTLIST
PROPOSERS -- IN FEBRUARY --
THE BOARD APPROVE THAT WE WENT
OUT TO THE INDUSTRY WITH OUR
PROJECT PLAN OUR CONTRACT AND
OR OR SENATE ENGINEERING PLANS
-- THAT WAS ISSUED DUE TO THE
INDUSTRY -- WE TOOK IT IN --
THEIR PROPOSALS -- THE PROPOSALS
RECEIVED IN IN SEPTEMBER OF
A JUST A COUPLE WEEKS AGO
ALMOST A MONTH AGO AND NOW
WE'RE REVIEWING THOSE PROPOSALS
ON OUR BOARD WILL AUTHORIZE
US TO MOVE FORWARD WITH THAT
CONTRACT LATER THIS YEAR HERE
-- THE FOUR TEAMS ARE LISTED
HERE NOW FOR ORDER -- THESE
ARE FOUR TEAMS THAT HAVE DONE
WORK -- NATIONWIDE -- PROBABLY
ALL OVER THE WORLD WAS KIND
OF LIKE REALLY SYSTEM SO WE'RE
VERY CONFIDENT THAT WE HAVE
FOUR FOR HIGHLY QUALIFIED TEAMS
OUR PROJECT ESTIMATE -- AND
AGAIN I WAS LIKE TO EMPHASIZE
THAT THAT'S JUST AN ESTIMATE
-- WEEK WE CAN'T COUNT FOR
WHAT THE INDUSTRY WILL BRING
TO THE TABLE -- WITH REGARD TO
THEIR BID -- BUT AS WE SEE IS
A GLENDORA MONCLER SEGMENT IS
ABOUT ONE POINT FOUR BILLION
DOLLARS FOR -- THE PROJECT WITH
ABOUT ANOTHER SEVENTY MILLION
DOLLARS TO -- GIVE US IN
CLAREMONT TO MONTCLAIR -- THIS
ENTIRE PART OF THE PROJECT THIS
IS ALL ONE PROJECT AS WE SEE IT
-- WE SEPARATE OUT THURMOND TWO
MONTHS THERE BECAUSE THOSE TO
BE FUNDED THROUGH SAN BERNARDINO
COUNTY DOLLAR SO HOW DID IT
THAT WAY AND WE WILL WORK IT
THAT WAY AS A OPTION TO THE
CONTRACTOR WITH REGARD
TO THE MOST IMPORTANT THING OUR
FUNDING SOURCES YOU CAN SEE THE
MAJORITY OF THOSE FUNDS COMES
TO MEASURE M. AND MEASURE ARE
FUN WE ALSO HAVE A THREE PERCENT
LOCAL MAPS OF EACH OF THE CITIES
WILL PROVIDE KIND CONTRIBUTION
OF STAFF SUPPORT FOR THE PROJECT
-- OVER THE PLAN CURRY BUT ALSO
TO THE CONSTRUCTION -- SAMBAR
YOU KNOW WE'LL BRING PROVIDING
ABOUT FORTY MILLION DOLLARS --
FROM THERE LOCAL FUNDS AND
THEN OF COURSE WE HAVE ABOUT
THREE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
TWO HUNDRED NINETY MILLION
DOLLARS OF CAP AND TRADE DOLLARS
WHICH CLOSED OUR GAP YEAH UP
WHICH IS VERY IMPORTANT TO
THE PROJECT OBVIOUSLY -- AND
WITH THE CAP AND TRADE OF
COURSE THAT IS ASSOCIATED WITH
SP ONE FUNDS AND -- IS VERY
CRITICAL TO THE -- THE THE
MOVING FORWARD OF THIS PROJECT
ONE IMPORTANT ELEMENT THIS
PROJECT COURSES TO YOU DO
TRANSIT OR IN DEVELOPMENT IS
KEY -- TO THE CITY'S GROW --
WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH EACH
OF THE QUARTER CITIES SINCE
TWO THOUSAND THREE -- WE'VE
WORKED WITH THEM -- NOT ONLY
TO ACCEPT THIS NOTION OF MORE
DENSITY -- BUT ALSO MAKING SURE
THEY PLAY A SIGNIFICANT ROLE
IN THAT DENSITY THAT THEY CAN
HAVE A HAND IN THE PLANNING
MAKING JOBS AVAILABLE BUT
ALSO RESIDENTIAL COMMUNITIES
AVAILABLE NEW RESIDENTIAL
COMMUNITIES -- TO EACH OF THE
CITIES -- AND ASSOCIATED WITH
EACH OF THE STATIONS ALONG THE
LINE EACH OF THE CITIES FROM
ARCADIA ALL THE WAY TO MONTCLAIR
HAS ADOPTED OR ISN'T ACOSTA
SAYS ADOPTING A GENERAL PLAN
OR SPECIFIC PLAN THAT LOOKS TO
JOINT DEVELOPMENT AROUND EACH
OF THE STATIONS SO THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT THEY'RE THEY'RE
VERY ANXIOUS TO PARTICIPATE IN
THEM SLIDE BLOOD I
AND THEY WORK WITH US SINCE TWO
THOUSAND THREE WITH THE PHASE
ONE OF THE PROJECT WHERE WE
HAVE TWELVE AND A HALF THOUSAND
NEW HOUSING UNITS ASSOCIATED
WITH THE GOAL LINE LINE --
FACE TO WE HAVE ALMOST TWICE
THAT THE HOUSINGS BUT THREE
TIMES THAT IN COMMERCIAL SPACE
OFFICE SPACE FOR TOTAL ABOUT
NINE BILLION DOLLARS WORTH OF
DEVELOPMENT ASSOCIATE WITH THE
NEXT PHASE OF THE PROJECT OF
COURSE THIS PROJECT HAS MANY
CONNECTIONS ALL OF YOUR WHERE
THE INSTITUTIONS OF HIGHER
EDUCATION THAT ARE ALONG THIS
LINE THAT'S A VERY IMPORTANT
PART OF THIS PROJECT -- ALL OF
THE SCHOOLS ARE ANXIOUS TO HELP
US PROVIDE PARKING NOT JUST FOR
THE STUDENTS BUT ALSO FOR THE
FACULTY AND STAFF AND OF COURSE
LOTS OF REGIONAL DESTINATIONS
ALONG THE WAY THAT ARE ALL
VERY IMPORTANT TO US TO THE
CULTURAL EVENTS OF EACH OF THE
CITIES INCLUDING THE MUSEUMS IN
HOSPITALS AND THAT CONCLUDES
MY UPDATES AS TEACHER
THANK YOU ARE WILL OF
OUR LAST PRESENTER AND THEN
WE'LL -- POSE QUESTIONS TO
USES OF THE THREE PERCENT
OR SO LOUISE RETURNED HER
GOOD MORNING AND THANK YOU
FOR THE INVITATION TO BE
HERE I'M ALWAYS BEST WITH
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE STRATEGIC GROWTH COUNCIL
-- AND I'LL START -- JUST
FIRST ALL INTRODUCTION TO THE
STRATEGIC GROWTH COUNCIL WE WERE
ESTABLISHED ABOUT TEN YEARS AGO
THROUGH US STATE LEGISLATIVE
THROUGH LEGISLATION AND OUR
ROLE IS TO BRING TOGETHER
STATE AGENCIES AND DEPARTMENTS
TO COORDINATE ACTIVITIES THAT
SUPPORT SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT ACROSS CALIFORNIA
EMPHASIZING STRONG ECONOMIES
EQUITY AND ENVIRONMENTAL
STEWARDSHIP IN THAT WORK WHERE
ARE COUNSEL'S MADE UP OF TEN
MEMBERS -- INCLUDING THREE
PUBLIC MEMBERS AND -- AND THEN
SEVEN SIX CABINET SECRETARIES
AND THE DIRECTOR OF THE OFFICE
OF PLANNING AND RESEARCH US
WE ACCOMPLISH OUR WORK THROUGH
DIRECT INVESTMENT IN COMMUNITIES
PROVIDING TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
TO COMMUNITIES -- AND THEN OUR
COLLABORATION AND COORDINATION
ACROSS THE STATE AGENCY SAW
WALK THROUGH A FEW OF THESE
ACTIVITIES AND AND TALK THROUGH
SOME OF OUR INVESTMENTS IN
IT TOGETHER IN THIS REGION
SO OUR LARGEST PROGRAM IS
THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITIES PROGRAM
-- THIS PROGRAM IS FUNDED
THROUGH A TWENTY PERCENT
CONTINUOUS APPROPRIATION FROM
THE STATE'S GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION FINDS IT FROM OUR
CAP AND TRADE REVENUES I AM WE
INVEST THESE FUNDS AN AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND SUSTAINABLE
TRANSPORTATION PROJECTS ACROSS
THE STATE OUR LAST ROUND OF
FUNDING WAS AWARDED IN JUNE
OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN WHEN WE'RE
WORRIED ABOUT TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS A TEN NINETEEN
PROJECTS WE'RE ABOUT TO FINALIZE
GUIDELINES FOR AROUND FOUR I
THAT WILL HAPPEN AYE HOPEFULLY
AT OUR COUNCIL MEETING LATER
THIS FALL -- AND APPLICATIONS
WILL OPEN -- RIGHT RIGHT
RIGHT AFTER THAT I JUST OVER
THE COURSE OF THE PROGRAM IN
THIS GAG REGION WE'VE AWARDED
TWENTY SIXTEEN CRYOGENICS
-- OF OF IT AT TOTALING JUST
OVER THREE HUNDRED AND TWENTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS ABOUT TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION OF THIS
IS GONE FOR HOUSING PROJECTS --
AND JUST OVER SEVENTY MILLION
IS GONE FOR TRANSPORTATION
PROJECTS ASSOCIATED WITH THOSE
DEVELOPMENTS I AND IS RESULTED
IN OVER THIRTY FIVE HUNDRED
AFFORDABLE HOUSING UNITS --
IN SIGNIFICANT REDUCTIONS IN
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS SO
ONE OF THESE PROJECTS THAT A
HIGHLIGHT WAS JUST AWARDED --
AND ACTUALLY GOT TO BE THERE FOR
A CELEBRATION ON THIS PROJECT
CENTER LEYVA AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RANDY I AN ARROWHEAD GROVE IN
THE CITY OF SAN BERNARDINO NO
-- THIS IS THE FIRST AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND SUSTAINABLE
COMMUNITIES AWARD FOR SAN
BERNADINO -- AND IT IS A HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY FOUR UNITS OF HOUSING
IN MID RISE BUILDINGS THAT
WILL BE CONSTRUCTED EIGHTY
PERCENT AFFORDABLE LEAVE GOAL
TO SIGNIFICANT ENERGY SAVINGS
-- BUT ALSO IT REALLY LOOKS
IN THIS INTEGRATED WAY AND HOW
WE SUPPORT COMMUNITIES AND SO
THIS HOUSING IS ALSO GOING TO
BE ASSOCIATED WITH INVESTMENTS
IN BIKE LANES LOCATED RIGHT
NEAR AN ELEMENTARY SCHOOL IN
THERE OF THE IMPROVEMENTS SO
THAT CHILDREN AND FAMILIES CAN
WALK TO SCHOOL -- THEIR NEW BUS
SHELTERS AND THEN OF COURSE ALL
OF THIS RESULTING IN GREENHOUSE
GAS A SIGNIFICANT GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSION REDUCTIONS IN OUR
THIS PROJECT ACTUALLY RECEIVED
THE LARGEST AWARD IN OUR LAST
ROUND OF FUNDING I WAS TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS -- ANOTHER
PROJECT -- HIGHLIGHT IS THE
MARCH THAT ARE IN THE VILLAGE
IN THE CITY OF RIVERSIDE -- AND
THIS IS ONE OF OUR FIRST AWARDED
WOULD FIND FINDINGS ARE FIRST
ROUND OF AWARDS -- AND THIS
IS A NUMBER OF HOUSING UNITS TO
SERVE -- TO SERVE VETERANS
OF THE PARTICULAR AND THIS
I CALL ATTENTION TO BUSINESS
AWARD IS ACTUALLY OPENED AND
SO WE'RE AT AN EXCITING PHASE
RIGHT NOW WHERE WE ARE ACTUALLY
SEEING OUR INVESTMENTS NOW
WITH -- WITH FAMILIES AND AND
PEOPLE LIVING IN THEM AND SO
THESE ARE JUST TWO EXAMPLES OF
PROJECTS -- HERE IN THE REGION
I AND OTHER IMPORTANT
PROGRAMS THAT WE ADMINISTERS
THE TRANSFORMATIVE CLIMBING
COMMUNITIES PROGRAM AND THIS IS
A PROPER PROGRAM THAT'S INTENDED
AT AND DESIGNED TO MAKE MY
NEIGHBORHOOD SCALE INVESTMENT
IN A SET OF INTEGRATED PROJECT
SO IT'S A PLACE LEAST APPROACH
WHERE WE REALLY LOOK AT BUILDING
A COLLABORATIVE COMMUNITY
STAKE HOLDERS STRUCTURE TO
TALK ABOUT -- HOW TO INVEST
FUNDS TO MAKE A MAJOR TO
CATALYZE TRANSFORMATION AND
COMMUNITIES AND THIS IS REALLY
FOCUSED ON EITHER SIDE PROGRAM
IS FOCUSED ON THE STATE'S MOST
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES AND
WE'RE LOOKING AT INTEGRATED
CLIMATE STRATEGIES AND OF
COURSE THE CHIEF GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSION REDUCTIONS BUT
ALONG SIDE HEALTH BENEFITS
ECONOMIC BENEFITS AND SO
WE'RE LOOKING AT WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT AND THAT'S AND SOME
TRANSFORMATIVE REQUIREMENTS
THAT ARE PART OF THIS PROGRAM
I WE MADE OUR FIRST ROUND
REWARDS IN THAT PROGRAM IN
JANUARY OF THIS YEAR WE HAD
A HUNDRED AND FORTY MILLION
DOLLARS AND WE MADE THREE AWARDS
WE ALSO AWARDED FOR TEN PLANNING
GRANT WOULD GET COMMUNITIES
ON ON TRACK TO BE ELIGIBLE
TO APPLY FOR THE NEXT ROUND
OF IMPLEMENTATION GRANT --
THE EACH OF THESE PROJECTS ON
TALKS ARE TO THAT ARE TWO OF
THE INVESTMENTS FROM THE FIRST
ROUNDER HERE IN THIS REGION
-- IS NOW IN ANOTHER IMPORTANT
PIECE OF THIS IS OR SIGNIFICANT
LEVERAGE IN EACH OF THESE
PROJECTS SO ALONG SIDE THE
INVESTMENT FROM THE STRATEGIC
GROWTH COUNSELLORS SIGNIFICANT
LEVERAGE DOLLARS NOW WE ARE
ACTUALLY IN THE PROCESS RIGHT
NOW OF THE GROUNDS TO OF THIS
PROGRAM YEAH FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS AVAILABLE IN THIS ROUND
APPLICATIONS ARE DUE AT THE END
OF THIS MONTH THAN WE ANTICIPATE
MAKING WARDS LATER THIS YEAR
ASSET TO THE TO THE PROJECTS
I WANTED TO TALK ABOUT FROM
ROUND ONE ONE IS -- IN ONTARIO
AND THAT'S ON TERRIO TOGETHER
AND AND THIS PROJECT RECEIVED
APPROXIMATELY THIRTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT AND
HAD JUST OVER US SIXTEEN AND A
HALF MILLION DOLLARS OF LEVERAGE
AT JUST SPEAKING ABOUT THE
COLLABORATIVE STRUCTURE THIS
PROJECT HAS FIFTEEN PARTNERS
-- THE LEAD ON THE ON THE
APPLICATION WAS AT THE CITY OF
ONTARIO THERE FIFTEEN PARTNERS
WHO ARE IMPLEMENTING PROJECTS
UNDER THE UMBRELLA OF THIS GRANT
AND INCLUDES -- INVESTMENTS IN
HOUSING SO -- HUNDRED AND ONE
AFFORDABLE NEW HOUSING UNITS BUT
ALSO SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT IN
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE
SO OVER FIVE MILES BIKE LANES
THREE MILES OF SIDEWALKS --
TRANSIT PASSES TO RESIDENTS --
AND ALSO A WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
COMPONENTS TO DEVELOPMENT
OF AN INCUBATOR -- TO HELP
GENERATE JOBS IN THE COMMUNITY
A SECOND ONE OF OUR INVESTMENTS
IN ROUND ONE WAS IN WHAT
IN THIS WAS -- WITH THE LA
COUNTY HOUSING AUTHORITY AS
LEAD APPLICANT AGAIN ANOTHER
ABOUT THIRTY FIVE MILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT THIS HAD SIGNIFICANT
LEVERAGE OF OVER A HUNDRED AND
SIXTY EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS
SEVENTEEN PARTNERS BRINGING
TOGETHER AB SOME INVESTMENT
INVESTMENT IN HOUSING SO OVER
ABOUT TWO HUNDRED AND SIXTEEN
AFFORDABLE HOUSING UNITS AT BUT
ALSO SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS
IN EXPANDING TRANSPORTATION
OPTIONS SO -- CARSHARING
ELECTRIC TRICK TRICK HE'S
ELECTION TRANSIT OPTIONS IN VAN
POOL A LOT OF INVESTMENT OSMAN
STREETS GAPING SO CREATING SAFE
-- AND USABLE PEDESTRIAN AND
BIKE WAYS -- IN THE COMMUNITY
EACH OF THESE INVESTMENTS
IS REALLY AT A NEIGHBORHOOD
SCALE SO ON A ON THE ORDER
OF A COUPLE YOU KNOW THREE OR
FOUR SQUARE MILES BUT REALLY
INTENDED TO BRING TOGETHER
MULTIPLE PROJECTS THAT ARE
GOING TO REDUCE GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS BUT ALSO PROVIDE OTHER
SIGNIFICANT BENEFITS -- TO
THE COMMUNITY EVERYONE OF THE
INVESTMENTS MADE UNDER THESE --
GRANT IS A TYPE OF PROJECT THAT
WOULD BE FUNDED THROUGH THE
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION FUNDS
THEY ALL ARE THINGS LIKE URBAN
GREENING INVESTMENTS AND --
IN SUSTAINABLE TRANSPORTATION
IN AFFORDABLE HOUSING -- SO
REALLY IS AN INTEGRATED PROGRAM
SO ANOTHER REALLY IMPORTANT ROLE
THAT WE PLAY AND WE THINK IT'S
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT ONE AT THE
STRATEGIC GROWTH COUNCIL IS WE
PROVIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO
COMMUNITIES TO ACCESS THE FUNDS
THAT ARE AVAILABLE THROUGH THE
CALIFORNIA CLIMATE INVESTMENTS
PROGRAM AND SO WE DO THAT
FOR OUR PROGRAM SERVICE FOR
THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITIES PROGRAM
FOR A TRANSFORMATIVE CLIMATE
COMMUNITIES PROGRAM I BELIEVE
ALSO DO IT IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
OTHER AGENCIES SO WE WORK WITH
WHERE FOR INSTANCE CAL TRANS
OR THE CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES
BOARD TO PROVIDE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO APPLICANTS --
TO BE ABLE TO ACCESS THOSE
FUNDS FOR DIFFERENT TYPES OF
PROJECTS IT LOOKS DIFFERENT FOR
DIFFERENT PROGRAMS BUT WE DO
THIS PROVIDING DIRECT ASSISTANCE
DIRECT APPLICATION ASSISTANCE
TO POTENTIAL APPLICANTS AND WE
ALSO -- WILL OFTEN DO A LOT OF
CAPACITY BUILDING IN COMMUNITY
SO WORKING WITH COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS AND OTHERS TO
BUILDER RESOURCE BASE THAT
CAN BE USEFUL ON THE GROUND
-- AND ALSO FREEZING YOU MIGHT
HOW TO INTEGRATE AND ACCESS
FUNDS ACROSS MULTIPLE DIFFERENT
PROGRAMS I AM SO WE'RE DOING
THIS AS I SAID ACROSS IN OUR OWN
PROGRAMS BUT ALSO WORKING ON
SOLAR COMMUNITY SOLAR LOW CARBON
TRANSPORTATION SUSTAINABLE
AGRICULTURAL PROGRAMS OF IN
THIS TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
HAS BEEN DEMONSTRATED TO
INCREASE THE THE SUCCESS RATE
OF APPLICANTS AND SO IT IS
ESPECIALLY IMPORTANT FOR UNDER
RESOURCE AND DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES WHICH IS WHERE
WE REALLY FOCUS THIS WORK
I AND SO JUST CONCLUDE WITH TWO
OTHER IMPORTANT PROGRAMS THAT
ARE NOT AS DIRECTLY RELATED ON
THE TRANSPORTATION FRONT BUT
JUST WANTED TO TO MENTION
BECAUSE I THINK THEY DO ROUND
OUT VERY NICELY -- THE SUITE
OF WHAT OF THE WORK THAT WE
DO ANOTHER AREA OF INVESTMENT
WHERE WE TAKE TEN PERCENT
OF THE FUNDING AVAILABLE THROUGH
THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITIES PROGRAM
TO INVEST AND AGRICULTURAL
AND OPEN AND AGRICULTURAL LAND
CONSERVATION AND THIS IS REALLY
TO MARRY TOGETHER THE IMPORTANCE
OF CONSERVING OUR OPEN SPACE
AND AGRICULTURAL LAND ALONG
SIDE MORE COMPACT DEVELOPMENT
PATTERNS -- AND SO WE HAVE
TO DATE INVESTORS IN JUST OVER
FIFTY EASEMENTS AND PROTECTED
OVER EIGHTY THOUSAND ACRES OF
LAND AND THEN FINALLY -- IN THAT
WE HAVE ALSO RECEIVED FUNDING
THROUGH THE GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION PROGRAM GREENHOUSE
GAS REDUCTION FUND TO SUPPORT
CLIMATE CHANGE RESEARCH PROGRAM
I THIS IS AT WE'RE REALLY
FOCUSED ON VERY POLICY ORIENTED
RESEARCH SO INVESTING IN
PROJECTS THAT HELP ADVANCE OUR
-- OUR PROGRAM IN OUR EFFORTS TO
REDUCE GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
SO IN THE FIRST ROUND OF FINDING
WHICH IS AWARDED IN JULY OF
THIS YEAR WE HAD ABOUT TEN
AND A HALF MILLION DOLLARS IN
GRANTS WENT TO CALIFORNIA BASED
INSTITUTIONS -- BUT I THINK
IMPORTANTLY LOOK AT SOME OF THE
IMPORTANT POLICY CHALLENGES THAT
WE'RE FACING IN IMPLEMENTATION
SUCH AS DISPLACEMENT I'M
THINKING ABOUT BARRIERS AND
OPPORTUNITIES FOR SUSTAINABLE
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT SO THESE
ARE JUST PROJECTS WERE REALLY
EXCITED ABOUT THEY ALL HAVE AN
ENGAGEMENT COMPONENT TO THEM SO
WORKING WITH STAKEHOLDERS AND
USERS OF THAT RESEARCH AND SO
WITH THAT I WILL CONCLUDE THAT
HAPPY TO ANSWER QUESTIONS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU WANTED
TO JUST STAY THERE FOR JUST
A MOMENT AND I'LL I'LL TURN
TO MY COLLEAGUE -- TO SEE IF
THEY HAVE ANY QUESTIONS WAS
FIRST LET ME JUST THANK YOU
FOR WHAT YOU WERE DOING THE
STRATEGIC GROWTH COUNCIL IS
DOING TO SORT INTEGRATE SO MANY
OF THE IMPORTANT WORK GOALS
THAT THE STATUS AND TO SORT
OF INTEGRATE THAT IN TERMS OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN THE USE OF
G. R. F. OF FUNDING --
TO HATTIESBURG HELP US GET TO
THE THE PLACE SO HE'S READY
MORE FORMAL HOUSING WAS ALSO A
SUSTAINABILITY AND REDUCING
THE CARBON OUTPUT SO REGULATIONS
ON THAT -- I I GUESS I GUESS BUT
LET ME JUST ASK THIS QUESTION
IN TERMS OF YOUR INTERACTING
WITH LOCAL TRANSPORTATION
AGENCIES DO YOU HAVE ANY RECENT
EXAMPLES OF HOW WE ARE WORKING
WITH THE LOCAL TRANSPORTATION
AGENCIES TO HELP ADDRESS ISSUES
OR PROBLEMS THAT MAY HAVE COME
UP DURING THE COURSE OF YOUR
PROJECTS OR HOW INTEGRATING IN
A STRATEGY GOING FORWARD -- AS
RELATED TO -- TRANSPORTATION
YOU TALK ABOUT BIKE LANES
AND I THINK THAT'S THAT'S
IMPORTANT THAT MAY BE PART OF
IT BUT YEAH AND A CERTAIN --
IN SOME OF OUR INVESTMENTS --
WE ALSO ARE WORKING WITH LOCAL
TRANSPORTATION AGENCIES ON IT
COULD BE POSSIBLE BUS SHELTER
IMPROVEMENTS -- INVESTMENTS
THAT WOULD INCREASE FREQUENCY OF
THE BUS SERVICE THOSE ARE PARTS
OR SOME OF OUR TRANSFORMATIVE
CLIMATE UNITIES INVESTMENTS AND
SO -- WE INTERACT WITH THEM
IN A NUMBER OF WAYS OR AN ARE
SPECIALLY ARE ORTIZ DO -- BUT
THAT IS CERTAINLY A PART OF
THESE TRANSPORTATION INVESTMENTS
THAT WE'RE MAKING ALONG SIDE --
YOU KNOW AT EITHER AS PART OF
THE WHOLE IN THE TRANSFORMATIVE
CLIMATE COMMUNITIES INVESTMENTS
OR AS PART OF AN AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND SUSTAINABLE
COMMUNITIES INVESTMENT THE SONG
BABY YOUR STAND READY AS WELL
WELL TURN TO MY COLLEAGUE IF
OF COURSE I DO WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR HAVING SELECTED THE
ERROR HAD GROW IT'S I THINK
IT'S WHAT'S WONDERFUL ABOUT THAT
AWARD IS OF COURSE THE HOUSING
IN THE SENSE OF OF HOME FOR
THE CHILDREN OF THE FAMILIES
BUT ALSO HUNDRED HO TRANSFORMS
THE COMMUNITY -- THEY WERE SO
USED TO THE HOUSING PROJECTS
THAT WERE THERE AT THAT SITE
AND NOW TO HAVE IT TRANSFORM
IT'S A TRUE TRANSFORMATION
QUITE FRANKLY AND I APPRECIATE
YOUR YOUR SELECTING THAT THAT
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT I THINK IS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT AND I'M I'M
GLAD ABOUT THERE'S A CONTINUOUS
TWENTY PERCENT CONTINUES
APPROPRIATIONS OFTENTIMES
WE HAVE ONE TIME FUNDING FOR
FOR PROGRAM BUT
TO KNOW THAT YOU WILL HAVE THIS
CONTINUOUS APPROPRIATIONS I
THINK MAKES YOUR JOB EASIER BUT
I'D LIKE YOUR THOUGHTS ON THEM
YEAH I MET UP YES IT DOES MAKE
IT EASIER HER HOME I THINK IT
ALSO THAT THAT EXAMPLE OF THEIR
HEAD GROUP PROJECT IS A REALLY
IMPORTANT ONE WHICH IS TEN
PORTANTINO HAD APPLIED IN THE
PAST AND NOT BEEN SUCCESSFUL AND
I THINK THAT THAT THAT HAVING A
CONTINUOUS PROGRAM LIKE THIS AND
HAVING THE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
PLEASE ALLOW US TO PROVIDE
RESOURCES TO CONTINUE WORKING --
WITH SAN BERNARDINO AND TO GET
TO SUCCESS AND NOW I HOOK SEEING
HOW THEY CAN ACHIEVE SUCCESS AT
AND HOW THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
AND SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITIES
PROGRAM CAN WORK FOR THEM AND I
THINK THAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO
HAVE THAT LONGEVITY TO BE ABLE
TO BUILD THAT CAPACITY TO BE
ABLE TO UNDERSTAND HOW TO MARRY
A PROGRAM THAT IS AVAILABLE
WITH COMMUNITY NEEDS -- AND
THAT DOESN'T HAPPEN OVERNIGHT
AND SO I THINK THAT'S TRUE --
FOR A LOT OF THESE INVESTMENTS
PROGRAMS OR TO HAVE -- YOU KNOW
OBVIOUSLY EVERYONE WOULD LIKE
TO GET MONEY RIGHT AWAY BUT IF
YOU'RE NOT SUCCESSFUL TO KNOW
THAT YOU'RE ABLE TO MODIFY
TO GET SOME ASSISTANCE AND COME
BACK AGAIN MAYBE TO ENGAGE THE
COMMUNITY IN A NEW WAY I THINK
IS REALLY IMPORTANT AND VERY
VALUABLE WONDERFUL THANK YOU YOU
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I WILL
START WITH LOUISE AND SHE IS
THERE TO SEE YOU UP THANK YOU
FOR THE TWENTY MILLION FOR
THE HOUSING AND THEN OF COURSE
THE TCC MONEY THE THIRTY FIVE
MILLION FOR ONTARIO ARE WE ON
TIMELY BUT THOROUGHLY ENJOYED
GETTING TO KNOW THE SEARCH
TV CROWD -- GROWTH COUNCIL
AND THE WORK THAT YOU DO MY
QUESTION IS OF THE NEXT ROUND
OF GRANTS HOW DO YOU PLAN TO
BREAK THOSE DOWN THE LAST TIME
IT WAS THIRTY FIVE MILLION
FRONT TERRIO SEVENTY MILLION
FOR -- LA OUR FOR FRESNO
AND THIRTY FIVE MILLION FOR
-- FOR LA SO WHAT DO YOU GUYS
LOOKING AT THIS TIME WE HAVE
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS THIS
TIME ULTIMATELY IT IS IT IS
A DECISION OF OUR COUNCIL --
EACH OF OUR APPLICANTS I THINK
WE'RE HERE YOU KNOW WE'VE BEEN
ANTICIPATING WE DO TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE FOR APPLICANTS AND
JUST WAITING FOR IMPLEMENTATION
GRANT APPLICATIONS IN THIS
ROUND WE'VE INSTRUCTED THEM
TO -- SUBMIT APPROXIMATELY
TWENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLAR --
PROJECTS OF THE THE IF IF WE
SEE IF THE COUNCIL GOES FORWARD
WITH THAT WE WOULD END UP WITH
TWO APPROXIMATELY TWENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLAR GRANT GREAT
VERY GOOD THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OF MY NEXT QUESTION IS FOR HOW
BE REGARDING OUR GOLD LINE
BUT I FIRST HAVE TO HAVE TO
PUT IN A LITTLE PLUG FOR THE
MILLENNIALS I HAVE NO PROBLEM
OF TWO TWENTY SIX YEAR OLD
MILLENNIALS HOLES LIVE ON THEIR
OWN SUSTAIN THEMSELVES HAVE A
GOOD SAVINGS ACCOUNT AND EVEN
TAKE A MOMENT OUT TO DINNER
OCCASIONALLY BUT I WILL SAY
THAT THEY DON'T WANT TO LIVE
IN A BIG HOUSE WITH A LOT OF
PROPERTY THEY WANT A SMALLER
FOOTPRINT THEY LIKE THEIR LEFT
IN THERE WHO WERE AND THEY LIKE
AMAZON SO I THINK I'VE GOT GOOD
-- MAYBE THE BEST OF BOTH WORLDS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I'M CAN YOU
SHARE SOME OF THE CHALLENGES OF
THE GRADE SEPARATIONS AND THE
INCREASE IN THE COST WITH US
WELL WE HAVE ANTICIPATED ALL
THE GRADE SEPARATIONS IN OUR
BUDGET WITH THE EXCEPTION OF
ONE ONE WHICH WAS ADDED AFTER
OUR BUDGET TIMES THAT'S ABOUT
A THIRTY MILLION DOLLAR HIT
YOU ARE BUDGET THAT WE'RE GONNA
HAVE TO DEAL WITH -- ONCE WE GET
THROUGH THIS PROCUREMENT PROCESS
WITH REGARD TO THE GRADE
SEPARATIONS THEMSELVES -- THEY
ARE -- EACH OF THEM ARE UNIQUE
EACH OF THE COMMUNITIES WE GO
THROUGH -- WE SHUT DOWN A
CERTAIN STREETS FOR A CERTAIN
PERIOD OF TIME PRE DETOUR SO
THERE'S A LOT OF CHALLENGES ON
THE GROUND WITH WORKING WITH
THE CITY'S -- AND THEN WITH
REGARD TO THEIR QUEUE SEASON
APPROVES THESE CROSSINGS WE'VE
GONE THROUGH A PROCESS OF
STARTING ABOUT THREE YEARS AGO
GETTING COMFORTABLE WITH EACH
OF THESE CROSSINGS GETTING
THEIR APPROVAL OR AT LEAST
A CONDITIONAL APPROVAL ON THE
DESIGNS TO THE SO I THINK WE'RE
IN PRETTY GOOD SHAPE AT EACH
OF THESE CROSSINGS BUT FOR SOME
OF THE FINANCIAL ISSUES THAT WE
HAVE OBVIOUSLY THIS TECHNICAL
OF CONSTRUCTION ISSUES THAT
WE WILL FORCE SOURCING WHERE
WOULD YOU GO FOR THAT ADDITIONAL
THIRTY MILLION WELL WE'RE
GOING TO GO THROUGH A PROCESS
ONCE WE GET THIS PROCUREMENT
-- WE HAVE AN AGREEMENT WITH
METRO ARE OFTEN AGREEMENT OUR
PARTNERS AT METRO -- ALWAYS
ANTICIPATING THAT BECAUSE THESE
ARE ESTIMATES -- THESE ESTIMATES
WERE CREATED TO IN FOUR YEARS
AGO -- WE KNOW WHEN WE'VE BEEN
LOOKING FORWARD TO -- WITH
-- A BIT OF A SOME SLEEPLESS
NIGHTS THAT WE ARE GOING TO
YOU INTO A VERY HOT ECONOMY AND
THAT ESCALATION IS MUCH HIGHER
THAN WE ANTICIPATED AND WHEN WE
WENT TO THE SUPREME WITH METRO
WE HAVE SERIES OF STEPS THAT
WE WILL GO THROUGH -- TO FIND
OTHER MONEY MAKE CHANGES TO THE
PROJECT EVERYTHING FROM MINOR
CHANGES TO SIGNIFICANT CHANGES
INCLUDING CHANGING THE SCOPE
OF THE PROJECT WHICH WOULD BE
UNFORTUNATE BUT THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT WE MAY HAVE TO DO --
LOOKING DEPENDING ON WHAT WE'RE
THE ESTIMATES COMMITTEE WILL
ALSO HAVE POTENTIAL OF COMING TO
THE STATE LOOKING FOR ADDITIONAL
CAP AND TRADE DOLLARS IN THE
FUTURE AROUND -- IN LOOKING AT
OTHER POTENTIAL FINANCING OF THE
JOB THAT WE CAN DO TO MAKE IT
MORE ECONOMICAL IF IT COMES TO
THAT OKAY SO MY WORRY MY CONCERN
IS THAT ORIGINALLY THE MONEY
THAT YOU CAME TO THIS CAT CAT
TO THE STATE FOR THROUGH CAP AND
TRADE WAS FIFTY FIVE MILLION AND
THEN A BALLOON TO TWO HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY MILLION ULTIMATELY
WE APPROVE THAT AND GIVE THAT
TO YOU I'M NOT I'M NOT GONNA
LIE WAS IT'LL FRUSTRATE WITH
THAT BECAUSE THAT WAS ALMOST
SIX TIMES MORE THAN WHAT YOU
ORIGINALLY ASKED FOR SO I JUST
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
THE BEST USING OUR CRACK CAP AND
TRADE DOLLARS AND THAT YOU GUYS
ARE DOING EVERYTHING YOU CAN TO
CONTROL THOSE COSTS YES I THINK
I THINK WE HAVE ESSENTIALLY
WERE RIGHT NOW IT'S REALLY AT
THE MERCY OF THE CONTRACTORS WE
HAVE FOUR BIDDERS OF THOSE BIDS
ARE BEING REVIEWED RIGHT NOW
-- AND IT'S UP TO THEM IN THE
ECONOMY WHERE THESE KIDS COME
IN AT AND -- YOU KNOW I THINK
AS LONG AS OF OUR ENGINEERS ARE
ENGINEERING A SOLID -- I THINK
WE'VE WE'VE ANTICIPATED MOST
EVERYTHING WITH REGARD TO THE
PROJECT WAS THE ACCEPTANCE ONE
GRADE SEPARATION THAT'S ONE OF
THE REASONS WHY THE THE DOLLARS
GOING UP WE HAVE TO SAY WE HAD
THE SEVERAL SEPARATE SEPARATIONS
THAT WERE ADDED TO THE PROJECT
-- ALL THE THINGS THAT WE KNOW
ABOUT ACCOUNTED FOR -- THINKING
THE CITY'S UNDERSTAND THE
PROJECT VERY VERY WELL THEY KNOW
WHAT TO EXPECT THE UNKNOWNS FOR
US ARE REALLY THE ECONOMY AND
WHERE THE BIDDERS COME IN OKAY
OKAY VERY GOOD THANK YOU WHETHER
QUESTIONS REALLY FOR BOTH YOU
AND SIGN IF THE PROPOSITION
SIX IS GOES THROUGH
AND SB ONE IS REPEALED WHAT
DO WE DO NUMBER ONE AND
NUMBER TWO I KNOW THAT YOU
CANNOT -- ACTIVELY CAMPAIGN FOR
SOMETHING BUT BUT SINCE THIS
DIRECTLY AFFECTS BOTH OF YOU
DO WHAT ARE YOU DOING TO HELP
MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE ARE VOTING
NO ON PROPOSITION SIX WELL
FROM THE CONSTRUCTION THIRTY
STANDPOINT ARE WHEN ARE THIRTY
IS TAKING THE POSITION IN --
IN OPPOSITION -- ARE BELIEVE
OUR UNDERSTANDING IS OUR FUNDS
THE THREE HUNDRED MILLION
TWO HUNDRED NINETY MILLION
DOLLARS CAP AND TRADE THAT'S
ALL PART OF A LARGER PACKAGE
OF WHICH THE SP ONE FUNDS --
COME SUMMERS COMES FROM THOSE
FUNDS -- IT WILL HAMPER OUR
PROJECT OUR ABILITY TO COMPLETE
THE PROJECT -- IT'S A IT WILL
BE A HUGE GAP IF IT COMES DOWN
TO THAT OKAY THANK YOU THANK
YOU THEN AT THAT IT JUST SAYS
SO WE WE WE HAVE A LOT OF
EDUCATION TO DO ABOUT THE
ONE AND WE'RE DOING THAT AND
I THINK ALL THE AGENCIES --
PARTICIPATING OF DOING THAT
BUT BUT THIS ALSO IMPORTANT
TO THE MINE THE PUBLIC THAT'S
NOT NOT JUST A REGULAR WISPY
ONE IT IS ALSO THE FUTURE
TRANSPORTATION FUNDING YES
THAT MEANT WILL PROBABLY BE
POSSIBLE TO GET SO IT IS REALLY
IMPORTANT FOR THE PUBLIC TO
UNDERSTAND THE IMPLICATIONS
OF NOT HAVING A DISPUTE GREAT
GREAT WE AGREE BODY ON THIS
DIET IS WORKING VERY HARD TO
MAKE SURE IT SAYS ONE MAKE SURE
THE FOLKS THAT ARE BENEFITING
ARE WORKING EQUALLY AS HARD HARD
ART THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR HERE SENATOR
I LIKE IT LIKE THIS
SOMEONE NUMBER FOUR HUBBY
I'M SORRY SORRY YES FOR HOBBY
THE THE GOLD LINED HOUSE THREE
PHASES AND AS I MENTIONED MY
DISTRICT BEGINS AT FONTANA
DON'T GO ANYWHERE CLOSE TO MY
DISTRICT JUST TO CONFIRM YES
THAT'S CORRECT SO THE PEOPLE
IN MY DISTRICT DO NOT BENEFIT
AT ALL FROM WHAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT -- THEY'LL BE INDIRECT
BENEFITS OF COURSE BUT DIRECTLY
NO YOU KNOW SO IT'S A DRIVE TO
THE CLOSEST WOULD BE AMONG CLEAR
THEN THEY MIGHT BENEFIT YES
ALL RIGHT ALL RIGHT JUST WANTED
TO CONFIRM THANK YOU THANK YOU
THANK YOU WE APPRECIATE ALL OF
OUR PANELISTS FOR A PANEL ONE
AND WE'RE NOW GOING TO MOVE TO
PANEL TO WE WANT TO STICK AROUND
BECAUSE WE WILL HAVE A PUBLIC
COMMENT AND IF THERE'S A NEED
TO COME BACK TO YOU AT SOME
POINT WE LIKE TO BE ABLE TO DO
THAT -- SO LET ME JUST INTRODUCE
OUR PANEL TO THIS IS GOING TO
ADDRESS ISSUES OF CONNECTIVE
ITTY BITTY OUR FIRST PANELIST
IS DOCTOR RAVEN A WHARF DOCTOR
WOLFE IS EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE SAN BERNARDINO COUNTY
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY READY
HE MANAGES A DIVERSE BUDGET THAT
DEALS WITH PROJECTS RANGING FROM
REGIONAL TRANSPORTATION POLICY
STATE YOUR QUALITY PROGRAMMERS
TODAY -- HE WILL --
HI DOCTOR WILL
FOR YOU CALLING ME
IT'S WILLIE BROWN SAID I
ANSWER THE CALL I
THINK I WILL NOT BUT JUST
KNOW THAT -- FORMER SPEAKER WAS
CALLED ALL RIGHT ALL RIGHT A
TODAY -- HE WILL BE DISCUSSING
THE PROGRESS OF HIGHWAY TRANSIT
AND REAL CONNECTIVITY IN THE
GREATER SAN BERNARDINO COUNTY
AREA WILL CONDUCT WILL OUR
SECOND OCCURS ENTER ENTER
OUR LEAHY THE CHIEF EXECUTIVE
OFFICER OF METRO HAS BEEN A
LEADER IN PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION
FOR OVER FORTY YEARS BEFORE
BEING APPOINTED AS A CEO OF A
MEASURE LINK IN APRIL OF TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN HE HAS SERVED
AS A CEO OF LA METRO FOR SIX
YEARS WE WORK TO BILL TRANSIT
AND HIGHWAY PROJECTS VALUED
AT OVER FOURTEEN BILLION
DOLLARS MR LAHEY IS A LOS
ANGELES NATIVE AND HE BEGAN
HIS CAREER AS A BUS OPERATOR
FOR THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
RAPID TRANSIT DISTRICT IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY ONE WHICH I
BELIEVE MY DAD WAS A MEMBER
OF OUR TO DO AT THAT POINT
-- OUR THIRD PANELIST IS STEVE
FOX STEVE IS CURRENTLY A
SENIOR REGIONAL PLANNER FOR THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF GOVERNMENTS SPECIALIZING
IN REGIONAL TRANSIT PLANNING
AND ANALYSIS CURRENT PROJECTS
INCLUDE PREPARATION OF THE
PASSENGER RAIL CONGESTION
MANAGEMENT TDM ELEMENTS OF
THIS GAG GAG TWENTY TWENTY
REGIONAL TRANSPORTATION PLAN
SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITY STRATEGY
WHICH PROVIDES AYE BLUEPRINT FOR
TRANSPORTATION IMPROVEMENTS A
SUSTAINABLE GROWTH AND STAGNANT
AND SKAGGS REGION ENCOMPASSING
SIX COUNTY IS A HUNDRED AND
NINETY ONE CITIES AND EIGHTEEN
MILLION RESIDENTS MISTER FOX
HAS OVER TWENTY FIVE YEARS OF
EXPERIENCE AND TRANSPORTATION
PLANNING ANALYSIS AND SCHEDULING
WITH ADDITIONAL EXPERIENCE IN
YOUR QUALITY TRANSPORTATION
ANALYSIS AND LAND USE
SUSTAINABILITY PLANNING AND ARE
WORTH WORTH A PRISONER ALLEN
WALK WALK MAYOR PRO TEM ALLEN
WALKING OR HAS BEEN A MEMBER
OF THE ONTARIO CITY COUNCILMAN
NEARLY TWENTY FOUR YEARS HE
HAS A KEEN UNDERSTANDING OF
POLICY LOCAL GOVERNMENT AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT DURING
HIS TENURE ON THE ONTARIO
CITY COUNCIL THE CITY HAS
EXPERIENCED RECORD ECONOMIC
SUCCESS ALLEN WAS CRUCIAL
IN REGAINING LOCAL CONTROL
OF THE ONTARIO INTERNATIONAL
AIRPORT AND AS PRESIDENT OF THE
AIRPORT AUTHORITY OVER SEEING
UNPRECEDENTED SUCCESS WILL TURN
AROUND BUSINESS AT THE AIRPORT
AND A HUGE ECONOMIC IMPACT
OF THE CITY AND REGION ALLEN
REPRESENTS ON TERRIO ON MANY
REGIONAL BOARDS AND IS KNOWN
IN THE REGION AS AN EXPERT
ON TRANSPORTATION PLANNING
AND OUR LAST ANALYST LIST
IS UP AT ALL GREEN YELLOW
APPALL BECAME PRESIDENT CEO
OF THE INLAND EMPIRE ECONOMIC
PARTNERSHIP IN THE TWENTY
TEN HE SERVES ON THE BOARD OR
MOBILITY TWENTY ONE A COALITION
THAT PURSUES REGIONAL SOLUTIONS
TO TRANSPORTATION CHALLENGES
ADDITIONALLY NO SERVES ON THE
SKAGGS LOCAL LAND USE AND
ECONOMICS COMMITTEE CAL STATE
SAN BERNARDINO'S FOUNDATION
BOARD THE LETTER TRANSPORTATION
CENTER ADVISORY BOARD REGIONAL
ECONOMIC ALLIANCE LEADERS OF
CALIFORNIA CAMPAIGN FOR COLLEGE
OPPORTUNITY BOARD REALTOR
REDLANDS AND THE CALIFORNIA
STEWARDSHIP NETWORK BOARD WE
WELCOME ALL OF OUR PANELISTS
FOR PANEL TO DOCTOR WILL FEEL
IT IS ALSO GOOD MORNING CHAIR
HOLDEN SENATOR LEYVA ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RAY IS -- THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY THIS MORNING TO
SPEAK IN FRONT OF THIS PANEL AS
A REPRESENTATIVE OF THE SAN
BERNARDINO COUNTY TRANSPORTATION
AUTHORITY THE STORY OR AGENCY
CREATED A THREE STATUTE TO FOR
ALL TRANSPORTATION PLANNING
AND PROGRAMMING WORK DONE IN
SAN BERNARDINO COUNTY I WANT
TO START WITH A KIND OF WHERE
WE ARE AND WE CAN GO BACK TO
THE FIRST LIFE LEASE -- THIS
IS AN IMAGE OF A RIBBON CUTTING
CEREMONY WE CELEBRATED LAST YEAR
AN EXTENSION OF THE METRO LIKE
SYSTEM THEM FROM THE CURRENT
-- FROM ITS FORMER TERMINUS AT
THE SANTA FE DEPOT WHICH DOUBLES
AS OUR OFFICE SPACE ADJACENT
TO THE BEE AND SS IN A MORAL
DISABILITY IN THE WESTERN PART
OF THE CITY OF SAN MARINO A TO
THE HARD PART OF THAT CITY AT
HE IN RIALTO STREET JOINING
AT A AT A TRANSIT CENTER --
CREATING CONNECTIVITY BETWEEN
A BUS RAPID TRANSIT LINE THE
GREEN LINE OPERATED BY ON
THE TRANS FROM CAL STATE SAN
MARINO TO THE NORTH OR THE LOMA
LINDA UNIVERSITY TO THE SOUTH
AND THE IMPORTANCE OF THIS IS
THE CAN ACTIVITY THAT WE'RE
CREATING IN TRANSIT SYSTEMS
IN OUR COUNTY BUT THIS IS ONLY
THE BEGINNING AND WE ARE MOVING
FORWARD IF WE CAN MOVE TO THE
NEXT SLIDE WE'RE MOVING FORWARD
-- ANY ANY IN PROCUREMENT
RIGHT NOW TO BUILD A NINE MILE
EXTENSION OF THE METRO LINK
SYSTEMS FROM THE ENTRANCE A
CENTER IN THE HEART OF THE
CITY OF SANDRA DINO EAST TO THE
UNIVERSITY OF REDLANDS AND SO
WE ARE INVESTING IN OUR COUNTY
TO EXPAND TRANSIT OPTIONS TO
THE EASTERN PART OF THE PART OF
OUR DAHLE WHICH THEN ALSO OPENS
UP THE METROLINK SYSTEM DOWN
TO THE COACHELLA VALLEY AS WELL
ONE OF THE REALLY INTERESTING
FAXES THAT I WANT TO POINT OUT
HERE IS WHAT OPERATE METROLINK
TRAINS ONCE IN THE MORNING
AND ONCE IN THE EVENING TO
DOWNTOWN RELATIVES ON THIS NEW
SERVICE SPECIFICALLY TO PICK UP
P. COMMUTER TRAFFIC BUT BUT
OFF PEAK HOURS WERE ACTUALLY
GONNA IN INTERVIEWS A DIFFERENT
SERVICE MODEL RUNNING MORE
FREQUENT SERVICE USING A DIESEL
MULTIPLE UNIT WHICH IF ANYBODY
HAS USE THE SPRINTER SYSTEM THAT
RUNS ALONG THE SEVENTY EIGHT
BETWEEN OCEANSIDE AND ESCONDIDO
YOU GET A SENSE OF WHAT THAT
VEHICLE LOOKS LIKE I'LL HAVE AN
IMAGE LATER BUT THE REALLY COOL
THING ABOUT THAT IS THAT
VEHICLE TO SITES NOW MEETS THE
FEDERAL RAILROAD ADMINISTRATION
USE CRASH COMPLIANCE
REQUIREMENTS WHICH MEANS THAT
WE CAN ACTUALLY OPERATE THAT
VEHICLE INTERMIXED WITH THE
HEAVY PASSENGER RAIL MODEL
THAT IS MUCH LIKE TODAY AND
INTERMIXED WITH FOR EIGHT AND
WE'LL GET BACK TO THAT POINT AS
WELL ON A FEW MINUTES SO NOW I
WANT TO JUST TALK ABOUT KIND OF
WHERE WE ARE MOVED BACK TO KIND
OF THIS PORTION OF THE WESTERN
PORTION OF OUR COUNTY AND AND
THEY CAN ACTIVITY TO THE EASTERN
PORTION OF LOS ANGELES COUNTY
A COUPLE OF YEARS AGO OR AGENCY
COMPLETED AN INTERNAL STUDY
THAT LOOKED AT AND DIFFERENT
ALTERNATIVES TO BRING
TRANSACTIONS -- INTO THE ONTARIO
INTERNATIONAL AIRPORT PROPERTY
AND WE WE STARTED WITH A VERY
BROAD SUITE OF OPTIONS AND
NARROWED IT DOWN TO REALLY
TO ALTERNATIVES ONE BEING
AN EXTENSION OF THE GOAL LINE
FROM MONTCLAIR DOWN TO THE
ONTARIO PROPERTY AND THE SECOND
BEING A CONNECTION OUT OF THE
RANCHO CUCAMONGA STATION CLOSE
TO WHERE WE ARE HERE INTO THE
AIRPORT PROPERTY CONNECTING AND
METROLINK SYSTEMS DOWN INTO THAT
PROPERTY -- BOTH OF THEM ARE
-- SIMILARLY -- PRICE WHEN YOU
LOOK AT THE CAPITAL INVESTMENTS
THE ONE OF THE THINGS ONE OF
THE QUESTIONS WE ASKED IN THE
STUDY WAS THE BENEFIT AND IF
YOU LOOK AT THE MAP RIGHT HERE
AND I DON'T HAVE THE ABILITY TO
USE A POINTER WITH THESE THESE
THE WAY WE'RE PRESENTING HERE
TODAY BUT I MEAN THE GOAL LINE
EXTENSION ESSENTIALLY CUTS
THROUGH THE WESTERN EDGE OF
SAM'S COUNTY AND SO WHEN YOU
CONSIDER THAT THE TAXPAYERS OF
SAN BENITO COUNTY OF THE ONES
THAT ARE GOING TO BE FUNDING
ON ANY ANY INVESTMENTS THIS TO
ANY CONNECTIONS TO THE ONTARIO
INTERNATIONAL AIRPORT WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
RECOGNIZING THAT CONTRIBUTION
AND MAKING SURE THAT THEY INDEED
ARE BENEFITING FROM THAT --
SIGNIFICANTLY AND SO THAT'S
ONE OF THE PARAMETERS OF THE
WE'RE CONTINUING TO GRAPPLE
WITH THIS WE LOOK AT WHAT IS
THE RIGHT INVESTMENT TO GET INTO
THE AIRPORT PROPERTY ANOTHER
STUDY THAT WE JUST RECENTLY
COMPLETED WAS WITH LA A METRO
AND IT REALLY GETS BACK TO USE
MY COMMENTS ABOUT THE THE DM USE
THE EIGHT MEETING FIRE'S CRASH
COMPLIANCE REQUIREMENTS AND SO
THEY CAN OPERATE ON EXISTING
INFRASTRUCTURE ON THE EXISTING
-- METROLINK SYSTEMS AND SO
WE STUDIED WITH LA MEASURE
THE IDEA OF OF REPLACING
OFF PEAK METROLINK SERVICE
WITH THE DMU SERVICE ALL THE WAY
INTO TO UNION STATION -- THERE'S
A A PINCH POINT -- JUST EAST
OF EL MONTE IS YOU GET PAST --
LAKE CITY COLLEGE IF YOU KNOW
YOUR RUNNING THROUGH THE THE
CENTER OF THE FREEWAY THERE --
AND SO THERE'S SOME DIFFICULTIES
TRYING INTERVIEWS MORE FREQUENT
SERVICE IN THAT PORTION -- BUT
CERTAINLY FOR A VERY LIMITED
CAPITAL INVESTMENTS TO A LARGELY
JUST PURCHASES VEHICLES YOU CAN
ENTITIES SIGNIFICANTLY HIGHER
FREQUENCIES -- ON THAT LINE THEN
YOU HAVE TODAY DURING OFF PEAK
HOURS AND THE REASON IS THAT
SENATE'S ORDER -- AND BE POINTED
TO THIS -- ALONG THE GOAL LINE
WE'RE SEEING TRANSIT ORIENTED
DEVELOPMENT CROPPING UP ALL
ALONG THE SAME READING A LINE IN
BOTH COUNTIES AND SO THE DEMAND
AND THE TWO YEAR DEEP BRAIN
IS DIFFERENT THAN THE CURRENT
MODEL THAT METRO X.'ERS WHICH
IS A COMMUTER SERVICE PRIMARILY
FOCUSED ON MOVING PEOPLE FROM
THE OUTLYING COMMUNITIES INTO
DOWNTOWN LA AND THEN BACK IN THE
EVENINGS -- YOU'RE GONNA
HEAR A IN A FEW MINUTES FROM
STEVE SOCKS YOU MENTIONED MR
CHAIR TO THAT HE'S GOING TO TALK
ABOUT THE SKAGGS STUDIES REALLY
LOOKED AT THE INTER CONNECTED
MIDI ISSUES BETWEEN THE TWO
COUNTIES AND I WANT TO THANK US
ON AND THINK STEVEN AND THE TEAM
THAT WORKED ON THAT IT'S IT'S
BEEN A LONG LABORIOUS PROCESS
BUT AN IMPORTANT PROCESS TO
REALLY TRY TO HONE IN ON WHAT
IS THE RIGHT INVESTMENTS MOVING
FORWARD AND THE RECOMMENDATION
ARISING OUT OF THAT IS THAT
THERE NEEDS TO BE MORE WORK --
AND AND WE HAD TO SPC TA OR
ARE CERTAINLY WELCOMING THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CONTINUE THE
DIALOGUE WE'VE ALREADY THE
-- CONVENED A ROUND TABLE
DISCUSSION AT THE AIRPORT
WE BROUGHT TOGETHER INDUSTRY
LEADERS INCLUDING YES ARE A
MAJOR ROAD GIS COMPANY
WORLDWIDE PLAYER IN THAT FIELD
OUT OF RED LINES WE BROUGHT IN
-- BUSINESS -- COALITION
IS BROUGHT IN ON UNIVERSITY CAL
STATE -- SIMMONS UNIVERSITY AS
WELL AS UNIVERSITY OF REDLANDS
-- CITY OF ONTARIO ONTARIO
INTERNATIONAL AIRPORT TO A
REPRESENTATION AS WELL AS MY
AGENCY TO REALLY SIT DOWN AND
TALK ABOUT YOU KNOW HOW ARE
WE GOING TO MOVE FORWARD TO
CREATE THAT CAN ACTIVITY --
IT'S BECOMING THE WARM WARM
PART YOU'RE GOING TO HEAR FROM
ALLEN WANT IF YOU MINUTES --
ON KIND OF THE PROJECTIONS
FROM THE AIRPORT AND WHEN
AND WHY THIS IS BECOMING AN
ISSUE THAT WE REALLY NEED
TO GRAPPLE WITH VERY QUICKLY
BUT -- WE'RE ACTUALLY OF THE
ROUND TABLES CONVENING AGAIN
IN MID NOVEMBER AND WE'RE GONNA
WE'RE GONNA GIVE AN UPDATE ON
THE AIRPORT -- ON THE PASSENGER
DEMAND GROWTH EXPECTED THROUGH
TWENTY FORTY -- FROM WHERE
IT IS TODAY AND THE SIGNIFICANCE
OF THAT RAMP UP WE'RE ALSO
GOING TO START TALKING ABOUT
-- YOU KNOW WHERE IS THE LIKELY
HOOD OF A STATION CITING ON OR
NEAR THE ONTARIO INTERNATIONAL
AIRPORT PROPERTY -- WE'RE GONNA
GONNA GIVE AN UPDATE ON THE
SKETCH THAT HE THAT YOU'LL ALSO
HEAR TODAY'S REPORTING OUT ON
RESULTS AND THEN DISCUSS WHAT
OUR NEXT STEPS ARE AND IT'S
IMPORTANT AGAIN -- GIVEN THE
THE GROWTH PROJECTIONS THAT
WE NEED TO CONTINUE TO MOVE
THIS DIALOGUE FORWARD -- YOU
CAN HEAR I THINK SMART LATER
ON THIS PANEL AS WELL ABOUT --
THE SUCCESS THIS METROLINK IS
HAD AND THEIR SCORE APPLICATION
IT'S A A GREAT INVESTMENT BY THE
STATE RECOGNIZING THE IMPORTANCE
OF THE METROLINK SERVICE
THROUGHOUT -- THE FIVE COUNTY
REGION AND -- ONE OF THE KEY
THINGS ON THE SAN BERNARDINO
ONLINE IS A RECOGNITION THAT
WE NEED TO AT LEAST GET TO
THIRTY MINUTES BI DIRECTIONAL
SERVICE FREQUENCIES AND SO
THERE'S THIS FUNDING IN THAT
PLAN TO HELP US GET THERE THERE
WITH AGAIN THIS HIGHLIGHTS THE
THE GROWING LEAD THAT TOT ALONG
THIS LINE BOTH COUNTIES IS
BROUGHT TO THE FOREFRONT OF THE
RIDERSHIP ON DECEMBER EIGHTEEN
ONLINE IS ONE OF THE HIGHEST
IN THE ENTIRE METROLINK SERVICE
AND I THINK THAT'S AN IMPORTANT
AGAIN WHEN WE TALK ABOUT WHAT
IS THE RIGHT CONNECTIONS TO
MAKE INTO THE AIRPORT PROPERTY
-- WITH THE EXTENSION TO THE
UNIVERSITY OF REDLANDS AS MUCH
LIKE SERVICE IN THE DMU SERVICE
WE'RE GOING TO USE THAT AGAIN AS
I MENTIONED EARLIER OPEN UP NOT
ONLY THE EAST VALLEY BUT PEOPLE
THAT COME FROM AS FAR AWAY AS
THE COACHELLA VALLEY CAN NOW
USE TRANSIT ONCE THEY GET INTO
THE SAME READING OF THE ALLEY TO
REALLY GET ANYWHERE IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA SO I THINK THIS IS
REALLY EXCITING TIMES BUT THE
SAM READING ONLINE ALSO LATELY
WE DO TALK ABOUT CONNECTIVITY
THE AIRPORT NOT ONLY
HELPS BRING IN PEOPLE FROM THE
EASTERN PART OF THIS COUNTY
AND IN RIVERSIDE COUNTY BUT
ALSO FROM LA COUNTY FROM UNION
STATION ALL THE WAY TO THE
AIRPORT PROPERTY SO THERE'S I
THINK THURMOND THIS OPPORTUNITY
-- BELIEVE THAT A LOT OF WORK
TO DO IF WE COULD GO TO THE LAST
SLIDE I THINK ONE OF THE MOST
EXCITING THINGS THAT WE'VE BEEN
WORKING ON THIS BCT A FOR THE
LAST SEVERAL YEARS NOW I TALKED
ABOUT THE DIESEL MULTIPLE UNITS
AND THIS IS AN IMAGE OF WHAT
WE'RE ACTUALLY FOR CARING FOR
OUR REDLANDS PASSIONATE RAIL
SERVICE AND YOU SEE THERE'S
THREE VEHICLES THEY'RE THEY'RE
CONNECTING THERE'S A LEADING
AND TRAILING CAR THERE --
INTERCHANGEABLE SO THE TRAIN
CAN MOVE BACK AND FORTH AT WILL
BUT -- IN THE MIDDLE THERE IS
THE -- THE POWER OUR VEHICLE
THE POWER AND WHAT THEY DO IS
THEY HAVE DIESELS CHAIR FOR
DIESEL GENERATORS AND THAT'S
GOOD BECAUSE THAT'S THE CLEANEST
DIESEL TECHNOLOGY THAT'S OUT
THERE TODAY BUT WE ARE YOU
ARE YOU BEING IN THE WORST AIR
QUALITY BASES IN THE
COUNTRY THAT THAT WASN'T WHAT
IT ENOUGH AND WE'RE INTRODUCING
THE SERVICE IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE
IT JUST DIDN'T SEEM LIKE IT MADE
SENSE ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU PAID
ATTENTION TO WHAT TEST LESS THAN
DOING AND AND THE ADVANCEMENTS
IN ZERO EMISSION TECHNOLOGY
VEHICLES -- AT DIFFERENT LEVELS
OF OF THE SPECTRUM AND SO
WE DID DID WE WERE SUCCESSFUL IN
THIS LAST ROUND HE -- GRANTS
FOR -- THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS TO
PURCHASE EIGHT ANOTHER VEHICLE
AND TOOK AND TYLER ZERO OR NEAR
ZERO EMISSION TECHNOLOGIES AND
I THINK THAT'S REALLY EXCITING
BECAUSE IT'S THE FIRST OF
ITS KIND IN NORTH AMERICA AND
WORD WORD WORD MOVING THIS
FORWARD -- HERE IN SAN BENITO
COUNTY AND IT'S SOMETHING
THAT COULD COMPLETELY RESHAPED
THE METROLINK SERVICE AT SOME
POINT IN THE FUTURE WE COULD
HAVE A BATTERY POWER TRAININGS
THAT ARE RUNNING THROUGH OUR
COUNTY AND THROUGHOUT THE ENTIRE
SYSTEM IN A SHORT PERIOD OF
TIME AGAIN USING THE EXISTING
TRACKS NOT HALF AND TO BUILD NEW
SIGNIFICANTLY NEW INFRASTRUCTURE
SO EXCITING TIMES WERE NOT JUST
TIED TO THE IDEA OF BATTERY
TECHNOLOGY BUT ALSO LOOKING
AT FUEL CELL TECHNOLOGY AND
SO IT TRULY IS A PILOT TO
TRY TO UNDERSTAND WHAT THE
BEST APPROACH IS WITH THAT'LL
THAT'LL CLUED IN AND CERTAINLY
ANSWER QUESTIONS AT THE END OF
THE PANEL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU AND WE WILL -- WILL
COME UP ART LEAHY ARTISTS
YOU MAKE YOUR WAY TO THE TO
THE -- PODIUM THE AND LET ME
ALSO A RECOGNIZE AND INTRODUCE
MY GOOD FRIEND OF THE MIRROR OF
RANCHO CUCAMONGA DENNIS MICHAEL
WHO WAS ABLE TO JOIN US IS SO
BEAR WITH US WELCOME YOU AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR HOSPITALITY
ALLOWS USERS YOUR GREAT CITY
GOOD MORNING A PLACE A LOW
TIER OF FATHER FORM I WOULD DO
SO -- BACK A FEW DECADES THANK
YOU -- -- I'M GONNA HAVE A
POWER POINT HERE TO SHOW YOU IN
JUST A MOMENT I DO WANT TO POINT
OUT A FEW THINGS MAKES METALINK
RIDERSHIP IS ACTUALLY UP
AND -- IS YOU KNOW THIS
THAT'S VERY UNIQUE RIGHT NOW
BECAUSE MOST TRACK TO SYSTEMS
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA HAVE
EXPERIENCED SIGNIFICANT LOSS OF
RIDERSHIP -- PART OF THE REASON
FOR THIS WAS A VERY INNOVATIVE
PROGRAM A FEW YEARS AGO --
ELECTION WHICH I'VE NEVER SEEN
TO SUCCESSFULLY CUT CUT AIRS ON
THE ANTELOPE VALLEY LINE WHICH
HAS ALL THE SERVICE MUCH LUCK
ASSEMBLY IN THE LINE OF WRITER
CHAIR CLIMBS AND SO THE OVER
TIME OF WITH INCREASED RIDERSHIP
XTC ACHIEVED A FARE CUT WHICH
WAS REVENUE NEUTRAL ARE I'VE
NEVER I'VE NEVER SEEN THAT MY
CAREER BEFORE IT'S ALWAYS A WILL
BUT IT DOESN'T HAPPEN VERY OFTEN
SO IN JULY WHEN WE REDUCE THE
FARES ON A SALMON IN A LINE TO
RECEIVE THE SAME THING RIDERSHIP
GROWTH GROWTH AND I BREAKING
EVEN YET BUT THAT WILL CERTAINLY
BE OUR OUR GOAL REMAINS IN
THE SCORE PROGRAM A METAL MAKE
RECEIVE OF ONE POINT TWO BILLION
DOLLARS OF RACERS TYPES OF STATE
MONEY A FEW MONTHS AGO -- WITH
THIS WILL BE WORKING ON IMPROVE
SIGNAL SYSTEMS DOUBLE TRACKING
TROUBLE TRACKING WHAT THAT MEANS
IS THAT MOST OF OUR SYSTEMS
A TWO THIRDS OF IT IS SINGLE
TRACK LIKE A ONE LANE ROAD ROAD
ONE LEBRON WITH BI DIRECTIONAL
TRAFFIC WHAT THAT MEANS IS IF
THAT LAND GETS BLOCKED FOR ONE
REASON OR ANOTHER EVERYTHING
COMES TO A STOP IT LIMITS THE
FREQUENCY OF THE SERVICE AND
ALSO ON TIME PERFORMANCE
ALSO BY CLINTON'S PROGRAM IN
THE STATE ARE WE WILL BE ABLE
TO OPERATE MORE FREQUENT SERVICE
WAS WITH BETTER RELIABILITY
IN FACT ONE OF THE THINGS I'M
TALKING TO FOR EXAMPLE BURBANK
AIRPORT ABOUT IS WHAT IF WE CAN
GET TO THIRTY MINUTE OR FIFTEEN
MINUTE FREQUENCIES FROM UNION
STATION UP TO BURBANK AIRPORT I
THINK ULTIMATELY WE ARE BE ARE
ARE PUTTING THE SAME KIND OF
FREQUENCIES ON THE SALMON IN A
LINE IN THE ORANGE COUNTY LINE
A LOTS OF GOOD THINGS OUT THERE
HAPPEN I DO WHEN I KNOW FOR YOU
THAT THAT ARE IN THE NATION
-- METALINK IS A PIONEER
OF POSITIVE TRAIN CONTROL THIS
ALL FLOWED FROM THE CHATSWORTH
ACCIDENT WHICH IS A LITTLE OVER
TEN YEARS AGO WHICH RESULTED IN
VERY SERIOUS ISSUES -- ISSUES
-- SO THERE'S ARE A FEDERAL
DEADLINE OF -- DECEMBER THIRTY
ONE HAPPY TO SEE AND PLACES WE
WILL BE FINE WITH THAT WORKING
WITH AMTRAK AND WITH THE FREE
OF ROADS I THINK WILL BE OKAY
-- THERE'S GONNA BE OTHER
REYNOLDS ALL AROUND THE COUNTRY
WHO WILL NOT BE COMPLIANT --
AND RIGHT NOW THE FRA IN THE IN
THE CONGRESS AND TO BE NO MORE
EXTENSIONS FOR SO -- IT'LL BE
AN INTERESTING YEAR NEXT YEAR
TO SEE WHAT HAPPENS BY THE WAY
ATC HAS COST A LOT OF MONEY
OF WE WE DID THIS BECAUSE OF
THE EXPERIENCE WITH THE WITH
THE ACCENT BACK WHEN WHEN OUR
BOARD MEMBERS WERE COMPLETELY
COMMITTED TO SAFETY AS A NUMBER
ONE VALUE AND PRIORITIES SO I'M
VERY PROUD OF THAT METROLINK IS
EIGHTY FIVE COUNTY JOINT POWERS
AUTHORITY -- WE RUN SERVICE IN
SIX COUNTIES OUR FUNDING COMES
PRIMARILY THROUGH THROUGH THE
THE COUNTIES I WOULDN'T KNOW
THAT BECAUSE MENTAL EXIST AS A
COMMUTER RAILROAD THAT GENERATES
A GREAT DEAL OF STATE AND
LOCAL MONEY WHICH THEN GOES TO
THE COUNTY SOMEONE OFFSETTING
INVESTMENT WHICH THEY MAKE AND
AND TO US WE RENT AMOUNT THREE
HUNDRED TRAINS A DAY -- WE HAVE
ABOUT FIVE HUNDRED FIFTY MILES
OF RUN AWAY MUCH OF WHICH IS
MOST OF WHICH AS I SAID IS A
SINGLE TRACK RIGHT NEXT MAYES
SO THERE'S A MAP OBVIOUS YOU CAN
SEE THAT OUR SYSTEM OF PARALLELS
THE FIVE NORTH AND SOUTH OF ONE
THIRTY FOUR OF THE SIXTY THE TEN
OF A NINETY ONE -- THAT'S VERY
IMPORTANT WILL COME BACK TO
THAT IN A MINUTE AND LET ME
JUST OBSERVE BEFORE I GO FORWARD
THAT IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA OUR
FREEWAY SYSTEM IS BASICALLY AT
FIXED CAPACITY WHEN I WAS IN
ORANGE COUNTY I THOUGHT WE WOULD
WIDEN FREEWAYS ARE DOUBLE DECK
FREEWAYS THAT'S NOT GONNA HAPPEN
THE PUBLIC WILL NOT ACCEPT
SO WE HAVE BASICALLY A FIXED
CAPACITY FREEWAY SYSTEM THERE
WON'T BE ANY NEW FREEWAYS IN
THE LA BASIN OTHERS ONE PROJECT
IN ORANGE COUNTY IN THE MIDDLE
OF FOUR OR FIVE FEW PROJECTS
AND SAM AND DEAN OR OVERSIZED
AT SOME POINT THE FREEWAYS ARE
DONE SO WE CONFRONT GROWING
POPULATION WHICH IS SPREADING
OUT BECAUSE OF HOUSING COSTS
IN THE IN THE INNER PART OF
THE COUNTIES US WITH A GROWING
POPULATION SPREADING OUT PRETTY
MORE DEMAND ON THE FREEWAYS
WITH A FIXED CAPACITY FREEWAY
SYSTEMS NO -- I DON'T GO ON THE
WEST SIDE OF LA ANYMORE MORE OF
YOU KNOW IT'S TOO MISERABLE TO
GET OVER THERE TO UNLESS I AM
FORCED TO I DON'T DO IT -- I
WOULD GO THERE TO WATCH AND
SEE IF YOU SELL A HOWEVER THAT
WOULD BE IT THAT WOULD BE A
MERITORIOUS UP SO IT'S IMPORTANT
THESE THESE THESE LINES CARILLO
THE FREEWAY SYSTEM RUN COME
BACK TO THAT -- AND SHOW THAT
MITCHELL MAKE IS ACTUALLY AN
EXCELLENT INVESTMENT FOR THE
COUNTIES AND OTHERS EXPLICITLY
SO -- IF WE MEASURE OF YOUR
RIDERSHIP AS WE DID FOR DECADES
AS BOARDINGS METAL LIKE A
SMALL FORTY FORTY FIVE THOUSAND
A DAY COMPARED TO ONE AND A
HALF MILLION AT METRO I SOUNDS
VERY SMALL BUT THE TRIPS ARE
MUCH LONGER THAN THEY ARE ON
ON SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA BUSES
ORDERS OR RAIL LINES TO THE
AVERAGE TRIP LENGTH MIGHT BE
FOUR MILES FOR A HALF THREE AND
A HALF MILES OUR TROOPS OR ABOUT
THIRTY MILES LONG SO BECAUSE
THEN IF YOU MEASURE RIDERSHIP
IN TERMS OF PASSENGER MILES
THEN METROLINK IS THE SECOND
BUSIEST CARRIER IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AFTER METRO BUT
HIGHER FOR EXAMPLE IN ORANGE
COUNTY RIVERSIDE COMBINE BECAUSE
OF CRIPPLING THING THAT'S
IMPORTANT BECAUSE THOSE ARE
CARS OFF THE FREEWAY NEXT PLEASE
SO -- ARE FAIRS COVER ABOUT
FORTY FORTY FOUR PERCENT OF
OUR OPERATING BUDGET THAT IS
HIGHER THAN OTHER CARRIAGES OF
THE CALIFORNIA BY SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT LA IS NOW I THINK ABOUT
EIGHTEEN PERCENT WERE AT FORTY
OF CELLS OF THE USERS ON
METROLINK ARE PAYING A BIGGER
PERCENTAGE OF THE FREIGHT RATE
THAN THEY ARE OTHER BOYS IN
AND RAIL SYSTEMS IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA NEXT NEXT SO IF WE
IF WE THEN TAKE THOSE FINGERS
TOGETHER ALONG ON THE LONG TRIPS
IF THE HIGH PASSENGER MILES AND
THE HIGH FAIRS WHAT WE SEE IS
THERE'S A VERY LOW SUBSIDY PER
PASSENGER MILE ON METAL LIKE
MUCH ALIKE IS THE ORANGE ONE UP
THERE ARE NOT QUITE AS AS LOW
AS AN OLD VALLEY WHICH IS A LONG
DISTANCE BUS CARRIER FROM AN
OLD VALLEY DOWN TO LA BUT MUCH
LOWER THAN OTHER SYSTEMS AROUND
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA IT CENTS
GOODBYE NOW IF WE TAKE THAT
NUMBER AND SUBTRACT FROM IT THE
AMOUNT OF MONEY WHICH METROLINK
GENERATES THE STATE AND FEDERAL
FUNDS WHICH GO TO THE COUNTIES
NEXT SLIDE PLACES WE COME OUT
WITH THE NET NEUTRALITY SUBSIDY
OR COST PER PASSENGER MILE
ACOSTA LA METRO ABOUT TEN CENTS
FOR EVERY PASSENGER MILE THAT
OCCURS WITHIN LOS ANGELES COUNTY
IN ORANGE IS A LITTLE LESS
THAN THAT YOU SEE SAM READY ON
RIVERSIDE AFFAIRS WELL MENTOR
MENTOR IS A LITTLE BIT HIGHER
THIRTY CENTS PER PASSENGER MILE
BUT EVEN THEN THAT IS VERY CHEAP
COMPARED TO OTHER TRANSIT
SYSTEMS SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA NEXT
PLEASE THEN IF WE LOOK AT THE
FACT THAT UNLIKE LIKE ALL SPEAK
THE ORANGE COUNTY METRO WHERE I
WORKED MAJORITY THE WRITERS ARE
LOW INCOME TRANSIT PENANCE GOD
BLESS WHAT'S GOING TO WORK OR
THEY'RE GOING TO SCHOOL MANY OF
THEM MOST ON PERHAPS OUR TRANSIT
ATTENDANCE THEY DON'T HAVE CARS
MAJORITY ELECTRONIC WRITERS
HOWEVER DO HAVE CARS EIGHTY MORE
THAN EIGHTY PERCENT OF THEM HAVE
AN AUTOMOBILE WHAT THAT MEANS IS
THEY ARE DISCRETIONARY WRITERS
THEY CAN TAKE THE FREEWAY IF
THEY WANT TO BUT THEY PREFER
TO TAKE METROLINK WHICH IS A
BLESSING TO THOSE PEOPLE WHO
ARE ON THE FREEWAY -- NEXT
PLEASE SO WHAT IS THE MAP AGAIN
AGAIN SO WHAT HAPPENS YET THIS
IS MICHAEL MICHAEL REPRESENTS
A VERY LOW COST OPPORTUNITY
TO REALLY FREEWAYS CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT BECAUSE WE HAVE A
FIXED COMPASSIONATE FREEWAY
SYSTEM WITH INCREASING DEMAND
AND FUTURE NEXT ELECTIONS
AT SIX OH THIS IS JUST A FEW
THINGS HERE THIS IS ANNABELLE
WE ALREADY DISCUSSED AT THE FARE
INCREASE OUR THE FAIR CUT THEM
TO WRITE A SHORT CLOSE NEXT NEXT
IN HERE WE'RE GONNA SEE WE HOPE
TO SEE THE SAME THING ON A SAM
READING ONLINE LINE NEXT NEXT
DOES JUST STATION ONCE BY THE
WAY YOU CAN SEE WE HAVE A LOT OF
BUSY STATIONS FOR A CAST LA IS
GOING RIGHT NOW -- THAT'S A THIS
IS A VERY HEALTHY SIR WAS THAT
-- THEY WERE VERY PLEASED WITH
NEXT NEXT OKAY I'VE ALREADY
DISCUSSED EVERYONE'S NEXT NEXT
NEXT NEXT OKAY OKAY THAT'S IT
ALL WRAPPED UP WITH AND I'LL
BE PLEASED TO ANSWER LATER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE THANK YOU
THANK YOU THE NUMBER
WELCOME MISTY FOX THE SENIOR
REGIONAL PLANNER OSCAR
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF REYES
AND SENATOR LATELY THEY'VE
RIGHT RIGHT I HAVE A POWER
POINT THANK YOU USE
US I'M HERE TODAY TO GIVE YOU
AN OVERVIEW OF OUR LOS ANGELES
IN THE SALMON AND YOU KNOW
IN OUR COUNTY TRANS AND REAL
CONNECTIVITY STUDY THAT WE
JUST COMPLETED WE CALL IT THE
INTER COUNTY STUDY FOR SHORT OR
EXPRESSLY THIS IS A STUDY
AREA WERE RIGHT IN THE HEART
OF IT OF IT -- INCLUDES THESE
SEVEN CITIES YOU SEE THREE
SHADED CORRIDORS THOSE ARE THE
CORRIDORS WE CONCENTRATE ON
THE TOP ONES AND SOME NATURAL
EXAMINED IN ONLINE LINE WHAT
THE FUTURE GOLD LINES ON CLEAR
THE MIDDLE MIDDLE IS DECEMBER
DINO FREEWAY AND THE LOWER ONES
METROLINK RIVERSIDE LINE NEXT
SO AS YOU KNOW THERE'S A LOT
OF INVESTMENTS -- IN THE WORKS
IN THIS CORRIDOR THE GOLD MINE
-- TO MONTCLAIR POSSIBLY TO
ONTARIO AIRPORT OR -- THE
METROLINK SOMEBODY IN A LINE
AS MR LEAHY SAID IS MOSTLY
SINGLE TRACK TRACK THERE'S A
LOT OF DOUBLE TRACK PROJECTS
BEING PLANNED SOME OF WHICH
ARE GOING FORWARD WITH THE
SCORE PROGRAM ROOM -- THAT'S
JUST BEEN AWARDED -- EXPRESS
LANES WOULD BECOME -- EXTENDED
FROM -- BELMONT EL MONTE ALL
WAY TO READ WOMEN'S EVENTUALLY
SO THAT OPENS UP THE POSSIBILITY
FOR NEW ANY FASTER EXPRESS BUS
SERVICES RUSSELL LOOKING AT BUS
RAPID TRANSIT SERVICES IN THE
STUDY AREA INCLUDING CONNECTING
TO THE -- I'M CHAIR OR AIRPORT
WORK AND SO WE STARTED A
STUDY -- AT THE REQUEST OF LA
METRO AND SPECTRE NEXT PLEASE
SO AND -- METRO WANT TO LOOK
AT -- THE EFFECTIVENESS AND
WHAT HAPPENS WITH THE GOLD LINE
RUNNING ALONGSIDE THE METROLINK
ASSEMBLY DINO LINE THEY'LL RUN
RIGHT NEXT TO EACH OTHER FROM
THE POMONA NOR STATIONS TO
MONTCLAIR WON THE GOLD MINE IS
BUILT AND SB CGA WANTS TO LOOK
AT -- THE BENEFIT AND VALUE REAL
TRENDS INVESTMENTS AND SOMEONE
YOU KNOW COUNTY AND CONNECTING
TO THE AIRPORT WORK AS A DOCTOR
WOLFE HAD MENTIONED NEXT PLEASE
LEAVE SO OUR OVERALL GOAL WAS
DETERMINED THE OPTIMUM MIX AND
SERVICE LEVELS OF ALL THESE
DIFFERENT MODES HYBRID RAIL
BEING THE DMU THE DOCTOR BOTH
MENTIONED -- LIKE THE FUTURE
REDLANDS RAILING SPRING SAN
DIEGO COUNTY COUNTY SO THERE
ARE GONNA BE COMING TOGETHER
IN THE IN THIS AREA NEXT
PLEASE SIR I WE HAD WE REMAIN
OBJECTIVE IS A SYSTEM MARKET FOR
INTRA AND INTER COUNTY TRANSIT
RAIL TRAVEL IN THE CORRIDOR
INCLUDING -- ORIGINS AND
DESTINATIONS TO THE AIRPORT FOR
-- POTENTIAL RIDERSHIP THE
TRAVEL ECONOMIC BENEFITS LOOKING
AT CAPITAL AND OPERATING COSTS
WITH THE DIFFERENT ALTERNATIVES
AND THEN RECOMMENDING THE
PATH FORWARD NEXT PLEASE
THE NATURE OF THE STUDY A
HIGH LEVEL OF PLANNING STUDY
OUR AIM WAS NOT TO RECOMMEND
A PARTICULAR PARTICULAR
ALTERNATIVES OR PARTICULAR MODE
NOT APPROPRIATE TO DO SO AT THIS
LEVEL BUT WE DID GET A LOT OF
INFORMATION OUT OF THE STUDY
WE DID RIDERSHIP FORECASTING
OPERATIONS AND MAINTENANCE
COSTS FOR THE FUTURE AFTER
TWENTY FORTY -- CAPITAL COSTS
-- NEXT PLEASE LEAVE WE
HAD A LOT OF PUBLIC OUTREACH
-- IN THIS IN THIS STUDY STUDY
AREA -- WE HAD REPRESENTATIVES
FROM THE SEVEN CITIES FROM
CAL TRANS -- TO DISTRICT SIX
SEVEN EIGHT EIGHT -- WE ALSO
HAD A REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE
OPERATORS METROLINK OMNITRANS
FOOTHILL TRANSIT OF COURSE AS PC
TA AND LA METRO AND WE
HAD TWO ROUNDS OF OPEN HOUSES --
DURING TWO SUMMERS AND A LOT
OF STAKEHOLDER INTERVIEWS NEXT
PLEASE SO WE DID A TRAVEL
MARKET ANALYSIS OF FIRST BEFORE
WE STARTED WORKING ON THE
ALTERNATIVES AND WE FOUND THAT
-- THERE ARE ONE POINT ONE
MILLION TRIPS ENTER OR LEAVE
THE STUDY AREA WE ALSO
FOUND THAT THERE'S ONE POINT
SEVEN MILLION TRIPS WITHIN
THE STUDY AREA SO THAT'S A LOT
AND THEN YOU NOTICE INVESTMENTS
IN THE PLANNING WAS A LOT OF
USE WAS SERVICES BUT WE FOUND
THAT THERE'S A VERY WHAT WE
CALL POLICY CENTRIC CREEK TRAVEL
PATTERN AS IN THIS AREA OF
PEOPLE ARE GOING ON DIAGONALLY
NORTH SOUTHEAST WEST AND IF
YOU LOOK AT THE NORTH SOUTH
SOUTH OF US SERVICES IN THE
STUDY AREA THE FREQUENCY OF
THEM WAS MUCH LESS THAN THE EAST
WEST SO THAT'S SOMETHING THAT
WE WERE THAT WE WERE LOOKING AT
-- AND THEN AND THEN THAT WERE
RIGHT IN THE HEART OF OUR TOP
CITY FARES -- WE HAVE RANCHO
CUCAMONGA TO ONTARIO ONTARIO AT
UPLAND IN UPLAND SURROUND TRADE
WITH THE TOP THREE CITY PAIRS OF
THOSE SEVEN CITIES IN OUR STUDY
AREA AREA NEXT PLEASE PLEASE
SO DID TO PHASE IN SCREENING
-- PHASE ONE PHASE TWO PHASE
ONE WAS VERY HIGH LEVEL THIRTY
EIGHT ALTERNATIVES BASED ON
PREVIOUS STUDY AS THE TRAVEL
MARKET ANALYSIS WE DID --
THERE'S SOME OF THE CRITERIA
THAT WE USE TRAVEL TIME TRANSFER
TIME NUMBER OF TRANSFERS MILES
OF NEW INFRASTRUCTURE MOSTLY FOR
RAIL AND THEN WE CAME UP BASED
ON THAT WITH THE FOR BUILD
ALTERNATIVES OF WEEKLY PACKAGE
MORTALLY -- AND WE ALSO HAVE
A NO BUILD ALTERNATIVE WHICH
IS NORMAL A TRANSPORTATION
SYSTEMS MANAGEMENT ALTERNATIVE
WHICH IS NORMAL IN THE FOR
BUILD ALTERNATIVES AND AGAIN
WE DID -- MORE ROBERT MUCH
MORE ROBUST ANALYSIS FOR
THE PHASE TWO NEXT PLEASE
SO HERE WE ARE PACKING IDEA
ALTERNATIVE DISPLAY LIGHT RAIL
TRANSIT ALTERNATIVE COMMUTER
RAIL HYBRID RAIL AND BUS RAPID
TRANSIT INCLUDING EXPRESS
BUS NEXT PLEASE SO FOLLOWING
ARE SOME MAPS OF THE DIFFERENT
ALTERNATIVES ANOTHER PRETTY
BUSY THE NO BUILDING CLUES
OF THE GOLD LINES MONTCLAIR'S
SINCE IT'S FUND AND -- THE RED
ONE IS RAIL WAY OVER ON THE
EAST YOU THINK LINE THE WEST
VALLEY CONNECTOR THAT'S GOING
TO BE SOMEBODY ON COUNTY SECOND
I CAN BE ARE TO SERVICESINS
WHICH RUNS MOSTLY ALONG THE
CURRENT ON A TREND LINE SIXTY
ONE ONE -- FROM DOWNTOWN ONTARIO
-- SERVING ON TERROR AIRPORT
IN IN THE PHASE ONE OF IT OF IT
GOING UP TO ONTARIO MILLS MALL
NEXT PLEASE AND THEN OTS
AN ALTERNATIVE GSM ASSEMBLY
IT TAKE THE EXISTING NETWORK
OF OF BUS AND RAIL TRANSIT AND
YOU AUGMENT THE FREQUENCIES AND
-- -- IT IT'S SOMEWHAT OF
WITH THE METROLINK DID DOESN'T
LOSE SOME NEW DOUBLE TRACKING
PROJECTS TO INCREASE THE LEVEL
OF MANAGEMENT SERVICE NEXT
PLEASE A LIGHT RAIL ALTERNATIVE
OPTION -- WE KNOW WE LOOKED AT
IT NOW -- AND ARE TRUE ALIGNMENT
AND TO GET DOWN TO THE AIRPORT
AS WELL AS -- AND OUR OUR AND
ALIGN ALONG CUCAMONGA CREEK
AND AGAIN THEIR CONCEPTUAL
THEY'RE NOT CHOSEN ALIGNMENTS
NECESSARILY TO MOVE FORWARD WHAT
WE USE THEM TO DO THE RIGHT OR
CERTAIN HOUSES AND THE COSTS
AND SO FORTH AND AND
-- THE CUCAMONGA CREEK OPTION
-- RUNS JUST PASS OUT A POINT
ON THE SAN BERNADINO ALIGN RIGHT
AWAY AND THEN USES CUCAMONGA
CREEK TO GET DOWN TO THE AIRPORT
SO WE HAVE TWO PHASES OF
COMMUTER RAIL -- PHASE ONE
AND PHASE TWO THE PHASE ONE
AND WANT TO LOSE THE NEW
RAIL ALIGNMENTS REAL CAPITAL
PROJECT TO GET DOWN FROM RANCHO
CUCAMONGA TO THE AIRPORT FOR
AND IT ALSO INCLUDES EXPRESS
SERVICE ON THE SAN MARINO LINE
PHASE TWO INCLUDES MORE
DOUBLE TRACKING PROJECTS
SO AND HAS HIGHER LEVELS OF
MUCH LINK SERVICE AND HAS
A HYBRID REAL SERVICE RUNNING
LONG DECEMBER AND YOU KNOW
LINES DOCTORAL OF MENTIONED
AND THEN AN EXPRESS SERVICE
FROM DOWNTOWN A LATELY TO THE
AIRPORT -- ON WITH THE MITCHELL
EXAMINED YOU KNOW SERVICE
NEXT PLEASE AND THEN WE HAVE
A HYBRID REAL ALTERNATIVE THAT
EXTENDS THE REDLANDS RAIL --
WEST WEST FROM DOWNTOWN SAN
MARINO -- TO THE AIRPORT OR
TO DOWNTOWN ON CHERRY ON AND ALL
THE WAY TO THE CITY OF INDUSTRY
NEXT PLEASE AND THE FINAL ANSWER
UNDER THE -- THE ARE TO EXPRESS
BUS IT INCLUDES A DEDICATED
BUS SERVICE FROM MONTCLAIR
TO THE AIRPORT OR -- FROM THE
GOAL LINE STATION A NEW B.
R. T. SERVICE -- RIGHT HERE ON
HAVEN AVENUE BETWEEN SHAPE THE
COLLEGE AND THE CITY OF CHINO
AND THAT'S ABOUT IT ON THE
ALTERNATIVES SO WE HAD OUR
FOUR MAIN GOALS UP THERE
THAT WE USE TO RATE RIGHT TO
-- SETS THE BUILD ALTERNATIVES
WE ALSO THE ECONOMIC IMPACT
ANALYSIS NEXT LINE LINE
AND THEN THIS IS A BAR CHART
SHOWS MORE OR LESS -- HOW
ALL OF THE ALTERNATIVES
DID -- TO THOSE GOALS
AND TO THE BLUE IS JUST AS
ALL ALL ALL ALL OF THE BEIJING
WANTS EQUAL LEVEL TOGETHER
SO -- -- YOUR AIR SOME HIGH
LEVEL RIDERSHIP INFORMATION AND
COSTING INFORMATION FOR COSTS
ON JUST ARRANGE BECAUSE OF THE
HIGH LEVEL OF THE STUDY THIRTY
AND NEXT SLIDE SLIDE AND SO
ARE OUR GENERAL CONCLUSION --
AND RECOMMENDED PATH FORWARD
IS THAT ALL OF THE ALTERNATIVES
-- DO MEET THE GOALS TO VARYING
DEGREES WE KNOW THAT WE'RE
GONNA HAVE MORE BRG SERVICE
IN THE AREA WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE MORE EXPRESS BUS IN THE
AREA MORE METROLINK SERVICE
IN THE AREA AND ADDITIONAL
RAIL SERVICE IN THE AREA AND
SO ARE TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE
JUST LAST WEEK FINALIZE A
STUDY AND WE'RE OFFICIALLY
HANDING IT OVER TO LA METRO IN
SPECTRE I CAN CLOSE MY STUDY
I CAN TAKE ANY QUESTIONS
LATER THANKS I APPRECIATE
THAT THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I
GET TO BE THE FIRST TO SAY GOOD
AFTERNOON HERE TODAY I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR HOLDEN FOR
OCTOBER HOLDING AT THIS OLD
HITTING THIS HEARING HERE IN
THE INLAND EMPIRE WHICH IN MY
OPINION IS THE EMERGING ECONOMIC
CENTER SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
PRIMARILY DUE TO WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT THE -- INCREDIBLE
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE
SYSTEM THAT WE HAVE ON CENTER
LEYVA ASSEMBLY MEMBER REYES
THANK YOU BOTH SO MUCH FOR THE
SUPPORT THAT YOU'VE SHOWN ON
TO THE ENTIRE REGION WHEN IT
COMES TO TRANSPORTATION ISSUES
NOW YOU KNOW I I WEAR A LOT OF
DIFFERENT HATS HOUSE TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT WHY WAS I INVITED
TO THIS I WASN'T SURE WHO WAS
REPRESENTING AND I FIGURED IT
OUT OUSTER CHAIR I FIGURED OUT
BECAUSE AS YOU'VE HEARD FROM
C. E. O.'S -- SP CTA
METROLINK THE GOAL LINE AND
SEND GAG AND I ACTUALLY SERVE
IN THE GOVERNOR BUSH OF ALL OF
THEM SO I'M HERE TO BE BE SET IS
BASICALLY ONE THE ONLY ELECTED
OFFICIAL THAT THIS CAN BE
ADDRESSING YOU TODAY I AM
I AM I WANT TO JUST PUT MY CCAC
OUT ON FOR JUST A MOMENT AND I
WANT TO TALK ABOUT HOW IMPORTANT
ACTIVITY IS AND ACTUALLY SEE GAG
IS THE CENTER FOR FACILITATION
COLLABORATION AND CONNECTIVE
ITTY FOR ALL SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
ONE OF MY OVER RIDING RIDING
HIS PRISONER'S GAG THIS YEAR
IS THAT WE ARE THE ONLY PLACE
FOR ALL HUNDRED NINETY ONE
CITY SIX COUNTY AND ALL THE
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITIES AND
COUNCILS OF GOVERNMENTS COME
TOGETHER EITHER SO IT'S REALLY
UP TO US TO FILL THE GAPS TO
MAKE SURE THEY CAN ACTIVITY
EXISTS IN ORDER TO MAXIMIZE THE
INVESTMENT WE HAVE IN ALL OF
OUR INFRASTRUCTURE NOW YOU'LL
NOTICE ON I HAVE NO POWER POINT
SO I NEED ALL OF YOU TO CLOSE
YOUR EYES AND VISUALIZE WHAT I'M
TALKING ABOUT I I DON'T DO THAT
KIND OF STUFF I'M HERE TO TALK
ABOUT THE AIRPORT PRIMARILY
BEFORE YOU START I WANT TO THANK
ALL OF YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT A
BRING IN LOCAL CONTROL TO OUR
AIRPORT AS WELL THIS IS SUPPORT
OF ALSO THE CALIFORNIA AND
I CAN TELL YOU THAT ALL YOUR
SUPPORT HAS BROUGHT SUCCESS YEAH
THE MEDIAN SIX ASSET TO OUR
AIRPORT CERTAINLY ALWAYS BELIEVE
THAT LOCAL CONTROL WOULD HELP
IN THE GROWTH OF THE AIRPORT
NEAR BRIDGE BACK AND IT TO
HAPPEN THIS QUICKLY BUT IT IS
EVERYONE AND EMBRACE IT IF YOU
HAVEN'T BEEN TO OUR NEW -- PORT
A STRONG INVITE SHOULD THERE
BE HAPPY TO GIVE YOU A TOWARD
WHAT YOU'LL FIND IS A VIBRANT
ENERGETIC AIRPORT PEOPLE --
THERE WE HAVE NO FLIGHT AIRLINE
SIGN -- OF COURSE WE HAVE DAILY
NONSTOPS TO TAIWAN REALLY FIRST
YOUR PORTENT SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
OUTSIDE OF LA ACTS TO PROVIDE
THAT JET BLUE IS BACK AT DEALEY
NONSTOP SINCE JFK FRONTIER IS
RUNNING MANY -- CORRECT NONSTOP
STEELY JUST STARTING TO ORLANDO
AND AND MANY MORE TO COME
ON THE CARGO SIDE YOU PS IS
EXPANDING THAT AXES ANNOUNCED
THE ONE WHO'S GOT WHICH A HUB
AIRPORT AND OF COURSE THAT
THE THE GROWTH AND CARGO JUST
ENCOURAGES MORE BUSINESSES TO
LOCATE IN THE AREA LOGISTICS AND
WAREHOUSING AND CREATE FOR MANY
THOUSANDS OF NEW JOBS FOR THE
REGION WHICH REALLY INITIATES
EVEN MORE THE COMMITTEE FOR
HOUSE AGAIN AND WE'RE IN THE
MIDST OF A BUILDING FIFTY
THOUSAND HOUSES SELF ON TERIA
INNER THAT WE ANNEXED TO THIS
A LOT OF DEVELOPMENT GOING
ON HERE IN THE AREA WE'VE
SEEN WRITER AND ON SHIP SHIP
INCREASING AT OUR AIRPORT FROM
ABOUT TWO POINT FIVE MILLION
WHICH IS WHERE IT WAS WHEN
WE TOOK CONTROL REPTILES FIVE
MILLION PASSENGERS A YEAR NOW
-- WE'VE SEEN DOUBLE DIGIT
GROWTH EVERY MONTH SINCE WE
TOOK OVER THE AIRPORT AND --
IN THE TWENTY ONE TO THIRTY
PERCENT INCREASE EVERY MONTH
IN CARGO SO WE'RE REALLY REALLY
EXCEEDING ANY EXPECTATIONS
THAT WE HAVE ONTARIO'S NOW
KNOWN AS THE FASTEST GROWING
AIRPORT IN THE COUNTRY WE'RE
TAKING WE'RE TAKING NOTICE BY
EVERYBODY AND AGAIN I COULD
JUST FALL BACK TO YOUR SUPPORT
AS WELL AS A SUPPORT FROM
EVERYONE IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
ONE IN GETTING AIRPORT AND
SECONDLY IN USING OUR AIRPORT
IT'S REAL IMPORTANT NOW THAT
RE TRAIN PEOPLE IN THE WRITER
SHOULD HAVE IT FOR SO LONG
ONTARIO EITHER DIDN'T HAVE
THE FLIGHTS AVAILABLE OR THEY
WERE TOO EXPENSIVE AND THAT
WAS REALLY OUR PRIMARY FACTOR
THAT WE WANTED TO ESTABLISH
AND WE'VE BEEN SUCCESSFUL BOTH
WITH THE INCREASED AMOUNT OF
IRAQ NONSTOP FLIGHT AND WE'VE
LOWERED THE FEARS ALMOST ALL
THE DESTINATIONS THAT WE FLY
TO SO I THINK IT IS MUCH MORE
ACCOMMODATING FOR ALL THE FOLKS
REGION -- THEY DON'T NEED TO
MAKE THAT DRIVE TO LOS ANGELES
I HAVE A LOT OF FRIENDS WE WORK
TOGETHER WITH THE COMMUNITIES
RUN ELLIE ACTION THEY'RE
EXTREMELY HAPPY THAT I TRAILS
SUCCESSFUL BECAUSE IT RELIEVING
A LOT OF THE REJECTION AN IMPACT
TO CITIES LIKE MICHAEL WOULDN'T
ALSO GONE DOWN -- ON THIS GAG
STANDPOINT I DO WANT TO MENTION
THAT THAT I'VE ESTABLISHED IN
NEW COMMITTEE AT SKAGGS JONES
WAS EPICALLY WITH AVIATION WERE
REESTABLISHING WILL WORK ON
THE AVIATION TASK FORCE MADE
UP REPRESENTATIVES FROM ALL THE
AIRPORTS IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
AND IN FACT WE EVEN REACHING
ACROSS THE BOARD AND HE WANTED
IF WE CONSIDER THEM PART OF THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AVIATION
ON NETWORK IN AND REALLY WHAT
I WOULD LIKE TO DO IS REALLY
TALK ABOUT THE CONCEPT AGAIN
OKAY NEGATIVITY BUT CAN ACTIVITY
BETWEEN AIRPORT CREATING A
SYSTEM OR NETWORK EVER PORTAL
SAID IT IS THIS KIND OF FEELING
OF COMPETITIVENESS BETWEEN THE
AIRPORT BECAUSE ALL THE FOR CASH
SHOW THAT AT SOME POINT EVEN
IF EVERY SINGLE YOUR POOR BILLS
TO CAPACITY WE STILL WON'T BE
ABLE TO MEET THE AVIATION INTO
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA SO THERE'S
NO NEED FOR US TO BE COMPETING
BECAUSE WE'RE ALL GOING TO MEET
HER IN A STRANGE WAY AS IT IS
NOW ALMOST EVERY YEAR IMPORTANT
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA HAS HAD ITS
CONSTRAINTS ONTARIO IS DOING
REALLY WELL WITH PORN FROM OUR
CATCHMENT AREA BUT WE ARE ALSO
GOING TO SERVE AS A RELIEVER
AIRPORT FOR AREN'T OFFER ORANGE
COUNTY FOR LOS ANGELES COUNTY
-- SAN DIEGO COUNTY -- ALL LOOK
INTO ONTARIO SO CAN ACTIVITY
IS REALLY REALLY IMPORTANT OUR
COMMITMENT TO OUR COMMUNITY WHO
HAS BEEN EXTREMELY SUPPORTIVE
OF THE GROWTH OF THE AIRPORT
IS THAT WILL SUPPORT THE
GROWTH OF THE AIRPORT UP TO
ABOUT THIRTY TO THIRTY FIVE
MILLION PASSENGERS A YEAR BUT
ONLY IF WE'RE ABLE TO GET ON
THERE WITHOUT THE ENVIRONMENTAL
IMPACTS THAT WE'RE SEEING IN LOS
ANGELES YOUR PORTENT COMMITTEE
REPORT OUR COMMITMENT TO THE
COMMUNITY IS THAT WE WILL
CONTINUE TO GROW THE AIRPORT AS
LONG AS PEOPLE ARE NOT DRIVING
THEIR OWN CARS INTO OUR AIRPORT
THEY NEED TO REACH HERE ORDINAL
TURNED ABOUT EITHER BY TRANSIT
BY TRAINING BY WHATEVER BY
RICKSHAW I DON'T HEAR WE WILL
TAKE EVERYBODY ANYWAY THAT WE
CAN YOU KNOW PEOPLE SAY YOU
SUPPORT THE GOAL LINE SUPPORT
I SUPPORT EVERYBODY ANYTHING
THAT WILL BRING PEOPLE TO OUR
AIRPORT WE ABSOLUTELY SUPPORT
WORK IT'S ALWAYS BEEN IN OUR
PLAN TO CREATE A MULTI MODAL
TRANSPORTATION CENTER THAT WILL
BE A PLACE THAT COMMUTER RAIL
WILL COME IN AND AMTRAK COME IN
LIGHT REAL FROM BOTH DIRECTIONS
EAST AND WEST AS WELL AS TRANSIT
-- TN SEASON OF COURSE ECONOMYJ
VEHICLES WE USE THAT FACILITY AS
WELL SO THAT IS OUR FUTURE PLAN
PLAN PROBABLY WHEN WE -- BILL
TERMINAL THREE STRUGGLE BETWEEN
THE TWO AND JUSTIN TERMINALS
WHAT I WOULD REALLY LIKE TO
SEE IS WHAT YOU SEE IN MANY
COUNTRIES AROUND THE WORLD IS
WERE THE TRANSPORTATION CENTER
IS ACTION PART OF THE TERMINAL
SO AS SOON AS YOU GET OUT OF
OUR TRAINER YOUR BUS OR WHATEVER
YOU'RE ALREADY IN THE TERMINAL
AND YOU CAN GO AHEAD AND AND
PURSUE YOUR YOUR AVIATION --
WE'RE IN THE MIDST OF BUILDING A
NEW CUSTOMS FACILITY -- IN ORDER
TO ACCOMMODATE THE FLIGHTS THAT
CHINA MEXICO AND THERE ARE A LOT
OF OTHER INTERNATIONAL CARRIERS
THAT HAVE EXPRESSED INTEREST
IN BEGINNING SERVICE OR ONTARIO
KIND OF WAITING FOR US TO GO
AHEAD AND CONTINUE THE GROSS FOR
THE CUSTOMER DISABILITY IS UNDER
PLAN REVIEW RIGHT NOW WE'RE
LOOKING TO EXPAND THAT AS AN
EXTENSION OF TERMINAL TO GOING
ON THE EAST SIDE OF TERMINAL
TO TO HELP ACCOMMODATE SOME THE
WIDE BODY PLANES WILL BRING IN
AND FROM OVERSEAS WE HAVE A
DOUBT THAT ARE ARE ARE ON ON
CUSTOMERS SO THAT WE HAVE NOW WE
HAVE ALL THE NEW TECHNOLOGY WE
HAVE GLOBAL INJURY AT THE KIOSK
AND EFFECTIVE HAPPY TO SAY THAT
WHEN I TOOK THE INAUGURAL FLIGHT
POINT BY ONE BACK TO ONTARIO
I CLEAR CUSTOMS AND FIVE MATCH
YOU TRY DOING THAT A DAILY I I'M
TELLING YOU THE MOST I'VE EVER
SEEN IS LIKE FIFTEEN MINUTES IN
ONTARIO SO IT WORKS OUT WORK
IS WE'RE ONLY DOING LIKE ONE
PLANE AT TIMES HAD LIKE FIFTEEN
PLANES SO OUR CHALLENGE IS
ALWAYS GOOD AND TO MAINTAIN THE
CONVENIENCE THAT WE'VE ENJOYED
WITH THREE OR FOUR MILLION
ANNUAL PASSENGERS WHEN WE REACH
THIRTY MILLION PASSENGERS BUT
THAT'S ALWAYS SOMETHING THAT
WE'RE CONSIDERING WE WANT TO
HAVE THE INFRASTRUCTURE IN PLACE
PRIOR TO THE ROLE OCCURRING SO
AS FAR AS CAN ACTIVITY BETWEEN
DIFFERENT TRANSFORMS I AND I I
PERSONALLY SEAT I TAKE NATURAL
LIKE WHENEVER LOS ANGELES AND
THEN WE DO NOT HAVE AN ACTIVITY
THAT WE NEED BETWEEN TRANSIT
AND AND METROLINK YOU SEE THAT
LOS ANGELES COUNTY BECAUSE NOT
ONLY DOES METRO RUN BUSES BUT OF
COURSE THEY HAVE BEEN A SIMPLE
BUS LINES THAT ARE ABLE TO MEET
THE TRAINS AND TAKE PEOPLE WE
HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO DO THAT
AND OUR COUNTY IS THAT SOMETHING
THAT WE'RE WORKING ON HERE AND
GERMAN AND YOU KNOW COUNTY ON
-- IT IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
THAT WE NOT ONLY CREATE THE
LINKS BETWEEN TRANSFER ASIAN
AND THE AIRPORT OR TRAIN
TRANSPORTATION THE VERSION
COMMUNITIES THAT WERE SERVING SO
WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT CAN ACTIVITY
TRANSPORTATION IT'S PROBABLY THE
FOREMOST IMPORTANT TO THE GROWTH
OF THE AIRPORT AND THE SUCCESS
OF THE AIRPORT -- SO I GUESS THE
REPORT CARD RIGHT NOW IS WE'RE
DOING GREAT AND ALL OF YOUR WORK
PAID OFF WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE
DOING WHAT WE'RE DOING -- WE
HAVE A WHOLE NEW INFRASTRUCTURE
SIDE THE AIRPORT AGAIN IF YOU
HAVEN'T BEEN THERE GOT TO HANG
OUT WITH GENE SIMMONS FOR THE
DAY HE OWNS ROCK GROUP GREAT
RESTAURANT IS THE ALL TIME LINE
-- OUR PARTNERSHIP DELAWARE
NORTH TO SUPPLY A RESTAURANT
SERVICES HAVE INVESTED OVER SIX
BILLION DOLLARS SO THERE'S ON
A RESTAURANT WITH KING PARK IS
THERE -- AND AND THE IMPORTANT
THING IS TO OPEN SO WHEN YOU
GET OFF AN AIRPLANE THERE'S
ACTUALLY A RESTAURANT TO EAT AT
IN FACT -- AGREEMENT WITH THEM
IS THAT THEY MUST REMAIN OPEN
FROM AN HOUR BEFORE THE FIRST
LIGHT LIGHT INTO AN HOUR AFTER
THE LAST FLIGHT AND THEY CAN'T
CHARGE MORE THAN TEN PERCENT
OVER STREET MARKET ON THEIR
FOOD SO YOU DON'T HAVE TO PAY
TEN DOLLARS FOR FIVE DOLLAR
HAMBURGER DOESN'T SOUND REAL
EXCITING BUT I'LL TELL YOU WHEN
YOU'RE TRYING TO SERVICE THE
NEEDS OF YOUR CUSTOMERS YOU HOW
CAN I MAKE IT A VERY COMFORTABLE
CUSTOMER EXPERIENCE SO THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE STRIVE TO DO
YOU -- TO REALLY THAT'S IT YOU
KNOW YEAH I THINK YOU ONCE AGAIN
FOR TALKING ABOUT CAN ACTIVITY
TALKING ABOUT TRANSPORTATION AND
TALKED ABOUT AIRPORT OFFICIALS
SPECIAL BECAUSE EVERYTHING IS
ABOUT BRINGING PEOPLE TIME TERRY
AIRPORT WHICH OBVIOUSLY BENEFITS
THE ENTIRE ARE YOU CHANGE
BANKING THANK YOU WE APPRECIATE
YOUR LEADERSHIP AND WE --
HAVING SERVED ON AN AIRPORT
AUTHORITY FOR OVER TWENTY
YEARS -- I I KNOW WHICH WE
DEALING WITH AND YOU'RE YOU'RE
DOING GREAT WORK WERE --
INTEGRATING NOT ONLY THE MODEL
MODEL -- CONCEPTS BUT ALSO
GROWING IT AS A BUSINESS SO
GRADUATION SO IN THAT REGARD
-- UP PAUL NEO APOLOGIES
FOR THAT'S OKAY PRONOUNCING
YOUR YOUR NAME CORRECTLY EARLIER
BUT -- BUT WELCOME OKAY THANK
YOU THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
CENTER LEYVA ASSEMBLY MEMBER
REYES -- -- I WANNA BE SERVICE
OR BRIDGE BETWEEN THE FIND
PRESENTATIONS YOU'VE HEARD
ABOUT WHAT'S GOING ON -- IN
THE FUTURE CHANNEL WHICH IS
GOING TO BE ABOUT -- HOW WE FUND
-- WHAT NEEDS TO HAPPEN AND YOU
JUST TO -- BRING US BACK INTO
THE THE CONCEPT OF THE INLAND
EMPIRE REGION AND ITS IMPORTANCE
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WHEN
I WAS BORN IN FIFTY YEARS AGO
THERE WAS LESS THAN A MILLION
PEOPLE IN THE INLAND EMPIRE AND
TODAY THERE'S FOUR POINT SIX
AND STUDIES TELL US THAT --
WE'RE ON OUR WAY TO A SIX SIX
OR SEVEN POINT FIVE -- BY
TWENTY FORTY FIVE SO THAT'S AN
AMAZING AMOUNT OF GROWTH AND
SO THIS DISCUSSIONS -- WE
THANK YOU FOR -- BECAUSE IT'S
A IT'S INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT
-- DISCUSSION NOW WHEN I WAS
GROWING UP AND UP AND WE WERE
ON THE NINETY ONE FREEWAY AND WE
WENT PAST TYLER STREET -- WE
GOT MY BROTHER AND I GOT REALLY
EXCITED BECAUSE YOU'RE ONLY
FOR REASONS TO GO PAST TYLER
STREET ON A NINETY ONE GOING
WEST AND THAT WAS THE ANGEL
GAME THE BEACH DISNEYLAND OR NOT
SO VERY FAR SO IN MY LIFETIME
I'VE SEEN THIS RATE REGION
TRANSFORM AND NO MORE
I THINK IN THE HISTORY OF
THIS REGION DO WE ALL HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO DEFINE THE FUTURE
FOR THE REGION -- YESTERDAY
-- THE BLOOMBERG -- POINTED
OUT THAT THE INLAND EMPIRE FOR
THE LAST FIVE YEARS HAS LED THE
COUNTRY IN JOB GROWTH TWENTY
TWO PERCENT JOB GROWTH OKAY
-- WE ARE NUMBER ONE IN JOB
GROWTH WE OUTPACED ORLANDO WE
OUTPACED -- GREATER HOUSTON AND
THAT'S A GREAT STORY TO BE TOLD
SO YOU ADD THAT TO THE FACT
THAT WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE
TO BE THE FASTEST GROWING AREA
IN THE REGION AND IN THIS ISSUE
OF TRANSIT AND TRANSPORTATION
-- BECOMES EVEN MORE IMPORTANT
-- MY ORGANIZATION INLAND
EMPIRE ECONOMIC PARTNERSHIP --
REPRESENTS THE LARGER EMPLOYERS
OF OUR REGION -- THE LARGEST
PRIVATE EMPLOYER CURRENTLY IN
THE INLAND EMPIRE IS AMAZON
WITH OVER TWENTY THOUSAND
EMPLOYEES -- OBVIOUSLY THE
SEARCH FOR THE SECOND AMAZON
HEADQUARTERS HAS BEEN INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT -- IN THE ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT COMMUNITY -- I
WOULD HOWEVER POINT OUT THAT
-- THAT'S A FIVE MILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT BY AMAZON -- TO
DATE -- AMAZON HAS INVESTED
ALMOST SIX SIX BILLION DOLLARS
IN THE INLAND EMPIRE AND FIVE
YEARS AGO THEY WEREN'T YOU OKAY
-- THE SECOND LARGEST PRIVATE
EMPLOYER IS LOMA LINDA HEALTH
AT SEVENTEEN THOUSAND ITS
EMPLOYEES SO OUR PERSPECTIVE IS
ONE OF THE GREAT -- CORPORATE
INVESTMENTS AND -- SUPPORTING
COMMUNITIES THROUGH JOBS --
I THINK THAT WHEN WE LOOK AT
OUR TRANSPORTATION AND TRANSIT
SYSTEMS BOTH NOW AND INTO THE
FUTURE -- WE NEED TO CONSIDER
WHAT THIS REGION IS GOING TO
DO FOR -- NOT ONLY THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA -- BUT FOR THE
NATION AMAZON AND ALSO YOU
PS -- WHY THEY ASSURE THAT WE
WILL ALL GET OUR PACKAGES AT
CHRISTMAS TIME -- ARE NOW IN
THE PLANNING STAGES TO SERVE
CHINA INDIA AND PARTS OF AFRICA
THAT ARE GOING TO COME ONLINE
WHICH MEANS IN THOSE COUNTRIES
IN THOSE PLACES IN THE UNITED
AND AND THE WORLD -- YOU'RE
GOING TO SEE PEOPLE PURCHASING
GOODS VIA FOR FILM AND A LOT
OF THAT IS GOING TO HAPPEN
-- FROM HERE WHICH AGAIN
BRINGS INTO -- INTO FOCUS
THE IMPORTANCE OF THE ONTARIO
AIRPORT -- AS A LOGISTICS HOUSE
-- CURRENTLY ONE OF A UPS IS
LARGEST FACILITY -- IN THE
UNITED STATES AND SO WE'RE
GOING TO CONTINUE TO GROW IN
IT WERE FULL OF OPPORTUNITY
I ALSO WANT TO SAY THAT --
WITH WITH THE CALIFORNIA AIR
RESOURCES BOARD RELOCATING TO
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
RIVERSIDE I REALLY HOPE THAT WE
CAN -- AS A REGION TAKE A LOOK
AT OPPORTUNITY AND JOBS GROWTH
THAT WE CAN LOOK AT THE ISSUES
OF THE ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUES
THAT AFFECT THIS REGION AND --
COME TOGETHER AND COME TOGETHER
FOR THE GOOD OF OF THE FUTURE
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES IN
THIS REGION AND I DO THINK THAT
THERE ARE GREAT OPPORTUNITIES
FOR US BUT IT'S GOING TO TAKE A
IN LIGHT MY LEADERSHIP AND AND
AND AND AND I KNOW THAT -- USE
OF MEMBERS OF THE PANEL TO YOU
UNDERSTAND GOES -- CHALLENGES
BUT AGAIN GREAT OPPORTUNITIES
FOR THE REGION AND FINALLY
I DON'T HAVE A MILLENNIAL CHILD
I HAVE A SIX YEAR OLD OKAY
MONICA YEAH YEAH I'M FIFTY
I TOOK MY FIRST AIRPLANE FLIGHT
FROM THE ONTARIO AIRPORT WHEN
I WAS FOURTEEN CLIMBING UP THE
STAIRS OUTSIDE RIGHT TO GET ON
A PLANE MEMBER THOSE DAYS RIGHT
-- NOW SHE KNOWS THE ONTARIO
AIRPORT IS THE WAY WE GET TO
NOTRE DAME GAMES RIGHT RIGHT
RIGHT RIGHT -- NUMBER FIVE
IN THE NATION ON OUR WAY TO
-- NATIONAL CHAMPIONSHIPS --
SHE FOR TWO DATES IN CYCLIC VIA
RIGHT TO PARTICIPATE SINCE OUR
GLORIA SHE KNOWS TO TAKE THAT
WE TAKE THE METRO LINK -- TO GET
ON THE SUBWAY TO GO TO THE LA
TIMES BOOK FAIR OKAY THAT
IS HER WORLD SHE EVEN HAS A
SPECIAL SEAT THAT WE CARRY WITH
US SO THAT WE CAN USE MOVES WERE
WITH HER OKAY THAT IS FOR WORLD
-- I DON'T KNOW IF SHE'S GOING
TO NEED A DRIVER'S LICENSE IN
THE FUTURE I HOPE THAT THERE'S
A COMMUNIST CARS ARE GOING TO
KEEP HER SAFE AS AS HUMANLY
POSSIBLE SO IN THIS DISCUSSION
AS YOU HEAR ALL THE GOOD THAT'S
BEEN DONE RIGHT I I THINK WE
ALSO HAVE TO LOOK AT THE FUTURE
BECAUSE NOW IS THE TIME FOR
THIS REGION TO DEFINE ITSELF
IT'S ALWAYS BEEN DEFINED BY
JUST HUGE AMOUNTS OF GROWTH AND
WE'RE ALWAYS TRYING TO CATCH
UP BUT THIS TIME WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY I THINK TO BE MUCH
MORE DELIBERATE -- CUTTING EDGE
AND ENSURE THAT THAT NOT ONLY
THAT THERE IS A STRONG VIBRANT
ECONOMY IN THIS REGION -- BUT A
GREAT QUALITY OF LIFE SO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I LOOK FORWARD
TO ANY QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE
THANK YOU AND WE APPRECIATE
YOUR LEADERSHIP AND YOU'RE A
GREAT -- LEADER INVOICE
FOR THE PROGRESS NOT ONLY IN
SAN BENITO COUNTY BUT ALSO THE
FUTURE SO WE APPRECIATE THAT
ALONG WITH -- MICHAEL'S YOUR
LEADERSHIP HERE AND -- RANCHO
-- I'M GONNA TURN TO SEE IF
THERE ANY QUICK QUESTIONS THAT
WE MIGHT HAVE THIS PANEL AND
THEN I'M YES COLORS
SINCE WHEN IT WAS LAST
WE TURN ON MY MIND
AND YOU'VE KNOWN THE
LONGEST TIME SO YES I HAVE
SINCE YOU WERE AN ALTAR BOY
I WAS I WAS A GOOD ALTER
ONE OF THE AREAS AND YOU'VE
BROUGHT THIS UP SO WE TALKED
ABOUT JOB GROWTH I'VE GOT
TO TELL YOU THAT WITH AMAZON
BEING THE LARGEST LAWYERS
I'M SO GLAD THAT THEY HAVE
INCREASED THEIR MINIMUM WAGE
TO FIFTEEN THE ONE AREA
AND YOU AND I HAVE LONG KNOWN
EACH OTHER LONG ENOUGH TO
KNOW EACH OTHER'S POSITIONS
ESPECIALLY WHEN IT COMES TO
AIR QUALITY WHAT DO YOU
SEE AS THE FUTURE IN LOGISTICS
SPECIFICALLY TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE DO HAVE GOOD PAYING JOBS
IF WE ARE TO BE THE LOGISTICS
HUB HUB TO BRING GOOD PAYING
JOBS NOT PART TIME OR OR
-- TEMPORARY AGENCY
JOB AND MAKING SURE THAT WE
ALSO TECH TO THE ENVIRONMENT
THAT WE HAVE TO FIND THE BALANCE
BECAUSE WE HAVE TOO MANY TOO
MANY PEOPLE WITHOUT TOO MANY
CHILDREN ONE ONE AND TEN
ONE AND SEVEN THE PENDING ON
WHAT'S WHAT TO SIX WE LOOK AT
IT NEITHER ONE IS GOING TO GO
AWAY WE NEED THE PEOPLE HERE
WE NEED FOR THEM TO THE HEALTHY
-- THE LOGISTICS INDUSTRY WERE
KNOWN AS THE HUB BUT WITH HALF
A MILLION SQUARE FEET OF OF
LOGISTICS SIX -- WE'VE GOT THE
DIESEL TRUCKS COMING IN SO IT'S
NOT THAT THAT FIT LOGISTICS AND
SELLS SELLS ITS ITS THE DIESEL
TRUCKS COMING IN AND WHAT IT
DOES TO THE COMMUNITY WHERE
DO YOU FIND THAT BALANCE HOW
WHAT WHERE DO WE NEED TO GO TO
FIND THAT BALANCE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER IT'S A GREAT QUESTION YOU
KNOW MY PERSPECTIVE IS A YOU'RE
ALL MY FAMILY HUNDRED TWENTY
FIVE YEARS IN THIS REGION AND
SO MY GRAND GRANDFATHER WORKED
IN ORANGE ORANGE GROVES RIGHT
-- I THINK WORK IS IMPORTANT
OKAY AND UNFORTUNATELY WHILE
WE'RE NUMBER ONE IN ONE JOB
GROWTH THE LAST FIVE YEARS --
WE'RE STILL OF METRO REGIONS
OVER MILLION THE ONE THAT HAS
THE LOWEST BACK WORRIED AT
TWENTY ONE PERCENT AND SO JOBS
THAT DON'T HAVE A HIGH THRESHOLD
FOR EDUCATION ARE SOMETHING
THAT WE NEED IN ORDER FOR PEOPLE
JUST TO GET ALONG AND I ALSO
AS YOU KNOW WE WORRY ABOUT
THE GOING RATE OF POVERTY --
UNEMPLOYMENT UNDEREMPLOYMENT
AND ALL OF THE SOCIAL ILLS THAT
COME WITH THAT -- -- BRIDGING
REACT TO WHAT I WHEN I WAS
I WAS TALKING ABOUT -- WITH
OPPORTUNITIES OF COURSE THE
CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES BOARD
I THINK I I I UNDERSTAND
-- FROM ROOM I WAS JUST IN
ATLANTA AT THE COCA COLA
HEADQUARTERS -- AND AND WORKING
WITH -- LEADERSHIP THAT UPS
LAST WAS WELL LAST WEEK --
THERE'S A HUGE DESIRE TO MAKE
-- THEIR FLEETS AS CLEAN AS
TECHNICAL AS POSSIBLE -- SO I
THINK WE NEED TO WORK TOGETHER
WE NEED TO INCENTIVIZE --
WE NEED TO STUDY BECAUSE IN
SOME CASES THE TECHNOLOGY
ISN'T THERE YET -- BUT BUT
THAT'S THAT'S MY HOPE IS FOR
-- A DISCUSSION AND PEOPLE TO
REALLY COME TOGETHER NOT JUST
RUN TO YOUR CORNERS AND YELL
AT EACH OTHER -- BECAUSE THAT'S
NOT GOING TO ACCOMPLISH ANYTHING
FOR EITHER SIDE WE REALLY NEED
TO COME TOGETHER AND FIND WAYS
TO HAVE THOSE CONVERSATIONS
ORDER SO THOSE TECHNOLOGIES
WHERE THEIR TRUCKS -- WHETHER
THEY'RE WITHIN THE WAREHOUSE
HOUSE AND WE ALSO KNOW THAT
ACCORDING TO A STUDY OUT OF
UNIVERSITY OF REDLANDS SIXTY
PERCENT OF OUR JOB AND IT'S
NOT JUST THE WAREHOUSE HOUSE
IT'S THE OPHTHALMOLOGIST IT'S
THE CPA'S SIXTY PERCENT OF
THE JOBS IN THE INLAND EMPIRE
ARE SUSCEPTIBLE TO AUTOMATION
AGE -- AND SO THAT'S ANOTHER
PRESSURE THAT WE FEEL AND
WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO BE PAYING
ATTENTION TO AS WELL WELL WELL
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
A. P. -- YOU ARE A LEADER
AND WE DO LOOK TO YOU --
THE COMMUNITY LOOKS TO US
ALSO TO BE SURE THAT WHATEVER
WE DO WHATEVER DECISIONS WE
MAKE THEY ARE FOR THE BENEFIT
OF THE COMMUNITY AS A WHOLE
WE WANT THEM TO STAY HEALTHY
BECAUSE IN THE END WE WILL
SPEND SO MUCH MORE IF WE'RE
NOT TAKING CARE OF THEIR HEALTH
BUT THANK YOU SO MUCH AND I
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO
WORK WITH YOU THANK YOU THANK
YOU I DID HAVE A QUESTION
FOR DOCTOR WILL ALSO
THE DOCTOR WILL SIT ON
THE QUESTION WAS OUT OF --
AND THE GENTLEMAN ONE OF
THE OTHER PRESENTERS OR --
SPECIFICALLY ABOUT GOLDLINE
LINE AS YOU KNOW I REPRESENTING
THE DISTRICT FORTY OR DISTRICT
FORTY SEVEN WHICH BEGINS AT
FONTANA AND THAT I WANT
TO KNOW -- I AM CONCERNED
ABOUT ADDITIONAL IMPACT --
BECAUSE THEY COULD REDUCE
SERVICE SERVICE TO THE VERY
PEOPLE THAT I REPRESENT SENT
OUT I WANT TO KNOW WHAT WILL
YOU AS SPC TA DO TO PROTECT
TRANSIT A TRANSIT AS IT
AVAILABILITY IN MY DISTRICT
I THINK HERE CONCERN IS THE
DIFFERENCE AND FAIRS IN THE
TWO SYSTEMS YOU SHOULD BE VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT THAT -- A ONE
WAY TRIP FOR ON THE GOLD LINE
EXAMPLE WHEN IT GETS TO COME ON
A NORTH IS A DOLLAR SEVENTY FIVE
TWO EVERYWHERE METRO SERVERS SO
YOU GO TO LONG BEACH A ONE WAY
TRIP ON THE METRO LIKE SYSTEM TO
UNION STATION WITH THE CURRENT
TWENTY FIVE PERCENT TEMPORARY
FAIR REDUCTION IS SIX DOLLARS
AND SEVENTY FIVE CENTS SO IT'S
A FIVE DOLLAR DIFFERENCE IT
DOESN'T MEAN THAT THE GOAL
LINE SERVICE CHEAPER IT MEANS
THAT IT'S BEING SUBSIDIZED
SIGNIFICANTLY MORE HEAVILY BUT
THE CONCERN AND WE HAVE AND
WE'VE EXPRESSED AND IN NUMEROUS
VENUES IS THAT WHEN WE'VE
ALREADY SEEN WE'VE GOT THAT
WE'VE GOT EVIDENCE THAT THE GOLD
LINE CURRENTLY THE TERMINUS IN
IS USE -- IS DRAWING PASSENGERS
OFFER THE METROLINK SYSTEM
BECAUSE OF THAT -- SUBSIDY
DIFFERENTIAL ON THE AND THE
FARE DIFFERENTIAL -- TO THE TUNE
OF ABOUT TWENTY FIVE PERCENT
WHEN IN THE GOAL LINE CONVERGES
INTO THE METROLINK CORRIDOR OR
WHETHER IT STOPS MONNING NORTH
-- CONTINUES EAST TO MONTCLAIR
CLEARLY WHEN YOU HAVE THE CHOICE
TO PAY A DOLLAR SEVENTY FIVE
SIX SEVENTY FIVE EIGHT DOLLARS
OR WHATEVER IT IS YOU HAD
FURTHER EAST ITS PROBLEM BECAUSE
MOST OF US DOESN'T MATTER OUR
FINANCIAL STATUS AGAIN AND
MAKE THE CHOICE THE CHEAPER
ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU CONSIDER AND
LEAVES ANALYZE THE THE SERVICES
THE THE TIME DIFFERENTIAL
TO TAKE THE GOAL LINE THREE
PASADENA DOWN INTO ELIAN
STATION IS INCONSEQUENTIAL IT'S
YOU KNOW THE TUNE OF OF FIVE OR
SIX MINUTES DIFFERENCE IN TIME
SO IT'S A HUGE PROBLEM REALLY
BEEN WORKING WITH LA METRO
-- A SOLUTION AND AND IT'S
CERTAINLY NOT A DECISION OF
DECEMBER YOU KNOW COUNTY BUT A
SOLUTION IS TO TAKE STEPS TO
RECOGNIZE THAT -- YOU NEED
DISTANCE BASED FARES ON THE
THE -- THE GOAL LINE SYSTEM
AND AND IN GENERAL ON THE THE
METROLINK SYSTEMS A METRO SYSTEM
AS IT'S EXPANDING THROUGHOUT LA
COUNTY BUT AGAIN THAT'S NOT A
DECISION THAT THAT WE CAN CAN
INTERFERE WITH SO WE'RE VERY
CONCERNED DOWNEY THAT THERE
COULD BE A SIGNIFICANT LOSS
RIDERSHIP BECAUSE OF THAT FARE
DIFFERENTIAL AND WE DON'T HAVE
THE ABILITY THROUGH OUR LOCAL
SALES TAX MEASURE TO COVER
THE INCREASED SUBSIDIES NEED
SO THIS COULD TRANSLATE TO
A REDUCED SERVICE EAST OF
MONTCLAIR EAST MONO WHEREVER
THEY TERMINATE THEIR FINAL
SERVICE IT'S IT'S A REAL
PROBLEM THAT WE'RE CONTINUING
TO WORK WITH LA NATURAL AND
AND TRYING TO FIND SOLUTIONS TO
WELL TO COUNT ON US TO TO
TO PARTNER WITH YOU YOU I THINK
THAT -- AND THAT'S WHAT'S SO
IMPORTANT TO ME TO HAVE A GOOD
WORKING RELATIONSHIPS WITH
SBC TA I EVERY TIME WE HAVE
HAD THE OPPORTUNITY SPEAK
ABOUT ANY OF THE ISSUES YOU'VE
ALL BEEN VERY RESPONSIVE BUT
THIS IS OF GREAT CONCERN THAT
BECAUSE OF THE SUBSIDIZING
OF THE THE THE GOLD LINE LIKE
THAT IT IS TAKING AWAY FROM
METROLINK AND THAT IS GOING
TO HAVE AN IMPACT VERY SERIOUS
IMPACT ON ON THE RIDERSHIP
SHIP FROM FROM MY SPECIFIC AREA
FROM THE EAST TO THE EASTERN
PORTION OF SAN BERNARDINO
COUNTY THAT'S A VERY GOOD
POINT THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THAT UP THANK YOU THANK YOU
I WILL START WITH DOCTOR NOVEL
CENSURED THEIR HAVE YOU
RECENTLY BECOME A DOCTOR
OF I JUST IT'S GROWING UP
ALL THESE YEARS EVEN SCREW
THAT UP I'M VERY SORRY
I DID NOT KNOW SO I'M GLAD THAT
I KNOW DOCTOR WILL MY QUESTION
ARE THERE A LOT OF PROJECTS
HAPPENING IN A LACY GABRIEL
SAMBERG THE NOW -- WHAT DO YOU
THINK IS THE BEST AN ACTIVITY
TO LA COUNTY AND SAN MARINO
COUNTY HOW HOW DO WE MAKE THAT
HAPPEN FOR FOLKS TO ART TALKED
ABOUT THE CONSTRAINTS THAT WE
HAVE ON THE FREEWAY NETWORK AND
CERTAINLY WE IN SAM'S YOU KNOW
COUNTY OUR CONTINUING TO ADVANCE
PROJECTS THIS THE -- LEAST
ADDING LANES TO SOME OF THE
KEY ARTERIALS BUT WE ARE
VERY QUICKLY REACHING A POINT
WHERE WE CAN'T CONTINUE TO ADD
CAPACITY IS CERTAINLY IN THE
GREATER LA BASIN INCLUDING THE
SAN MARINO VALLEY IT'S VERY
UNLIKELY THAT WILL EVER ADD A
NEW FREEWAY FACILITY -- AND
SO WITH THE POPULATION GROWTH
THAT THAT ARE NOT -- COMMENTED
ON WE'VE GOT TO FIND WAYS TO GET
PEOPLE TO MAKE DIFFERENT CHOICES
AND I THINK THE MOST EXCITING
THING THAT WE'RE DOING RIGHT NOW
IS IS WHAT I MENTION AT THE END
OF MY PRESENTATION IS LOOKING
TO BRING ZERO EMISSION PASSENGER
RAIL TECHNOLOGY THAT NOT ONLY
BENEFITS A SHORT RAIL ROAD THAT
WE'RE BUILDING IN THE EASTERN
PART OF OUR COUNTY BUT REALLY
HAS THE POTENTIAL TO BENEFIT
THE ENTIRE METROLINK SYSTEM
WHICH IS OVER FIVE HUNDRED MILES
BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY CHANGED
THE LANDSCAPE OF PASSIONATE
RAIL THROUGHOUT THIS COUNTRY
AND THROUGHOUT NORTH AMERICA
IT'S REALLY EXCITING TO TO
HAVE THAT INCUBATED HERE IN
SAM'S IF YOU KNOW COUNTY YET
THAT'S A REALLY BIG DEAL IT'S
VERY EXCITING WHAT MY OTHER
QUESTION IS GOING TO BE WHAT
ARE YOU WORKING ON TO CONTROL
EMISSIONS THAT'S ONE A BIG ONE
IS THERE ANY OTHER PROJECTS OR
ARE THERE ANY OTHER PROJECTS
THAT YOU'RE WORKING ON THAT
WILL CONTROL EMISSIONS IN THE
INLAND EMPIRE SO WE'VE PARTNERED
THE LATELY IT'S A MANUFACTURER'S
BATTERY TECHNOLOGIES ON A COUPLE
OF PILOT PROJECTS ONE WITH
WRITER THAT CONCLUDED A FEW
YEARS AGO THAT -- LOOKED AT --
PURCHASING -- BATTERY POWERED
VEHICLES AND SMALLER SCALE AT
THE TIME BECAUSE THE TECHNOLOGY
WOULD ADVANCE TO THE POINT OF A
VERY LARGE VEHICLES -- AND NOW
WE'RE WORKING WITH THE LADY
AGAIN AND -- THE SHORT HAUL
FREIGHT RATE -- OF VEHICLES
THAT ARE USED IN A MEMBER WHAT
THEY CALL IN BUT THAT ARE USED
IN THE -- INTERMODAL YARDS AND
SO WE ARE YOU KNOW TRYING TO
ADDRESS THE THE QUESTION IS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RADIUS ON HOW DO
WE CONVERT THE VEHICLES THAT
ARE USE THE GRADE SCHOOLS FOR
EXAMPLE THAT ARE USED -- WERE
NOT TO THE POINT YET YET AND
-- ILAN MOSQUE DID ROLL OUT --
LAST YEAR EARLIER THIS YEAR
A -- A BATTERY POWERED SEMI
TRACTOR TRAILER BUT WE'RE NOT
QUITE TO THAT POINT WHERE THOSE
VEHICLES I THINK ARE GOING TO
INFILTRATE THE MARKET PLACE BUT
AS A AS A COUNCIL OF GOVERNMENTS
WERE VERY ACTIVE IN TRYING TO
FIND SOLUTIONS THAT HELP TO
ACCOMPLISH A MUCH HEALTHIER
ENVIRONMENTS AND WAS YOU KNOW
COUNTY EXCELLENT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH DOCTOR WILLFUL AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU MORE
JUST A COMMENT FOR A MERE WALK
THERE I LOVE ALL THE CHANGES
THAT WERE SITTING AT THE AIRPORT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF THOSE OF
US WHO WERE THERE TWICE A WEEK
WE VERY MUCH APPRECIATE IT HAVE
ONE LITTLE FAVOR DO YOU THINK
YOU GUYS CAN RE PAVE THE PARKING
LOT IT REALLY TEARS AT MY HEELS
SO THIS IS A TOTALLY PERSONAL
BUT THANK YOU IT'S WONDERFUL
TO SEE THE TRANSFORMATION I
TO REMEMBER WHEN WE USED TO
PORT WALKING UP THE STAIRS OUT
OUTSIDE -- AND I JUST WANT TO
MAKE A COMMENT ABOUT AMAZON
AND AND YOU KNOW THERE'S TWENTY
THOUSAND EMPLOYEES BUT I THINK
WHAT WE HAVE TO REMEMBER IS THAT
OR THOUSAND OF THOSE JOBS ARE
TEMPORARY PART TIME JOBS AND I
KNEW THAT TWO YEARS AGO -- THE
CITY OF SAN DINO HAD TO CUT TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
THAT THEY USUALLY GIVE TO NON
PROFITS SO THEY COULD RE PAVE
THE STREETS BECAUSE THAT'S A
LOT OF CARS COMING IN AND OUT SO
WE JUST HAVE TO BE AWARE OF THAT
I THINK IT'S GREAT THAT AMAZON
HAS INCREASED THEIR MINIMUM WAGE
TO FIFTEEN DOLLARS AN HOUR BUT
WE ALL KNOW THAT EVEN FIFTEEN
DOLLARS AN HOUR IS NOT A LIVING
WAGE MY TO MILLENNIALS THAT
I REFERRED TO ONE PAY SIXTEEN
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY DOLLARS
A MONTH FOR A ONE BEDROOM
APARTMENT IN ONTARIO AND THE
OTHER ONE PIECE FOURTEEN HUNDRED
AND THIRTY DOLLARS FOR AN
APARTMENT IN ONTARIO AND THEY
BOTH HAVE VERY GOOD JOBS IN THE
HEALTH PARTNERS THAT HAVE GOOD
JOBS SO WE JUST HAVE TO REMEMBER
THAT THE JOB SO WE'LL BRING IN
TWENTY TWO PERCENT GROWTH WHILE
THAT'S GREAT WHAT JOBS ARE WE
BRINGING AND NOW WHERE I SIT AND
WHERE WE SIT WHEN WE COMPANIES
HAVE TO HAVE THEIR EMPLOYEES
GO ON WELFARE OR COLLECT
FOOD STAMPS THAT'S LESS MONEY
THAT WE AS A GOVERNMENT CAN
I USE FOR EDUCATION AND OTHER
THINGS SO WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
WE'LL BRING SUSTAINABLE JOBS
-- TO THE INLAND EMPIRE OUR
LAST NIGHT WE DID A TOWN HALL
WITH ASSEMBLYMEMBER THURMAN
WHO'S RUNNING FOR ON THE STATE
SUPERINTENDENT OF SCHOOLS
AND HE TALKED ABOUT STAND AND
STEAM JOBS COMING TO THE INLAND
EMPIRE TO SAM REGINO COUNTY
RIVERSIDE COUNTY AND I THINK
THAT'S THAT'S THE KIND OF VISION
THAT WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
ALL THE ONLY JOBS THAT COME TO
THE INLAND EMPIRE ARE NOT JUST
WAREHOUSE JOBS BECAUSE THEY'RE
NOT PRIMARILY GOOD JOB MORE
SUSTAINABLE FAMILY JOBS SO I
WANT TO THANK EVERYONE THANK THE
CHAIRMAN FOR HAVING THIS VERY
INFORMATIVE AS WE HAVE LOTS OF
GREAT WORK THAT WE GET TO DO
WELL THANK YOU AND -- WE HAVE
OUR FINAL PANEL THERE WOULD
LIKE TO RETURN TO AND WE
DO APPRECIATE THOSE OF USE OF
THAT ON THE PREVIOUS -- THREE
BUT IF YOU CAN OF HOLD ON
WE'RE GOING TO ALSO PUT THE --
REQUEST OUT THERE IF THERE'S
ANY ONE OF THE PUBLIC WHO HAS
A QUESTION THERE ARE BLUE CARDS
THAT THE STAFF I BELIEVE AS
AVAILABLE SO AS WE GET TO OUR
FINAL PANEL WE WILL IN TURN
TO THE PUBLIC IF THERE ARE ANY
QUESTIONS OF THIS PANEL
WILL DEAL WITH INFRASTRUCTURE
FUNDING AND -- THE FIRST
PRESENTER WILL BE JOHN POLANSKI
WHOSE CAL TRANS DISTRICT SEVEN
DIRECTOR A HE WAS RECENTLY
APPOINTED DIRECTOR FOR CAL
TRANS DISTRICT SEVEN WHICH
ENCOMPASSES LOS ANGELES INVERTER
COUNTY ANI BEFORE JOINING GOING
TO DISTRICT SEVEN JOHN SERVED
AS DIRECTOR OF DISTRICT EIGHT
WHICH INCLUDES RIVERSIDE AND SAN
BERNARDINO COUNTIES JOHN ALSO
SERVED AS DIRECTOR FOR DISTRICT
TWO WHICH INCLUDES READING
WRITING AND HAS OVER TWENTY FIVE
YEARS OF EXPERIENCE CAL TRANS
OUR SECOND OR CENTER WILL BE
MARK OR CHRISTOFFEL SINCE TODAY
MARKETS WERE IN THE SAN GABRIEL
VALLEY KARKAT WERE HE SERVES
AS DIRECTOR TRANSPORTATION
HE REPRESENTS THE SAN GABRIEL
VALLEY ON METROS MEASURE HIM AND
LONG RANGE TRANSPORTATION PLAN
ADVISOR POLICY COUNCILS HE IS
ALSO THE CEO CHIEF ENGINEER
OF THE ALAMEDA QUARTER EAST
CONSTRUCTION AUTHORITY WERE IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR IMPLEMENTING
THE ONE POINT SEVEN BILLION
DOLLAR ACE PROGRAM OF RAIL
A ROADWAY GRAY SEPARATION
IS AT GRADE CROSSINGS SAFETY
MOBILITY IMPROVEMENTS THE ACES
TODAY'S CONSTRUCTION PROGRAM
HAS BEEN CITED AS A NATIONAL
MODEL FOR DRESSING THE IMPACTS
OF NATIONALLY AND REGIONALLY
SIGNIFICANT RATE RATE FREIGHT
RATE RAIL TRAFFIC ON LOCAL
COMMUNITIES OUR THIRD PANELIST
MICHAEL TURNER IS THE DEPUTY
EXECUTIVE OFFICER GOVERNMENT
RELATIONS AT LA METRO IN THAT
ROLE MISTER TURNER MANAGES
THE AGENCIES GOVERNMENT
RELATIONS DEPARTMENT MISTER
TURNER'S WORK WERE ON METRO
SPONSORED LEGISLATION RELATED
TO A VARIETY TRANSPORTATION
ISSUES FROM INFRASTRUCTURE
FINANCING INNOVATIVE PROJECT
DELIVERY CONGESTION PRICING
AND THE LEGISLATION AUTHORIZING
MEASURE ARE ADDITIONALLY MISTER
TURNER IS ACTIVE IN VARIOUS
STATEWIDE TRANSPORTATION
RELATED GROUPS AND HAS WORKED
TO DEVELOP CONSENSUS AROUND
MAJOR TRANSPORTATION ISSUES IN
THE REGION TURNER HAS A
BACHELOR'S DEGREE IN PSYCHOLOGY
FROM UCLA AND A MASTER'S
DEGREE IN URBAN PLANNING
FROM USA I DON'T KNOW HOW YOU
GUYS DO THAT BUT ANYWAY OF
OUR FOURTH PANELIST IS ANDREA
HUNDRED ZEROS DIRECTOR OF
FINANCE AND ADMINISTRATION
FOR THE SAN BERNARDINO COUNTY
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY AND
IS RESPONSIBLE FOR MANAGING THE
ALLOCATION AND EFFICIENT USE OF
FEDERAL STATE AND LOCAL FUNDS
THAT COME DECEMBER DINO COUNTY
FOR TRANSPORTATION SHE BEGAN
WITH SPC TA AS TRANSPORTATION
SPECIALIST EVENTUALLY
WORKING HER WAY UP TO THE C.
PROGRAMMING CHIEF OF PROGRAMMING
DEMONSTRATING HER FLEXIBILITY
AND COMMITMENT TO THE INLAND
EMPIRE ANDREA SPENT SEVERAL
YEARS WITH THE RIVERSIDE COUNTY
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION BEFORE
TRANSITIONING BACK TO S. B. C.
T. A. AS THE DIRECTOR OF FUNDING
MINISTRATION WE WELCOME ALL OF
OUR PANELISTS FOR FINAL PANEL
AND WE CALL IT JOHN LEWINSKI
FORWARD A DELETED AFTERNOON
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR ALLOWING
ME AND I'M TRYING TO COME UP
HERE AND SPEAK TO YOU TODAY
MY TOPIC IS GOING TO BE COVER
-- -- SP ONE SENATE BILL ONE
ONE FUNDING ENDING AT CAL
TRANS AND ACROSS THE STATE
HAVE TO GET USED TO SEE IN
DISTRICT SEVEN AFTER MY NAME
BECAUSE I HAVE BEEN IN DISTRICT
EIGHT FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS
-- AND IT'S A LITTLE BIT --
DIFFERENT DIFFERENT THANK
YOU THANK YOU BUT I AM TAKING
METROLINK ART ART BY THE WAY
WAY -- AND IT'S A GREAT SYSTEM
SYSTEM SO THAT AGAIN THANK
YOU FOR THE INVITATION --
PRIOR TO HER PASSAGE OF SENATE
BILL ONE CALIFORNIA STATE
HIGHWAYS IN THE LOCAL ROAD
NETWORK WERE FACING AN ESTIMATED
ONE HUNDRED AND THIRTY SEVEN
BILLION DOLLARS FOR MAINTENANCE
BACKLOG OVER THE NEXT TEN YEARS
AS WE ALL KNOW IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN GOVERNOR BROWN SIGNS
SENATE BILL ONE -- OTHERWISE
KNOWN AS THE ROAD REPAIR AND
ACCOUNTABILITY ACT OF TWENTY
SEVENTEEN WHICH PROVIDES A
STABLE SOURCE OF TRANSPORTATION
FUNDING ENDING WITH STRONG
ACCOUNTABILITY MEASURES
THIS NEW TRANSPORTATION BILL
IS ESTIMATED TO GENERATE FIFTY
FOUR BILLION DOLLARS OVER THE
NEXT DECADE A CASE AND IT IS
A SPLIT LET THAT FIND THAT
FINDING WILL BE SPLIT BETWEEN
STATE AND LOCAL AGENCIES TO
IMPROVE OUR ROADS BRIDGES
AND CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE
ALL OF THIS PROVIDES CAL
TRANS IN LOCAL COMMUNITIES AN
OPPORTUNITY TO CATCH UP ON YEARS
OF UNFUNDED MAINTENANCE NEEDS
THE BENEFITS OF SP
ONE INCLUDES SAFER
ROADS SMOOTHER MAY MANAGEMENT
BETTER COMMUTES AND REDUCING
LONG TERM MAINTENANCE
SO SPEAKING A MAINTENANCE
MAINTAINING INFRASTRUCTURE
WE ALREADY HAVE IS THE VOCAL
PRIORITY FOR CENTER CELL ONE ONE
BOTH FOR STATE EIGHT AND LOCAL
NETWORKS IT IS IN LINE
WITH CAL TRANS LONG TIME FIX IT
FIRST STRATEGY WE'RE A BIT OF
PREVENTATIVE MAINTENANCE CAN
GO A LONG WAY SAVING OUR ASSETS
FROM EXPENSIVE REPAIRS AND
INCREASING THE LIFESPAN OF THOSE
INVESTMENTS EACH YEAR SENATE
BILL ONE NINE WILL PROVIDE
LOCAL AGENCIES AN AVERAGE OF
ONE POINT FIVE BILLION DOLLARS
AND THIS IS A CORE STATEWIDE WAY
IN ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR LOCAL
STREET AND ROAD MAINTENANCE
EACH YEAR CAL TRANS WILL RECEIVE
AN AVERAGE OF ONE POINT EIGHT
BILLION DOLLARS IN ADDITIONAL
FUNDING FOR STATE HIGHWAY
MAINTENANCE AND REHABILITATION
FOUR HUNDRED HUNDRED MILLION OF
WHICH WE WILL SPECIFICALLY GO TO
BRIDGE AND COVER OVER DRAINAGE
IMPROVED IMPROVEMENT PROJECTS
SENATE BILL ONE CAL TRANS AND
WAS ABLE TO START NUMEROUS
PROJECTS ACROSS THE STATE EIGHT
WHICH WERE PLANNED TO BE
DELIVERED IN LATER YEARS
THIS INCLUDES NEARLY THREE
HUNDRED AND FIX IT FIRST
PROJECTS WORTH WORTH MORE
THAN FIVE BILLION DOLLARS
AND THOSE ARE XCELERATED
BECAUSE OF SENATE BILL ONE
FINDING SO I CAL TRANS
WE HAVE ALREADY COMPLETED
FORTY NINE PROJECTS FUNDED BY
SENATE SO ONE WE HAVE AFFORDED
OR BEGAN CONSTRUCTION ON NINETY
PROJECTS AND HAVE BEGUN WORK
INCLUDING DESIGN ENVIRONMENTAL
CLEARANCE ON THREE HUNDRED
AND NINETEEN PROJECTS
FUNDED BY THE S. P. ONE ONE
SP ONE ALSO REQUIRES CAL TRANS
TO SHOW SIGNIFICANT IMPROVEMENTS
TO THE CONDITION OF THE
STATE HIGHWAY SYSTEM OVER THE
NEXT DECADE WITH THE
WITH THAT MAINTENANCE MINING
MONEY SO STATEWIDE OUR
GOALS OR TO
IMPROVE -- SEVENTEEN THOUSAND
LANE MILES OF PAVEMENT
FIX FIVE HUNDRED BRIDGER'S
REPORT REPAIR OR REHABILITATE
FIFTY FIVE THOUSAND COVERS
AND SEVENTY SEVEN HUNDRED
HUNDRED TMS ELEMENTS TRAFFIC
MANAGEMENT SYSTEM ELEMENTS THOSE
ARE LIKE LIKE SIMILAR TO TRAFFIC
SIGNALS OR RAMP METERS TRAFFIC
CAMERAS ELECTRONIC MESSAGES
OR TO YOU SEE ON THE HIGHWAY
SO SOME OF THE MAJOR MAINTENANCE
INVESTMENTS IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA INCLUDE ONE POINT TWO
BILLION DOLLARS FOR PROJECTS ON
INTERSTATE TEN IN SAN BERNARDINO
AND RIVERSIDE COUNTIES THOSE
INCLUDE RICHARD PLACEMENTS MET
PAVEMENT RIP REPLACE LANCEMENT
AND IMPROVING TRUCK LANES
SHOULDERS AND RAMP IMPROVING
THIS VITAL ECONOMIC COMIC
CORRIDORS IMPERATIVE TO BOTH
BUSINESSES AND RESIDENTS ALIKE
LIKE FIVE HUNDRED
FOUR MILLION TO REPLACE
BRIDGES AND OVERPASSES ALONG
INTERSTATE FIVE IN LOS ANGELES
COUNTY ONE HUNDRED AND
NINETY ONE MILLION FOR BRIDGE
REPLACEMENT HIM A PAVEMENT
PLACEMENTS ONLINE STATE ROUTE
SIXTY IN SAM RENDON RIVERSIDE
COUNTIES ONE HUNDRED AND THIRTY
SIX MILLION FROM PAVEMENT
REHABILITATION ON ON SIX
OH FIVE IN LA COUNTY HONEY
AND FORTY TWO MILLION FOR
PAVEMENT REPLACEMENT ON THE TWO
TEN IN IN SAN BERNARDINO COUNTY
SO SOME OF THE OTHER
ELEMENTS OF SENATE BILL
ONE INCLUDE COMPETITIVE
GRANT PROGRAMS AND ONE OF
THOSE IS CONGESTION RELIEF
SO SENATE BILL ONE INCLUDES A
TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS EACH YEAR FOR THIS NEW
PROGRAM THIS IS CRITICAL
OBVIOUSLY TO SEVEN CALIFORNIA
AS IT IS HOME TO HALF OF THE
STATE'S POPULATION AS WE HAVE
ALREADY DISCUSSED EARLIER
AND UNFORTUNATELY
LA ALSO HAS SEVEN OF THE
TEN MOST CONGESTED CORRIDORS
WHERE COMMUTERS VAN AND
COMMUTERS WILL SPAN AND
UP TO HUNDRED TWO HOURS
PER YEAR STUCK IN TRAFFIC
NOW I'M BEGINNING TO WONDER
WHY I WENT TO DISTRICT SEVEN
FOR YEARS WHERE THE PROJECTS
SIX FROM THIS NEW SOLUTION SINCE
TWO FOUR CONGESTED CORRIDORS
PROGRAM AND WHICH IS ANOTHER
ONE OF THE COMPETITIVE GRANT
PROGRAMS TOTALLING ONE
BILLION WERE APPROVED BY THE
CALIFORNIA TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION AND MAY
SENATE BILL ALSO IS ONE ALSO
INCLUDES TWO HUNDRED MILLION
FOR COMMUNITY SOLUTIONS TO
EASE CONGESTION ON BOTH STATE
HIGHWAYS AND LOCAL ROADS VIA
THE LOCAL PARTNERSHIP PROGRAM
THIS PROGRAM FIND SEVERAL
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA PROJECTS
INCLUDING SIXTY MILLION FOR THE
CITY OF RANCHO CUCAMONGA TO
BUILD AN OVER CROSSING AT AND
WANDA TO GET OVER THE
BNSF TRAIN TRACKS THREE POINT
SEVEN MILLION FOR THE CITIES
OF CHALAM MESA AND YOU CUT BUT
CONSTRUCT ROUNDABOUTS AND STREET
IMPROVEMENTS ANOTHER TWENTY
FIVE MILLION IN SP ONE ONE
FINDS FOR ADDITIONAL
FREEWAY SERVICE OR TROLLS
SENATE BILL ONE ALSO ESTABLISHES
A LONG TERM VISION FOR IMPROVING
THE STATE'S CRITICAL TRADE
CORRIDORS INVESTING IMPROVEMENTS
ON KEY FREIGHT RATE ROUTE
ROUTES FREE TO RECRUITMENT
OBVIOUSLY IS IMPORTANT YOU
SEND IN CALIFORNIA -- AS
IT IS THE LINK BETWEEN THE
PORTS AND THE REMAINING PORTION
OF THE WESTERN UNITED STATES
-- FREIGHT RATE GENERATE
ABOUT ONE THIRD OF
CALIFORNIA'S TWO POINT TWO
TRILLION DOLLAR ECONOMY
SO THROUGH THE TRADING
AND AND TRADE CORRIDOR
ENHANCEMENT PROGRAM SP ONE
INCLUDES THREE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS ANNUALLY
SO SO THE CALIFORNIA
TRANSPORTATION TICKET
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION
APPROVED THREE YEARS WORTH OF
TRADE CORRIDOR FUNDING TOTALING
ONE POINT FOUR BILLION FOR
THIS PROGRAM AND MAY OF THIS
WAS PASSED OF THIS YEAR HERE
AND THOSE INCLUDE ONE HUNDRED
TWENTY MY TWENTY NINE MILLION TO
IMPROVE FREIGHT RAIL CORRIDORS
IN AND OUT OF THE PORTS OF LOS
ANGELES AND LONG BEACH TO --
FORTY SEVEN MILLION FOR THE
GOLDEN STATE CHOKE POINT RELIEF
PROJECT TO ADD TRUCK LANES AND
CARPOOL LANES TO THE I. FIVE
ROUTE ROUTE FOURTEEN INTERCHANGE
AREA FORTY FOUR MILLION
IN IN POMONA FOR PROJECT AT
CARPOOL AND MIX NICOLO LANES TO
THE SEVENTY ONE EXPRESS WAY
THE ADA FINALLY
YEAH WHICH WILL CONVERT THAT
TO A FULL EIGHT LANE FREEWAY
SO WE'RE NOT BUILDING NEW
FREEWAYS OR IMPROVING THE
SIX EXISTENCE TING TWENTY
MILLION FOR THE FIFTY SEVEN
SIXTY CHOKE POINT RELIEF
PROJECT WHICH IS ALSO CRITICAL
TRANSPORTATION PROJECT
SO HOW DOES THAT IMPACT CAL
TRANS OBVIOUSLY
WITH ALL THIS ADDITIONAL
FUNDING ENDING IN THE
WORKLOAD IS INCREASING
-- AND ALSO IT'S GOING TO
IMPACT THE CONTRACTING INDUSTRY
SO WE ARE LOOKING TO MEET THAT
WORKLOAD IT'S GOING TO BE TO BE
GENERATED THROUGH
A DIVERSE GROUP OF CONTRACTORS
WE ARE INCREASING OUR OUTREACH
EFFORTS TO HELP SMALL BUSINESSES
AND MINORITY AND BETTER KNOWN
BUSINESSES TO MAKE CONNECTIONS
AND CONTRACT FOR THE STATE DATE
EITHER DIRECTLY OR INDIRECTLY AS
SUBCONTRACTORS WE'RE ALSO
FOCUSED ON SOME STREAMLINING
HOW WE DELIVER OUR PROJECTS
IN A WAY THAT CAN HELP US REDUCE
RESOURCES SENATE BILL ALSO
WAS ONE ALSO REQUIRES THAT CAL
TRANS AND PLACE ARE PUT INTO
PLACE EFFICIENCY MEASURES WITH
THE GOAL OF GENERATING AT LEAST
ONE HUNDRED MILLION ANNUALLY
IN SAVINGS TO INVEST IN THE
MAINTENANCE AND REHABILITATION
TION OF THE STATE HIGHWAY SYSTEM
SO SAFEGUARDS ARE AND
AND AND AND MEASURE THE
ACCOUNTABILITY MEASURES ARE
ALSO INCLUDED IN SENATE SO ONE
SP ONE FINDS ARE FOR
TRANSPORTATION USE ONLY
AND THE LEGISLATION INCLUDES
HISTORIC ACCOUNTABILITY
AND TRANSPORTATION MEASURES
PROPOSITION SIXTY NINE WHICH
WAS PASSED IN JUNE OF THIS PAST
YEAR AMEND THE STATE
CONSTITUTION THAT INSURERS
ALL OF THEM THIS NEW FUNDING
STREAM IS DEDICATED
TO TRANSPORTATION SPENDING ONLY
SO WHAT IS CAL TRANS DURING YOUR
EXPECTATIONS ARE HIGH WE ARE
CAL TRANS RECOGNIZE WE HAVE
AN EVEN GREATER RESPONSIBILITY
TO DELIVER FOR THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA SP ONE PROVIDES
THE FIRST SIGNIFICANT STABLE AND
ON GOING INCREASE IN STRAIGHT
TRACK TRANSPLANTS STATE
TRANSPORTATION FUNDING ENDING
IN DECADES WITHOUT THESE
PLANS A STATE WILL NEED TO
DELAY DELETED OR DOWNSIZED
PROGRAM GRAHAM THIS WILL IMPACT
MOBILITY SAFETY AND QUALITY
OF LIFE WE ARE COMMITTED
TO DELIVERING ON OUR PROMISES
THAT ARE INCLUDED IN SB ONE ONE
AND FOR ADDITIONAL INFORMATION
YOU CAN I DON'T HAVE A
POWER POINT -- BUT I DO
HAVE A WEBSITE SO YOU CAN
YOU CAN GO TO TO IDENTIFY
-- LATEST LATEST INFORMATION
ON SENATOR ONE AND WHAT
PROJECTS ARE INCLUDED IN
THERE IS REBUILDING THE
CA DOT CA DOT GOP YOU
AND WITH THAT I THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME TIME THANK YOU JOHN
WE APPRECIATE THE PRESENTATIONS
VERY IMPORTANT VERY TIMELY --
MARK CHRISTOFFEL AND THEN --
MICHAEL AND ANDREA IF THE THREE
OF YOU CAN BE YOUR PRESENTATION
LIKE FILE -- FIVE MINUTES
THEREABOUTS OUT -- BECAUSE I
KNOW WE'RE GETTING CLOSE TO
OUR OUR OUR TIME TO HAVE TO
WRAP UP AND I DO WANT TO SEE
IF THERE'S ANY OTHER COMMENTS
BEYOND THE THE MEMBERS FROM
THE ABSOLUTELY I WILL TRY TO
BRING YOU BACK ON SCHEDULE AYES
INDICATE WHEN IS MICROSOFT'S
ALSO I'M HERE REPRESENTING
THE SINGULAR VALLEY COUNCIL
GOVERNMENTS -- WE ARE THIRTY
ONE CITIES WITH A POPULATION
OF JUST OVER TWO MILLION PRETTY
SIGNIFICANT CHUNK OF LA COUNTY
-- I DO MOST OF THEIR LONG RANGE
OR SHORT RATES TRANSPORTATION
PLANNING AND ALSO -- OVERSEE
OUR OUR ONE POINT SEVEN BILLION
DOLLARS GRADE SEPARATION PROGRAM
I WILL KEEP MY PROGRAM SHORT IN
EXCHANGE IF YOU'LL REMEMBER AND
THREE KEY WORDS FOR ME AT THE
END OF MY PRESENTATION AND THAT
IS A PARTNERSHIP SHIP LEVERAGING
AND ECONOMIC GOT TALENT AND I
SEE THE CHAIR WRITING RISE DOWN
GOOD NOTE TAKER OCCUR -- THOSE
THREE WORDS AND FORTUNATELY
ASSOCIATED WITH ASPIN ONE WILL
NOT SHOW UP INADVERTENTLY IN
THE ABSENT WE'RE GOING TO SEE
THE WEEK PRIOR TO THE ELECTION
BUT THEY ARE THEY ARE CRUCIAL
IN THE DISCUSSIONS THAT YOU
WILL PRESUMABLY HAVE BETWEEN
NOW AND ELECTION WITH YOUR
CONSTITUENTS AND OTHERS OKAY
AND LET ME GIVE YOU SOME
EXAMPLES OF WHY AM I DOING THAT
THE LAST TIME THAT THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA PUT FORTH ANY
TYPE OF A MAJOR INFRASTRUCTURE
DOLLARS BACK IN TWO THOUSAND
AND SIX IT WAS PROPOSITION ONE
B. SINCE THEN THE STATE HAS NOT
NOT SIGNIFICANTLY CONTRIBUTED TO
THE INFRASTRUCTURE OF THIS DAY
IF YOU GO BACK TO THE DOLLARS
THAT WERE ALLOCATED ON THE
PROPOSITION ONE B. AND YOU WERE
TO LOOK AT WHAT WAS INVESTED IN
THOSE DOLLARS AND HOW THEY WERE
THE LEVER ASKING PARTICULARLY
AND MOST OF THOSE DOLLARS ONE
DOLLAR OF THAT OF A PROPOSITION
ONE B. WOULD HAVE GOTTEN MATCHES
TO THE THREE DOLLARS THE OTHER
SOURCES OF FUNDING WHEN IT
WAS FEDERAL OR LOCAL OR OTHER
SOURCES FROM THE PRIVATE SECTOR
AND IF YOU GO BACK AND YOU LOOK
AT THAT PROJECTS THAT WE BUILT
AS A STATE EIGHT IN CONJUNCTION
WITH WITH LOCAL ENTITIES IN THE
COUNTY YOU WILL SEE THAT MOST
OF CONTRIBUTED PARTICULARLY
HERE IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
TO OUR ECONOMIC VITALITY
WE LOSE SOMETIMES THAT FACT
AND THAT NOW THAT ABILITY FOR US
TO DO THAT AT WAS PARTNERSHIPS
THAT WAS PARTNERSHIPS BETWEEN
THE STATE EIGHT AND COUNTY
TRANSPORTATION -- THIS IS LIKE
LIKE THE ONES THAT WE HAVE
REPRESENTATIVE HERE AT LIKE
RAY OVER HERE FROM FROM FROM
SAN BERNARDINO WE TOOK THOSE
DOLLARS AND WE PUT THEM IN THE
PROJECTS AND MATCH THEM AGAINST
OTHER DOLLARS THE TRADE REWARD
OR ENHANCEMENTS PROGRAM WAS
MENTIONED IT'S PART OF THAT'S
BECAUSE ONE IT IS THE SUCCESSOR
TO -- PREVIOUS PROGRAM CALLED
TRI CORDER IMPROVEMENT FIND TCI
YEAH THOSE WILL INFRASTRUCTURE
RELATED TO OUR TRADE REWARD OR
THERE WAS DISCUSSION BY PAUL
AND OTHERS ABOUT HOW TRADE
IS OUR ECONOMIC VITALITY HERE
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA THERE
WERE LOTS NOT DOLLARS THAT
WAS PUT INTO THAT PROGRAM
THAT ULTIMATELY IMPROVED OUR
ECONOMIC BYE BYE BYE TALLY
WE'RE NOT GOING TO WHICH RACK
RACK BUSINESSES WE'RE NOT GOING
TO GET RESIDENTS MOVED AROUND
AND WE'RE NOT GONNA SIT ACTIVELY
INCREASE OUR ECONOMIC BASE IF WE
DON'T HAVE THE INFRASTRUCTURE TO
SUPPORT IT IF YOU DRIVE THE PORT
IS WE SPEAK TODAY AND THEY'RE
INVESTING IN LOTS OF MONEY IN
THERE PORTS TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY REMAIN COMPETITIVE IN THIS
WORLDWIDE MARKET IT'S ESSENTIAL
TO CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY THAT
WE BE ABLE TO GET THOSE GOODS
IN AND OUT OF THIS REGION
WITH WE DON'T YOU KNOW LIKE WHY
AS A STATE IMPROVE THE CORRIDORS
TO COME IN AND OUT OF THOSE
BILLBOARDS INTO OUR COMMUNITIES
AND TO THE JOB THEY GENERATE
WE'RE GOING TO LOSE THAT BATTLE
AND WE'RE GOING TO SEE OTHER
PARTS OF THE WORLD IN OUR NATION
OUTSOURCE THESE ITEMS THAT
ARE SO VITAL TO OUR ECONOMY
I'M ALL SHARE SOMETHING WITH
YOU WHAT WE DID AS PART OF LA
COUNTY WHEN WE POUR PUTTING
FORTH MEASURE AND MY MOST RECENT
SALES TAX INITIATIVE I TOOK
THE THIRTY ONE CITIES THAT WE
HAD AND DID WHAT WE CALL THE
MOBILITY STUDY AND I APPROACHED
ELECTED OFFICIALS AND THEY SAID
SET ASIDE YOUR CURRENT NEEDS
FOR THE MOMENT TO SET ALL OF
THE PROBLEMS THAT YOU CURRENTLY
GUIDE AND GIVE ME A LONG RANGE
VISION GOALS AND OBJECTIVES OF
WHERE YOU THINK WE'RE GOING TO
BE AS THE SUBREGION TWENTY YEARS
FROM NOW FORTY YEARS FROM NOW
AND WE GOT THEM TO AGREE ON A
SET OF GOALS AND OBJECTIVES WE
TOOK THAT AND WE WENT TO EACH
OF THE COMMUNITIES INSTEAD BASED
ON THESE GOALS AND OBJECTIVES
COLLECTIVELY FOR US FOR US EVERY
WHAT TYPES OF INFRASTRUCTURE
ARE WE GOING TO HAVE TO PUT
IN WHAT WE HAVE TO BILLS WILL
MAKE SURE THAT WILL BE VITAL AS
COMMUNITIES AS WE MOVE FORWARD
AND WE DEVELOPED A LISTLESS
SIXTEEN MILLION BILLION EXCUSE
ME SIXTEEN BILLION DOLLARS WORTH
THE NEEDS THAT WE KNEW WE HAD
YOU'RE NOT GONNA FIND ALL THAT
OUT OF ONE STORES MEASURE AND
ESSENTIALLY BEATING HEAVILY TO
THAT PROGRAM GRAHAM IT PASS OUT
WITH A VERY STRONG SUPPORT I
THINK PRIMARILY BECAUSE MOST OF
THESE NEEDS WERE GENERATED BY
THE LOCAL COMMUNITY THIS WAS A
GROUND UP TYPE OF EVENT AND WHAT
WE'RE PREPARED NOW THE LEVERAGE
THOSE AGAINST YOU DOLLARS THE
STATE MIGHT PROVIDE LET ME TALK
ABOUT SOME OF THE LEVERAGING
WE HAD HAD A GOAL LINE IT WAS
MENTIONED EARLIER BY HAVE THE
THE THERE WAS THAT DISCUSSION
OF THE ROUGHLY THREE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS IN CONTRIBUTED
BUT IT'S AGAINST THE PROJECT
AT ONE POINT FOUR BILLION
DOLLARS WE ARE LEVERAGING MONEY
FROM THE STATE AID WITH LOCAL
DOLLARS IN ORDER TO GET THAT
PROJECT FULLER COULD HAVE THE
NEXT SLIDE PLEASE THE FIFTY
SEVEN SIXTY WAS MENTIONED ON
WE HAVEN'T PROVEN TO BE SEE
ON HERE COST OF THAT IS TWO
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY EIGHT POINT
SIX MILLION DOLLARS SP ONE IS
BEING TWENTY TWO MILLION DOLLARS
AGAIN THAT'S THAT DISCUSSION ON
HAVING HER IT'S A PARTNERSHIP
BETWEEN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
AND THE LOCAL CONSTITUENCY AND
CAL TRANS IN THIS CASE TO PUT
FORWARD AN ESSENTIAL PROJECT FOR
OUR ECONOMIC VITALITY BUT IT'S
ALSO A LEVERAGING OF THE DOLLARS
IT'S HOW WE'RE GOING FORWARD
THAT SEVENTY ONE FREEWAY WHICH
HAS BEEN MENTIONED SEVERAL TIMES
HERE AGAIN YOU'RE LOOKING AT
WHAT TO LOOK AT THE LEVERAGING
THE DOLLARS A HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLAR
PROJECT FORTY FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS IN SB ONE FINDS ITS
BEING CONTRIBUTED HAVE THE NEXT
SLIDE PLEASE AND THEN I WANTED
TO MENTION SOME OF OUR ALAMEDA
QUARTER PROJECTS COULD ADD
THE NEXT YEAR PLEASE HERE'S A
LEVERAGING EVER PROJECT OF A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY EIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS TO BUILD THE GRADE
SEPARATION -- IN THIS CITY OF
MONTEBELLO MONTEBELLO BOULEVARD
IN FORTY NINE MILLION AND THAT
WOULD BE COMING FROM AS IN ONE
AND THEN FINALLY WE GOT ONE
MORE WE HAVE ANOTHER PROJECT
THAT OF TURNBULL CANYON ANOTHER
GREAT SEPARATION ROUGHLY EIGHTY
SIX MILLION DOLLARS AND A
TWENTY MINUTE MILLION DOLLAR
CONTRIBUTION FROM SP ONE LINE
I THINK IF YOU GO OUT ON AMBER
MY THREE WORDS YOU GUYS WHEN
YOU GO OUT AND TALK TO THE
COMMUNITY WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT PARTNERSHIPS
THAT HAVE BEEN AFFECTED IN
THE PAST WE'VE PROVEN IN
AS STATE AND LOCAL COMMUNITIES
THAT WE CAN DELIVER IF THE IF
WE HAVE THE DOLLARS AVAILABLE
TO US PROPOSITION ONE BE WAS A
HUGE SUCCESSFUL PROGRAM AND WE
CAN DEMONSTRATE THAT IT'S DONE
ON WE DID THAT AND WE'RE GOING
TO DO IT AGAIN IF YOU GET THE
OPPORTUNITY AND F. AS SB ONCE
REVISED THE NOVEMBER ELECTION SO
THAT THANK YOU FOR TELLING TIME
THANK YOU WE APPRECIATE TO
MICHAEL MICHAEL WELCOME
WELCOME I WILL MOVE THROUGH
MY PRESENTATION QUICKLY -- I
ALSO HAVE A MILLENNIAL -- HE
HAS NEVER OWNED A CAR ANY GROUP
IN LA HE LIVES IN NEW YORK NOW
SUITE IS REALLY NEED ONE -- --
SO LET ME MOVE TO MIND QUICKLY
I'LL JUST SKIP OVER THE PARTS
FOR THAT -- PEOPLE OF ALREADY
COVERED AND HIGHLIGHT A COUPLE
OF THINGS I THINK EVERYBODY'S
TALKED ABOUT SP ONE PORTENT
-- ITS IMPORTANCE -- I THINK
THE IMPORTANT THING TO STRESS
HERE IS THE SPLIT LIKE THAT
OCCURRED WITH SP ONE BECAUSE A
LOT OF LOCAL IS A COMBINATION OF
LOCAL AND STATE FUNDING
THAT GOES TO THAT THAT IT IS
COMMITTED TO TRANSPORTATION
IT'S CONSTITUTIONALLY PROTECTED
ACTIVE -- AND THAT'S --
IMPORTANT PIECE OF THIS IT
CANNOT BE DIVERTED FOR ANY OTHER
PURPOSE THESE ARE THE KEY THINGS
THAT IT'S DOING IN LOS ANGELES
HELPING US DELIVER MEASURE AM
MEASURE AND RELIED ON STATE
FEDERAL FUNDS BEING AVAILABLE
-- WE WERE THANKFUL THAT SB
ONE CAME ALONG EARLIER IN THE
MEASURE AND PROGRAM -- TO HELP
WITH THAT IT'S ALSO HELPING
US TO ADDRESS THE TWENTY BY
TWENTY TWENTY EAST INITIATIVE
WHERE WE WANT TO HAVE TWENTY
PROJECTS DONE BY THE TIME THE
OLYMPICS START PART -- WE
ARE -- THERE'S BEEN MANAGEMENT
BECAUSE WE WOULD PROGRAM I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE
-- WE TALKED ABOUT OTHER PEOPLE
TALKED ABOUT PROP ONE BE IN TWO
THOUSAND SIX WHERE THERE IS A
ONE TIME INFUSION OF FUNDS FOR
-- FREE PROJECTS THIS IS IN
THE STATE'S FIRST TIME TO HAVE
AN ONGOING FUNDING COMMITMENT
TO GOODS MOVEMENT PROJECTS
AND SO THAT'S THAT'S A VERY
IMPORTANT ELEMENT OF -- SP
ONE WE KNOW THAT -- OBVIOUSLY
PROP SIX IS A THREAT RIGHT IF
-- PROP SIX PASSES THERE ARE A
LOT OF THE FUNDING MOST OF THE
FUNDING FOR THIS GOES AWAY THERE
SOME FUN SOURCES THAT HAVE --
SOME SOME OF SB ONE CATEGORIES
THAT HAVE OTHER FUNDS SOURCES
BUT -- THIS IS OBVIOUSLY A
SIGNIFICANT THREAT RIGHT WHAT
WHILE WE SAY IS THERE'S ONE OF
THREE THINGS THAT HAPPEN HOUSE
OF FUNDING GOES AWAY YOU EITHER
CUT THEIR SCOPE OF THE PROJECT
YOU DELAY THE PROJECT OR TO GIVE
YOU THE LEADER PROJECT SO ONE OF
THOSE THE THREE THINGS IS GOING
TO HAPPEN TO ALL OF THE PROJECTS
THAT COULD FUND THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT WIDE FOR US -- IN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY THERE ARE EIGHTY
EIGHT CITIES IN LOS ANGELES
COUNTY AS WELL AS THE COUNTY
INCORPORATED AREA THEY GET TWO
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY TWO MILLION
DOLLARS EVERY YEAR FOR LOCAL
STREET ROAD REPAIR PROJECTS THAT
IS HAPPENING DIRECT THAT GOES
DIRECTLY TO THE CITIES WE DON'T
TOUCH IT OR LET ANYTHING TO DO
WITH IT IT'S ALL OF THE CITY'S
DISCRETION -- AND IF AS THE PROP
SIX PASSES THE AMOUNT OF MONEY
TO THE CITIES WILL HAVE FIRST
LOCAL STREET ROAD REPAIR GETS
CUT IN HALF AS A SIGNIFICANT
THAT'S A SIGNIFICANT LOSS IS
HELPING -- WITH US OF THE BIG
KEY THING FOR US BECAUSE WE WANT
TO HELPING TO EXPAND TRANSIT
WE'VE TALKED ABOUT THE GOAL
LINE WE'RE ALSO TALKING ABOUT
A NEW RAIL PROJECT IT GOES FROM
DOWNTOWN INTO THE SOUTHEAST
PART OF THE COUNTY EXTENDING THE
GREEN LINE TORRANCE AND NEW RAIL
LINE IN THE SAN FERNANDO VALLEY
REXY BREAKING GROUND TOMORROW
OR ON SAFETY IMPROVEMENTS FOR
THE ORANGE LINE AND -- THE
SAN FERNANDO VALLEY AS WELL WELL
THESE ARE JUST AS IT IS JUST
A BREAKDOWN OF ERRORS FUNDING
CATEGORIES -- THAT'S THE TRANSIT
INTERCITY REAL CAPITAL PROGRAM
WHICH WAS ONE OF THE BIG TARGETS
FOR US -- THE NEXT
NEXT A POT HOLES I MENTION
CIVIC SKIP THROUGH THAT ONE
HIGHWAYS WITH TALKED A LOT ABOUT
THE HIGHWAYS A LOT OF SAFETY
IMPROVEMENTS WE DID AN EVENT
YESTERDAY WITH CAL TRANS WHERE
THEY ARE LEAST RIGHT BEING
A NUMBER FREEWAYS THROUGHOUT
LOS ANGELES COUNTY RESTRICTING
MIGHT SOUND BORING BUT IF YOU
HAVE A CAR THAT LOOKS AT THE
LANES OR IF YOU WANT TO HAVE
AUTONOMOUS VEHICLES NEEDS TO
SEE THE LATELY AND -- IF YOU'RE
DRIVING DOWN THE FREEWAY IN
SOME OF OUR OLDER FREEWAYS IT'S
KIND OF HARD TO SEE THE LANES
AND THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT
SAFETY PROJECT WE'VE TALKED
ABOUT SOME OF THESE PROJECTS
WE COULD JUST SKIP THROUGH THAT
FOR THE NEXT ONES WHEN I
MENTION FREIGHT RATE OF INTEREST
OF TIME WILL KEEP GOING ON
A CLEAN AIR IS OBVIOUSLY
IMPORTANT WE'VE TALKED ABOUT
THAT BEFORE THE INVESTMENTS IN
OUR TRANSIT SYSTEM ARE IMPORTANT
FOR THE REGIONAL BENEFITS US GAG
HAS THE -- SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITY
CATEGORY THROUGH THE REGIONAL
TRANSPORTATION PLAN AND THE END
OF THE REGION NEEDS ARE TRANSIT
-- THEIR QUALITY BENEFITS FROM
OUR TRANSIT INVESTMENTS TO ME
ARE REGIONAL AIR QUALITY GOES
GOALS OF THIS IS IN THE SP ONE
FUNDS ARE IMPORTANT -- ELEMENTAL
MAKING THAT HAPPEN HAPPEN THE
EXCELLENT LOCAL PARTNERSHIP
PROGRAM WE'VE TALKED ABOUT
THAT AND THEN -- THIS JUST THE
WEBSITE WE HAVE -- HAD A VERY
-- A PROACTIVE INFORMATIONAL
EFFORT GOING ON EVERYTHING
WE DO AND SAY IS THAT IT BY
OUR ATTORNEYS SO -- WE'VE
BEEN VERY ACTIVE IN GETTING
INFORMATION OUT TO TO PEOPLE
ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF THESE
INVESTMENTS OF WHERE THE MONEY
IS GOING AND EVERYTHING IS ON
OUR WEBSITE WITH THAT I WILL
CONCLUDE PLEASE THANK YOU THANK
YOU MICHAEL -- UNDER UNDER
GOOD MORNING THANK YOU CHAIR
HOLDEN FOR HAVING ME TODAY
IN A NICE TO BE HERE WITH
YOU ALSO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
REYES I'M I'M GONNA FOCUS
TODAY ON POTENTIAL IMPACTS OF
PROPOSITION SIX SPECIFIC IMPACTS
AND STAMINA DINO COUNTY AND
WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO BECAUSE
I'M NEVER DOING AN ANIMATED
SLIDE PRESENTATION AGAIN --
THE LARGEST IMPACT TIME WE'LL
SEE IS -- THE IMPACT ON THE
FORMULA ALLOCATIONS AND WITH
THE LARGEST IMPACT BEING THOSE
ALLOCATIONS TO GO DIRECTLY
TO THE CITIES IN THE COUNTY
FOR LOCAL STREETS AND ROADS
RE HAPPEN EIGHT MINUTES THIS
YEAR FOR EXAMINING OUT COUNTY
THAT'S ESTIMATED AT ABOUT
FIFTY NINE MILLION DOLLARS
AS ALSO TRANSIT AGENCIES ARE
EXPECTING TO SEE AN INCREASE
OF THIRTEEN MILLION DOLLARS
AND THIS IS COMING THROUGH THE
STABILISATION OF -- THAT STATE
TRANSIT ASSISTANCE FUND WHICH
HAS BEEN A HISTORICALLY VOLATILE
SOURCE FOR TRANSIT AND THE STATE
OF GOOD REPAIR PROGRAM WHICH
IS FOCUSED ON A MAINTAINING
THE EXISTING TRANSIT NETWORK
AND THEN FINALLY -- THE ONE
ONE FORMULA FOUND THAT SVC TA
RECEIVES BECAUSE OF OUR MEASURE
I TRANSPORTATION SALES TAXES
THE LOCAL PARTNERSHIP PROGRAM
I'M AND ALL THAT SEVENTY EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY WE
EXPECT TO RECEIVE AND IT'S
IMPORTANT TO REMEMBER THAT THIS
WILL GROW WITH TIME BECAUSE WE
HAVE DECIDED TO END ACCESS SALES
TAX -- THE GAS TAX FOR NOW
AND FISCAL YEAR SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN LOOKING SPECIFICALLY
AT WHAT WAS AVAILABLE TO THE
CITIES FOR LOCAL STREETS AND
ROADS AND THEY IDENTIFIED A
HUNDRED AND ONE PROJECTS FOR
IMPROVEMENT -- RECEIVED TWENTY
ONE MIGHT MILLION DOLLARS OF
COURSE THIS IS ONLY A PARTIAL
YEAR ALLOCATION BUT THAT WAS A
FIFTY PERCENT INCREASE IN THIS
-- GAS TAX FUNDING OVER THE SAME
PERIOD FOR THE LOCAL AGENCIES
-- IN THIS FISCAL YEAR THEY'VE
IDENTIFIED A HUNDRED ELEVEN
PROJECTS FOR IMPROVEMENT AND
IT'S IMPORTANT REMEMBER THAT A
LOT OF THESE PROJECTS ARE CITY
WIDE MAINTENANCE PROJECTS SO
MANY MORE ROADS WILL ACTUALLY BE
IMPACTED BY -- THIS FUNDING THAN
IT APPEARS I LIKE I SAID THERE'S
FIFTY NINE MILLION ESTIMATED
TO BE RECEIVED AND THAT'S A
SEVENTY SEVEN PERCENT INCREASE
-- OVER THAT OLD GAS TAX
I AM I YOU CAN JUST GO THROUGH
THESE REAL QUICKLY THESE OF
COURSE ARE THE COMPETITIVE
PROGRAMS THAT MANY PEOPLE HAVE
TALKED ABOUT THAT'S ABOUT A
BILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY AND
NEW REVENUE -- NEW OPPORTUNITIES
FOR TRADE FOR TRANSPORTATION
IMPROVEMENTS AND THAT ARE
COUNTY DID REALLY WELL IN THE
FIRST ROUND OF COMPETITION
-- WE RECEIVED THE AT LEAST
LEAST THREE HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
ONE MILLION DEPENDING ON HOW
THINGS GO WITH METROLINK SCORE
PROGRAM THAT THAT CAN BE UP
OVER FOUR HUNDRED MILLION IN
THESE COMPETITIVE PROGRAMS AND
THAT IS -- THAT FAR EXCEEDS OUR
SHARE OF WHAT WOULD TYPICALLY BE
OUR SHARE OF STATEWIDE FUNDING
SO WE'RE EXCITED ABOUT THE
FIRST ROUND OF COMPETITION --
WE HAPPEN TO BE AT THE RIGHT
PLACE AND THE RIGHT TIME WITH A
LOT OF OUR MAJOR PROJECTS WHERE
THEY FIT WELL IN THE CRITERIA
OF THESE PROGRAMS AND THEY
WERE READY FOR IMPLEMENTATION
JUST THOSE PROJECTS ALONE WERE
OVER AT TWO HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
MILLION YOU CAN DO ONE MORE TIME
TWENTY NINE PROJECTS THROUGHOUT
THE COUNTY RECEIVE FUNDING
AND THE SPURS COMPETITION
THAT WAY THAT TOTAL FOUR HUNDRED
AND SIXTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
WHEN YOU FACTOR IN THE FORMULA
ALLOCATIONS WE'VE MADE I STAFF
IT HAS BEEN A CTA WENT THROUGH
AN ASSIGNED AS LOW MEDIUM AND
HIGH RISK TO EACH OF THESE
PROJECTS THAT WERE AWARDED
FUNDING AND GREEN YOU CAN SEE
THE PROJECTS ARE CLASSIFIED
AS LOW RISK THESE PROJECTS
HAVE EITHER BEEN EXPRESSED AS
PRIORITIES BY THE STATE SUCH AS
THE -- DMU DIZZY MOUNTAINS EMAIL
CONVERSION PROJECT DOCTORAL
SPOKE ABOUT EARLIER -- OR IN
THE CASE OF OR A TEN EXPRESS
LANES PROJECT WE'VE ALREADY
AWARDED A CONTRACT A LOT OF
THE MONEY COMES FROM ACTUALLY
FROM A FEDERAL SOURCE OUT OF AN
SP ONE PROGRAM SO WE FEEL THAT
HE'S MEDIUM RISK PROJECT
-- WE'VE ASSIGNED A MEDIUM
RISK EITHER BECAUSE THEY'RE
PROGRAMMED ON THIS FISCAL YEAR
THEY'VE BEEN ALLOCATED FUNDS
BY THE STATE BUT THEY HAVEN'T
YET YET HAD A CONTRACT AWARDED
SO WE AREN'T REAL SECURE THAT
THOSE -- PROJECTS THE FUNDING
COULD STAY AROUND FOR THOSE
PROJECTS AND THEN HIGH RISK
PROJECTS ARE THOSE WITH THE
BULK OF FUNDING IS PROGRAMMED
AND THE OUTER YEARS SO WE
KNOW THE REVENUE HASN'T BEEN
COLLECTED YET YET FOR THOSE
PROJECTS AND THE OTHER ONE
TO GRADE SEPARATION HAS BEEN
MENTIONED SEVERAL TIMES TODAY
WE ASSIGN THAT AS A HIGH RISK
PROJECT JUST BECAUSE THE PROJECT
IS PROGRAMMED OUT IN LATER
YEARS AND IT'S COMING FROM
PROGRAM RIGHT NOW AND LATER
FOR STATE FUNDS FROM MUST BE
ONE THAT COULD BE BACK BACK
FILLED WITH FEDERAL THAT'S
OUR SIMON OF RESTAURANTS
FOR SAMITY NOW COUNTY
THANK YOU FOR THAT CAN I JUST
WANT TO ASK YOU REAL QUICK
QUESTIONS AND THEN I'LL TURN
TO SOME OF MEMBER RESEARCH
HE HAS ANY QUESTIONS FOR THE
PANEL AND THEN IF WE HAVE
ANY CARDS FOR A PUBLIC PUBLIC
-- QUESTIONS AND WE CAN
TAKE THOSE NOW BUT -- AS IT
RELATES TO THE IMPACT OF THE
GAS TAX ON SAN BERNARDINO
COUNTY POPULATION HOW WOULD
YOU DEFINE THAT -- AND THEN
THE OTHER PART OR THERE
ARE THEY DISPROPORTIONATELY
AFFECT ACTED SO THE IMPACT OF
THE GAS TAX ON SAN BERNARDINO
POPULATIONS AND WELL IT IS
A SIGNIFICANT INCREASE IN
FUNDING FOR -- FOR SAM
READY NOW COUNTY POPULATION
THE GAS TAX IS AN INTERESTING
THE DISTRIBUTION OF GAS TAXES AN
INTERESTING SUBJECT -- BECAUSE
IT IS DISTRIBUTED BY POPULATION
SOME OF OUR BECAUSE WE ARE
LOCATED IN AN AREA -- WITH
MAJOR FREEWAYS CROSSING THROUGH
-- THERE IS SOME CONCERN THAT
MAYBE WE'RE NOT GETTING A RETURN
TO SOURCE TYPES OF ALLOCATION
OUT OF THE GAS TAX BUT THIS IS
-- INCREASE IT IS A SIGNIFICANT
YOU KNOW AS AS IT SHOWS THEY'RE
EXPECTING TO RECEIVE SEVENTY
SEVEN PERCENT INCREASE IN THIS
FISCAL YEAR SO I'D SAY IT SAID
SIGNIFICANT IMPACT THE LOSS
OF THAT WOULD BE SIGNIFICANT
RICHARD SOME
JUST JUST TO GENERAL JONES
AND I DON'T KNOW WHO WOULD
WANT TO RESPOND TO IT BUT --
WHERE THERE WAS A CUT MICHAEL
TURNER WAS TALKING ABOUT THE
CLEAN AIR TALKING ABOUT CLEAN
THEIR MORE LECTURES BUSES OF
YOU I KNOW YOU'RE NOT TALKING
ABOUT SAN BERNARDINO COUNTY OF
BUT BUT CLEARLY IT'S SOMETHING
THAT -- COULD ALSO TRANSLATE
TO SAN BERNARDINO COUNTY
HOW HOW MUCH IMPORTANCE ARE
YOU GIVING TO THE CLEAN AIR
ACT -- OF SP ONE FUNDING
WELL IT'S IMPORTANT THAT THE
FORM OF WRITING REASONS --
FOR THE REGION WE ALL LIVE
UNDER THE SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITY
STRATEGIES AND THE REQUIREMENTS
OF THE REGIONAL TRANSPORTATION
PLAN TO REDUCE EMISSIONS AND
SO EACH COUNTY GOES ABOUT IT
THEIR OWN WAY -- OVERALL
THE THE REGION DOES RELY ON
INVESTMENTS FROM OUR TRANSIT TO
MEET ITS GOALS BECAUSE THEY DO
CONTRIBUTE SIGNIFICANTLY TO THE
TO THE REDUCTION SO THAT'S JUST
THE THAT'S JUST A BIG ELEMENT OF
THE OVERALL REDUCTIONS BUT THE
STRATEGIES FOR EACH COUNTY ON A
REALLY BOTTOMS UP AND THAT'S THE
WAY THE SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITIES
STRATEGY WAS STRUCTURED --
FOR US IN A LOS ANGELES COUNTY
INVESTMENTS IN TRANSIT ARE THE
MAIN WAYS WHERE WE'RE TREATING
THE EMISSIONS REDUCTIONS IN
OUR REGIONS SO THE SP ONE FUNDS
ARE CRITICAL TO THAT -- WE
HAVE A SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT
FROM OUR LOCAL SALES TAXES BUT
THOSE LOCAL SALES TAXES RELY
ON STATE AND FEDERAL FUNDS
-- IN ORDER TO BE IN ORDER TO
MEET THE FUNDING COMMITMENTS
SO IT'S A BIG ELEMENT OF IT
WITH RESPECT TO ELECTRIC BUSES
-- THE STATE IS -- SOON GOING
TO BE ADOPTING A RULE THAT
REQUIRES ALL TRANSIT AGENCIES TO
EVENTUALLY CONVERT TO ELECTRICAL
PROCESSES -- WE ARE BOARD IS
ALREADY ADOPTED A PLAN THAT
WOULD HAVE US CONVERT OUR ENTIRE
FLEET TO ZERO EMISSION BUSES
BY TWENTY THIRTY WE'RE ACTUALLY
GOING TO START RECEIVING
THE FIRST -- ONE HUNDRED AND
FIVE I BELIEVE OF THOSE BUSES
NEXT YEAR THERE ARE A LOT OF
CHALLENGES TO THAT BECAUSE
THE TECHNOLOGY IS STILL VERY
EXPENSIVE VEHICLES DON'T PROVIDE
A RANGE OF SERVICES WE NEED AT
THIS TIME AND I SHOULD NOTE THE
THE UTILITY ISSUES ASSOCIATED
WITH THAT ARE A SIGNIFICANT
CHALLENGE BECAUSE THE COST OF
THE CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE
NOT TO MENTION HOW MUCH WE'RE
GONNA END UP PAYING FOR LIKE
TRICITY IS GOING TO BE A BIG
CHALLENGE IN IN MAKING THAT
CONVERSION TO HOPE THAT ANSWERS
YOUR QUESTIONS THANK YOU
AND AND -- JOHN ON
NO WE'VE LOST TO TO TO
DISTRICT SEVEN ABOUT THE
QUESTION WOULD BE THE SAME NAME
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA IS FOR
EACH REGION FOR EACH COUNTY
WHAT SORT OF STEPS CAN BE
TAKEN TO BE SURE THAT WE HAVE
LOCAL CONTRACTORS GETTING
GETTING THOSE LOCAL JOBS AND
GIVING YOU THE THE DIDN'T
HIRING LOCAL PEOPLE WHERE I
THINK THE PRIMARY FOCUS WOULD
HAVE TO BE -- THE OUTREACH
EFFORTS SO MAKING SURE THAT
WE ARE HAVING PRE BID MEETINGS
-- WORKING WITH THE LOCAL
CONTRACTORS ENCOURAGING THEM
BECAUSE WE DO HAVE A STATE
CONTRACT ACT ACT -- THAT DOES
NOT ALLOW US TO SELECT LIKE
WITHIN A SPECIFIC COUNTY BUT
ENCOURAGING THEM TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY'RE OUT REACHING TO
SOME OF THE SMALL BUSINESSES
AN EXISTING CONTRACTORS --
WITHIN THE LIMITS OF THAT COUNTY
IS THERE ANYTHING YOU WOULD
NEED FROM THE STATE THAT
WOULD ALLOW A PARTICULAR COUNTY
THEN TO HELP HELP EIGHT DUE TO
TO TO TO GIVE PREFERENCE
TO LOCAL CONTRACTORS -- LIKE
I SAID WE HAVE THE STATE
CONTRACT ACT SO I DON'T
THINK IT'S REALLY ALLOWABLE
FOR US TO GIVE PREFERENCE
TO LOCAL CONTRACTORS BUT THE
OUTRAGE AND THE PRE PRE PRE
BID MEETING RECONSTRUCTION
MEETING PRE PRE BID MEETINGS
HAS PREPARED MEETINGS -- IS ONE
AVENUE -- WE ALSO HAVE A SMALL
SMALL STATEWIDE SMALL BUSINESS
COUNCIL -- OF THAT WE ARE
ACTIVE IN AND WE MEET --
I THINK SIX TIMES A YEAR HERE
TO ARE TRYING TO ENCOURAGE THE
SMALL BUSINESSES TO GET OUT
AND WITH THEIR CONSTITUENTS
AND EXPRESSED TO THEM THAT
NEED FOR FOR THE AVAILABILITY
OF FUNDING FOR THE INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTS THANK YOU
THANK YOU WE HAVE NO
QUESTIONS FROM FROM THE PUBLIC
SO I THINK THAT SOME OF
MEMBER THAT WOULD BE THE LAST
QUESTION FOR PANEL TODAY AND I
DO APPRECIATE IT CERTAINLY ALL
OF YOU WHO HAVE PARTICIPATED --
ENSURING THE INFORMATION WITH US
LAW I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT NOTE
THE SELECT COMMITTEE HEARINGS
ARE ARE VALUABLE I THINK NOT
ONLY FOR THE COMMUNITIES IN
WHICH WE HOLD THEM BUT THEY ARE
VERY IMPORTANT FOR THE MEMBERS
BECAUSE WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
TO HEAR FROM THE PUBLIC WE
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY HERE FROM
EXPERTS AND ALSO TO SEE
HOW THE DECISIONS IMPACT VERY
SPECIFICALLY TO COMMUNITIES THAT
WE REPRESENT AND SO FOR MANY
OF THE ALL ALL PROFESSIONALS
WHO PRESENTED THEMSELVES
TODAY IT REALLY GIVES US AN
OPPORTUNITY TO BE INTIMATE WITH
THE IMPACTS OF OUR DECISIONS
AND THE AND ALSO TO HEAR HOW
WE CAN BE MORE EFFECTIVE IN
DOING OUR JOB I REMEMBER A
COUPLE OF YEARS AGO AS WE HELD
THE SIZE OF HEARINGS IN THE
COMMUNITIES OF THE SANGAMON
VALLEY THE COMMENTS CAME BACK
LOCAL GOVERNMENT DID NOT HAVE
THE RESOURCES THAT IT NEEDED TO
-- TO DO DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
PROJECTS AND SO OUT OF THAT --
IT IN INFORMED US TO THE POINT
WHERE WE COULD GO BACK ON YOUR
PART OF A CONVERSATION AND HELP
STRUCTURE AND AND RESTAURANTS
REMEMBER THAT SP ONE WAS VERY
DIFFICULT AND COMING TOGETHER
I MEAN IT TOOK A COUPLE OF
SESSIONS BEFORE WE WERE ABLE TO
FINALLY COME UP WITH A PROPOSAL
IN WHICH THE LEGISLATURE COULD
COULD GET GARNER BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT OR AND MOVE FORWARD
AND SO WE FIND OURSELVES AT A
POINT NOW WHERE OBVIOUSLY OF
THOSE FUNDS ARE IN JEOPARDY
BUT I DO BELIEVE THE THE MORE
INFORMATION THAT THE PUBLIC
KNOWS ABOUT PROJECTS THAT
IMPACT ON THEIR COMMUNITY
I THINK THAT THEY WILL SEE
THE VALUE AND -- CONTINUE TO
MOVE FORWARD -- I THINK IT'S
ALSO IMPORTANT TO KNOW THAT
AND WE CAN BOTH BUT ALL OF US
HAVE TAKEN NOTE TO THE VARIOUS
COMMENTS THAT HAS BEEN PRESENTED
TO US AND I KNOW THAT THERE
WAS AN EARLIER PRESENTATIONS
A REFERENCE TO SEEK REFORM AND
ALSO -- FINDING SOME WAY AVENUE
TO BRING BACK REDEVELOPMENT
OR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS BECAUSE
IT HAS IT WAS A VALUABLE
TOOL AND IT CAN BE AGAIN --
WE TRIED THIS YEAR -- WE
WERE HOPING THAT AS GOVERNOR
BROWN WAS FINISHING HIS LAST
TERM GOOD -- -- HE WOULD KINDA
LOSE THAT'LL GRINCH THE STOLE
CHRISTMAS -- ATTITUDE AROUND
REDEVELOPMENT AND MAYBE EMBRACES
-- ANOTHER SHOT AT IT BUT IT
WAS CLEAR THAT THAT WAS NOT
GOING TO HAPPEN AND I DON'T
MEAN THAT AS A CRITICISM OF THE
GOVERNOR BECAUSE HE'S DONE A
FANTASTIC JOB AND AND HE STANDS
BEHIND US IF YOU WANT IT IS
GOING TO BE CONTINUING TO STAND
FOR ON MANY INITIATIVES THAT
ARE OR ARE PROVEN TO BE VERY
BENEFICIAL TO THE STATES OR
PROCEDURES LEADERSHIP BUT BUT
I THINK THAT IT'S VERY CLEAR
THAT HAVING SOME TYPE OF A
RE LOOK AT REDEVELOPMENT HOW
THAT CAN BE STRUCTURES FOR TO
HELP COMMUNITIES WILL BE VERY
ESSENTIAL ESPECIALLY AS YOU SEE
THESE REGIONAL TRANSPORTATION
SYSTEMS SYSTEMS MAKE THEIR
WAY THROUGH THE VARIOUS
COMMUNITIES AND IT WILL BRING
LIKE IT DID IN MY COMMUNITY
MY CITY OF PASADENA THAT I
SERVED ON THE CITY COUNCIL ON
IT BROUGHT -- TRANSIT ORIENTED
DEVELOPMENT HOUSING IN THE
DOWNTOWN IT SPURRED ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT FOR THE RETAIL
CORRIDOR OPACITY IN IT WOULD
NOT BE WHAT IT IS TODAY IF IT
WERE NOT INVESTMENT OF PARKING
STRUCTURES BUT ALSO -- HOW
THE LIGHT RAIL HAS PROVIDED AN
INCENTIVE IN AN ECONOMIC BOOST
TO THAT PARTICULAR CITY CITY
SO THE SAME TYPE OF CITIZEN
OPPORTUNITIES EXIST US FOR
OTHER PARTS OF THE REGION AND
LASTLY LET ME JUST SAY HOW I
REPRESENT A SMALL PART OF SAN
BENITO COUNTY UP ONE AND A
PORTION OF THE NORTHWEST PART
OF RANCHO CUCAMONGA AND I'M
VERY EXCITED ABOUT THE FUTURE
OF THE INLAND EMPIRE OF YOU
HAVE GREAT LEADERSHIP -- FROM
ELOISE REYES AND FROM CONNIE
LEYVA BUT THERE ARE A HOST OF
OTHER MEMBERS WHO ARE HERE TODAY
WHO SERVE ON AND WHEN EMPIRE
CAUCUSES AND THERE IS CONTINUOUS
DISCUSSION FOCUSES ON ALL OF
THESE ISSUES AND HOW WE CAN
CONTINUE TO DESIGN -- STRATEGIES
OF SACRAMENTO THAT -- BILL
TO AWAY LOCAL CONTROL BUT
LOOK TO ENHANCE AND TO CREATE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR LOCAL CONTROL
TO BE EVEN STRONGER AND MORE
VITAL SO I'M HAPPY TO
BE HERE TODAY I LEARNED A LOT
-- THIS WAS THIS WAS PODCAST
YEAH SO OTHERS SO WE HAD HAD
-- AUDIENCES THOUSANDS THAT
WE'RE HERE TODAY BUT THEY WERE
WATCHING AND SO WE APPRECIATE
THAT THE OPPORTUNITY TO GET
THE MESSAGE OUT THAT WAY --
LET ME ALSO THIS THANK MY STAFF
BECAUSE THAT CERTAINLY PUTTING
THESE TYPE OF EVENTS ON ON --
IT REQUIRES A LOT OF OF FOCUSED
PLANNING AND AND AND ENERGY SO
I'D LIKE TO THANK OUR STUFF --
COLLECTIVELY BUT LIKE TO THINK
BOBBY JOHNSON WHO SYSTEM I LEFT
-- AND MY DISTRICT STAFF FOR
THEIR -- CONTINUOUS HARD WORK
AND THEY'RE THEY'RE FOCUSED
ON MAKING SURE THAT THIS IS
-- HEARING -- WAS STRUCTURED
RIGHT AND IT WOULD BE ABLE TO
GET THE PROPER INFORMATION OUT
TO THE COMMUNITY SO APPRECIATE
THAT -- I ALSO HAVE AN ADVISORY
COMMITTEE OF -- COMMUNITY
MEMBERS THAT HELP ME FOCUS ON
A VARIETY OF ISSUES AND WE HAD
FOUR OF OUR -- COUNCILMEMBERS
OR ADVISING MEMBERS HERE TODAY
-- OTIS GREER PAUL HEALER WHO
IS ALSO ASSOCIATED WITH AIDS
PROJECT LISA LEVY BUSHINGS ALSO
WAS COLD LINE AND -- BOB WAGNER
-- WE'RE HERE TODAY SO I WANTED
TO THANK THEM FOR -- FOR THEIR
PARTICIPATION IN THEIR HELP HOME
IN TERMS OF HELPING TO SHAPE
THIS AND SO -- WITHOUT ALL TURN
TO MY COLLEAGUE FOR ANY CLOSING
COMMENTS YOU MAY HAVE AND THEY
WILL I JUST WANT TO THANK THE
CHAIR ASSEMBLY MEMBER HOLDEN FOR
COMING TO RANCHO CUCAMONGA IS
A LOT CLOSER THAN GOING ALL THE
WAY TO YOUR AREA AND I'M SO GLAD
THE EMPHASIS ON SAN BERNARDINO
COUNTY -- WE HAVE GREAT LEADERS
WHO REPRESENT DIFFERENT ASPECTS
OF SAN BERNARDINO COUNTY -- AND
THE REASON THAT WE ARE GROWING
AT THE RATE WE'RE GROWING IS
BECAUSE WE HAVE SUCH GREAT
LEADERS WHO ARE COMMITTED
AND I THINK THAT WHEN WE ALL
WORK TOGETHER THAT'S WHEN THE
COMMUNITY -- WILL MOVE IN THE
DIRECTION THE TRAJECTORY FOR
OUR COMMUNITY IS SO MUCH BETTER
THAN WHAT IT WOULD HAVE BEEN
OTHERWISE SP ONE HAS PROVIDED
OPPORTUNITIES FOR ME IT'S
SUCH AN TO A PLEASURE TO
VISIT WITH MY VARIOUS CITIES
AND REMIND THEM THAT THEY'RE
GETTING CHECKS EVERY SINGLE
MONTH MONTH FROM IS THE ONE ONE
IT IS A ONE TIME THING EVERY
SINGLE MONTH ONE EIGHTY DOLLAR
AMOUNT IS BEING DEPOSITED FOR
EACH OF OUR CITIES EACH OF OUR
COUNTY AND I HAVE CHECKED IN
WITH ALL OF MY CITIES TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY KNOW THAT IS SB
ONE MONEY AND THEY ALL TELL ME
YES WE DO KNOW BECAUSE WE SEE
THE DIFFERENCE AND WERE ABLE
TO BEGIN NEW PROJECTS WITH OUR
SP ONE MONEY AND THE COMMUNITY
AS A WHOLE IS BENEFITING
AGAIN YEAH -- CHAIR HOLDEN
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
CONVENING THIS SELECT COMMITTEE
AND THANK YOU TO ALL OF OUR
SPEAKERS ALL OF OUR PRESENTERS
FOR PROVIDING SUCH GREAT
INSIGHT THANK YOU THANK YOU
AND WITH THAT WE ARE ADHOURNED